du président Pierre Henriet qui me
délègue ses pouvoirs l'espace d'un
instant
je voudrais en votre nom et toute
particulièrement au nom des
parlementaires ici présents
remercier le président Gérard Larcher
d'avoir accepté
d'ouvrir cette manifestation qui qui
commémore les 40 ans du de l'office
parlementaire de l'évaluation des choix
scientifiques et technologiques et qui
nous permet à cette occasion à la fois
de mieux faire comprendre ce que nous
avons fait pourquoi nous l'avons fait
comment nous l'avons fait et finalement
pourquoi ça marche pas trop mal depuis
40 ans
et réfléchir à cette occasion à ces deux
journées consacrées à l'Assemblée
nationale et au Sénat au fonctionnement
de l'office et à sa vocation réfléchir à
ce que nous pourrions faire de mieux
alors
c'est le président cher Gérard il faut
que tu saches que tu as devant toi outre
naturellement les parlementaires les
plus assidus à l'office et je les
remercie de leur présence il y a un
bataillon il y a une phalange
indéfectible dans nos travaux qui est en
moyenne supérieure je le crois
au pourcentage obtenu
qui ne revêtent pas un caractère
obligatoire des gens passionnés qui ont
un prix à se connaître à travailler
ensemble avec la diversité de leur
formation de leur convictions mais qui
arrive à produire des travaux qui sont
toujours paritaires je veux dire par là
qui est associé toujours un député et un
sénateur
aujourd'hui nous allons travailler sur
un thème original les controverses
scientifiques pour essayer d'évaluer
rappeler comment elle se présente
comment elles sont animées et parfois
comment elles sont tranchées ce qui est
d'ailleurs jamais une décision
définitive hier nous avons travaillé sur
la science et la politique avec des
interventions de très haut niveau dans
la salle Victor Hugo ce qui est une ce
qui est un grand sénateur Victor Hugo
l'Assemblée nationale lui a rendu
hommage on lui donnant une grande salle
c'est très bien
et on a travaillé également sur
technologie et Parlement c'est beaucoup
plus concret parce qu'au fond si la
science nous ouvre des perspectives et
des horizons la technologie à l'avantage
de s'engager plus directement sur les
décisions d'investir de créer de
réaliser ou de soutenir et par
conséquent passionne plus directement
nos parlementaires députés et sénateurs
qui retrouvent la présence de la
technologie dans les activités
économiques de leur département ou de
leur circonscriptions respectives ce qui
les motivent puissamment pour essayer
d'en comprendre l'évolution
voilà je voulais te dire que nous sommes
très heureux que tu
participes à cette ouverture et c'est
une garantie pour la qualité de nos
travaux parce qu'après tout quand on est
connu et reconnu on a envie de mériter
cette connaissance et cette
reconnaissance merci monsieur le
président
monsieur le Président de l'Office
parlementaire d'évaluation des choix
scientifiques et technologiques sur
pierre Henriet monsieur le Premier
vice-président
de cette office parlementaire cher
Gérard Longuet merci merci pour vos mots
monsieur le Président Longuet je vois
avec plaisir des anciens présidents de
l'Office parlementaire d'évaluation des
choix scientifiques et technologiques je
vois Henri Revol pardonnez-moi de le
dire avec bonheur je veux voir Jean-Yves
le déo qui comme Victor Hugo avait une
fonction quasiment inéternable je
rappelle que Victor Hugo était
sénateur il m'a inamovible fonction trop
tôt disparue c'est ce que je pense car
une fois élue on l'était inéternable
et je voudrais saluer aussi le président
qui a été Cédric Villani pendant
salué parce que je me souviens de nos
échanges ces moments là every nocido qui
m'a prié de l'excuser qui ne peut pas
être là j'aurais saluer les membres
actuels et anciens de l'Office les
membres du conseil scientifique de
l'Office celui des académiciens qui sont
présents et les responsables des grands
organismes de recherche et vous tous
c'est bien sûr mes collègues sédataires
dont vous avez dit que l'assiduité dans
la liberté ils n'ont pas l'article 23
bises du Règlement du Sénat était une
forme d'hommage à leur activité oui
c'est pour moi un plaisir de célébrer
avec vous nous en avions convenu
ensemble et deux présidents au Sénat le
40e anniversaire de l'office
parlementaire de d'évaluation des choix
scientifiques et technologiques
c'est la loi du 8 juillet 1983 je sais
que vous l'avez rappelé hier
après un vote unanime de chaque
assemblée
qui a créé cette structure
j'allais dire originale
utile efficace
l'intuition de nos prédécesseurs était
aussi simple que pertinente doter les
deux chambres du Parlement d'un
organisme commun chargé de l'informer
sur les conséquences des grands choix
scientifiques et technologiques
d'éclairer la décision parlementaire
lors des travaux préparatoires on
évoquait
quelques grands sujets qui me paraissent
rester d'actualité
le spatial
on a assisté hier soir au dernier
lancement d'Ariane on est dans
l'actualité
le nucléaire et ses déchets on vient
de débattre et d'adopter une loi
d'accélération en matière notamment
d'énergie nucléaire la génétique j'y
reviendrai
hier une décision de la Commission
européenne
l'informatique la rebatique la
microlecteur tronic c'était les sujets
de 1983
nombre égal de députés de sénateurs une
présidence tournante
entre Assemblée nationale et Sénat une
vraie structure
bicamérale a lieu intéressant de
fabrique de consensus la citation des
pas de Victor Hugo mais Jean-Yves le déo
c'est la force incontournable des
rapports de l'office de pouvoir
s'appuyer sur ce travail approfondi et
commun
entre députés et sénateurs et sur une
adoption de ces rapports
250 depuis le début de son existence
malgré les vicissitudes de la vie
politique à quel caractère parfois
délicat parfois brûlant polémique des
sujets traités l'Office n'a jamais calé
devant l'adoption d'un rapport même s'il
a fallu parfois aller dans la discussion
assez loin pour rechercher le compromis
c'est catheries progacia qui pourraient
en parler plus longuement
sur de nombreux sujets abordés comme par
exemple
celui des nouvelles techniques de
sélection végétale
sujets d'actualité avec la proposition
formulée hier par la Commission
européenne
l'originalité de l'office est aussi la
présence de ce conseil scientifique
24 personnalités représentatives d'un
large éventail de discipline
scientifique et technologique ce conseil
fournit une expertise précieuse à
l'office
autre originalité les modalités de
travail de l'office
première bien sûr celle des études sur
saisine soit par le bureau soit par une
commission permanente de l'Assemblée
nationale du Sénat et de souvenir
président de la commission des affaires
économiques souvenez-vous que c'était le
moment on annonçait que tout ce qui se
passait en matière téléphonique et
d'onde allait absolument détruire le
monde et bien j'ai confié à l'office le
choix de cette réflexion
hier pour marquer l'importance que le
sida accord de travail de l'Office le
bureau a décidé
conjointement avec celui de l'Assemblée
nationale de saisir le fils
d'une évaluation des nouveaux
développements d'intelligence
artificielle la technologie en la
matière avance en effet
particulièrement vite
le grand public peut le constater avec
les sortes des dernières solutions
d'intelligence
artificielle et tout le monde a en tête
le chat GPT
au-delà des rapports sur ces îles le
pèche qui a par la suite l'énergie ces
modalités de travail en organisant des
auditions publiques d'actualité
ces auditions contradictoires sur des
sujets scientifiques parfois
controversés souvent complexes ont
permis d'éclairer le travail
parlementaire sur des thèmes aussi
variés que les OGM les compteurs
communiquent quand la politique
vaccinale d'expérimentation animale
l'usage d'algorithme dans certaines
politiques publiques elles sont
d'ailleurs réinterrogées en matière de
logement actuellement on est dans une
actualité que les maires connaissent
bien par rapport à l'algorithme
et encore
paraît-il une audition électrique qui a
été la question des soudures de l'EPR de
flamants villes si j'en crois mon
service de renseignement cher Gérard
Longuet outre
leur caractère éclairant approfondie et
contradictoires ces auditions publiques
ont deux particularités pour moi elle
donne lieu à l'adoption de conclusion
souvent assorti de recommandations et
l'autre particularité plus récente de
ces auditions et que chacune de ces
auditions est ouverte aux questions des
internautes
et qui en direct peuvent interroger les
intervenants lorsque les questions sont
très nombreuses bien sûr toutes ne
peuvent pas être posées pendant
l'audition
c'est la marque d'un office vraiment
l'écoute du grand public non seulement
carrefour de la science et du Parlement
mais aussi de la science et de la
société j'y reviendrai dans un instant
autre modalité du travail de l'Office
les notes scientifiques
ce nouveau format des travaux de
l'office est une initiative de Cédric
Villani et Gérard Longuet ensemble
au rite d'une dizaine par an c'est notre
explorent des sujets très divers souvent
en lien avec nos travaux parlementaires
un format court et synthétique quatre
pages qu'elles peuvent s'ajouter
d'autres et références je crois que
c'est vraiment une réussite
je ne peux pas toutes les citer mais je
pense aux notes sur le stockage de
l'électricité chargée en anglais sur les
technologies quantiques sur les enjeux
sanitaires et environnementaux je pense
à l'huile de palme vaste débat
à la phagothérapie
au mode de production d'hydrogène à la
pollution lumineuse
recyclage notamment des plastiques
le fils est également chargé par la loi
de l'évaluation de certaines
législations ou politiques publiques je
pense aux lois de bioéthique sur lequel
le travail de l'Office a toujours été
fondamental pour faire l'état des lieux
de la recherche ou naturellement j'y
reviens au domaine nucléaire avec deux
points d'intérêt particulier le contrôle
de la sûreté
et la gestion des déchets radioactifs
j'en profite pour dire que le contrôle
de la sûreté fait partir des
responsabilités qu'un président du Sénat
exercé dans le choix des membres
notamment du collège de l'Autorité de
Sûreté Nucléaire
dans le contexte actuel de renouveau du
programme nucléaire l'Office à fort de
son expérience et de son autorité me
semble-t-il un rôle éminent à jouer le
rapport qui doit rendre très bientôt sur
la réforme envisagée de la Sûreté
Nucléaire me paraît très attendu et en
tous les cas les pour nous tout à fait
essentiel pour éviter j'allais dire de
faire des fautes de car des excès
j'allais dire de rapidité et de regarder
les choses me semble-t-il avec la
sérénité nécessaire
il est difficile de citer tous les
travaux de l'Office mais encore plus de
mentionner tous les collègues députés et
signateurs qui ont participé mais je
peux saluer l'engagement de tous dans
chacun des rapports note de l’office
fruit de très nombreuses heures
d'auditions déplacements sur le terrain
de visite de laboratoire de rencontre
avec des scientifiques y compris des
scientifiques étrangers je crois que
c'est vraiment précieux pour le
Parlement avant
de vous laisser entamer cette matinée de
travail je voudrais souligner l'intérêt
de la manière dont vous avez décidé de
l'organiser aujourd'hui vous avez tenu à
consulter le public en évitant
sélectionner quatre thèmes que vous
allez aborder ce matin c'est une
habitude aussi que nous avons prise au
Sénat consulter le public ou les élus
locaux sur un certain nombre de nos
travaux
l'Office à cette pratique c'est à mon
avis
utile
utile essentiel pour créer aussi un lien
supplémentaire entre nous les
parlementaires et ceux que nous
représentons vous allez donc travailler
pour cette seconde journée
sur quatre thèmes peut-on satisfaire nos
besoins énergétiques avec les énergies
renouvelables
réduire l'usage des produits
phytosanitaires agricoles et se mettre
en trangés la production alimentaire
interrogation peut-on capter stocker
davantage de CO2 enfin l'intelligence
artificielle est-elle une menace vous
répondrez pas à tous ce matin puisque
vous venez d'être saisi par le bureau
des deux assemblées et j'ai d'ailleurs
noté hier dans le bureau du Sénat
puisqu'il avait lieu hier matin et que
je l'ai présidé l'intervention de
collègues je pense notamment aux
vice-président Pierre Laurent qui nous a
dit l'importance pour lui de cette
saisie
je souhaite vraiment devant vous chers
collègues salués le premier
vice-président Gérard Longuet le
remercier pour tout le travail accompli
en tant que parlementaire bien sûr en
tant que ministre ça ne me revient pas
mais je voudrais aussi saluer son
engagement communiste et j'ai eu
l'occasion de le faire en séance mais je
voudrais saluer son travail comme
premier vice-président de l'Office
je sais votre engagement sur les
questions relatives sur le site au
nucléaire la production de la gestion de
déchets je n'oublie pas les propos
prophétiques que je voudrais rappeler
ici et le côté prophète de Gérard
Longuet et de moi-même est assumé
au sens de Gibran peut-être mais en tous
les cas ce que je voulais dire
souvenez-vous il y a eu un projet de loi
en 2015 qui proposait la réduction
sans études préalable sans études
d'impact à 50% de la part du nucléaire
dans la production d'électricité à
l'horizon de l'année prochaine
vous aviez déclaré que pour atteindre
cet objectif la France serait contrainte
de remettre en activité ce qui lui
restait de centrale à charbon vous êtes
pas totalement trompé puisque nous avons
réouvert Saint-Avold et quand tous les
cas vous avez posé certains nombre de
questions dont on redémarre aujourd'hui
je pense que les ministres ont toujours
comme les parlementaires intérêts à
fonder leur position sur la science et
la technologie plutôt que sur les
arrangements de coalition politique
merci cher Gérard Longuet d'avoir été
notre vigie à cette occasion vraiment
merci pour cet engagement je voudrais le
dire au nom du Sénat tout entier il
associer vos prédécesseurs je dois dire
que pendant ces années vous avez été
pour nous une vraie référence chergara
longuet
[Applaudissements]
donc
très bon anniversaire mais dernier mot
il mettrait personnel
en ces temps où la défiance envers la
science
les pratiques ésotériques
un certain nombre de discours
obscurantistes et des raccourcis pseudo
scientifiques me paraissent de plus en
plus répandue il me semble que le rôle
de l'Office parlementaire d'évaluation
des choix scientifiques et techniques
n'en est que plus essentiel
pour éclairer non seulement mais
parlementaires mais aussi des médias à
la société tout entière pour rappeler à
tous la complexité des sciences et des
technologies face à une pensée
parfois simplificatrice du coup de
baguette magique je formule donc le vœu
que l'Office poursuivre son travail
indéniablement d'intérêt général au
service de la science de la société et
du Parlement je crois que nous en avons
besoin encore plus que jamais et ceci me
paraît tout à fait essentiel très bon
anniversaire
[Applaudissements]
je vais lancer les quatre controverses
de ce matin nous sommes tenus par la le
temps et par la qualité des intervenants
ici présents et j'imagine par la volonté
de tous ceux qui ont plus libérer de
participer au débat alors nous avons des
controverses vraiment c'est l'idée de
l'opinion différentes avec la nécessité
malgré tout de trouver une position qui
puisse fédérer une action collective
nationale c'est le rôle du Parlement
première controverse peut-on satisfaire
nos besoins énergétiques avec les
énergies renouvelables alors la question
est prudente et malicieuse car il n'est
pas dit peut-on satisfaire nos besoins
énergétiques avec les seules énergies
renouvelables mais nous avons deux
témoins qui vont voir s'exprimer et
animer cette controverse ma part je
serai silencieux bien je dois
théoriquement l'ouvrir pourquoi parce
que vous avez vous connaissez mon point
de vue et vous avez déjà bien plus
compétent je ne le serai jamais sur ce
sujet puisque nous avons David Marchal
qui est directeur exécutif adjoint
expertise et programme de l'ADEME je le
cherche du regard il est devant moi
c'est parfait et Madame Valérie fodon
délégué général de la Société française
de l'énergie nucléaire dont nous
connaissons tous l'engagement et la
combativité
combativité qu'il n'exclut pas
l'ouverture et le partenariat c'est
d'ailleurs l'esprit de l'Office
Parlementaire la deuxième controverse
alors là est passionnante pour les
sénateurs ruraux comme je le suis j'ai
pas l'air comme ça mais je suis un rural
et un paysan et c'est réduire l'usage
des produits phytosanitaires agricoles
et se mettre en danger la production
alimentaire j'ai plutôt tendance à
penser que oui mais je m'effacerai pour
écouter l'ouverture que présentera
Jean-Yves le déo qui est ancien
président de l'office et dans la
compétence est universellement reconnu
et il partagera cette intervention avec
Christian huygues qui est directeur
scientifique de l'inrae et Madame
Valérie chancigneau qui est historienne
des sciences et de l'environnement ce
qui est absolument passionnant pour
connaître et comprendre l'attitude de
des opinions et nous sommes élus par des
gens qui ont des opinions des opinions
sur ce sujet je vous annonce une pause
extra
d'autant plus courte que je parlerai
longuement donc je parlerai brièvement
et nous attaquerons la troisième
controverse qui est
une controverse assez prometteuse
peut-on capter stocker davantage de CO2
ce qui serait une réponse et nous avons
deux le sujet sera initié par Madame
Catherine procacia
qui est vice-président de l'Office et
qui a surtout porté à titre personnel
des combats homériques pour le chlore
déconne voilà par contre
et pour en expliquer les dangers les
inconvénients elle animera une
controverse qui est portée par Thierry
caquet directeur scientifique et
environnement à l'inrae je cherche il
est là et Madame Cécile Barrère Trika
qui elle est directrice à l'Institut
français du pétrole et de l'énergie
nouvelle
elle va arriver
et nous aurons enfin
autour de midi la quatrième controverse
qui sera évidemment
soumise
un public tenez par la fin et par la
fatigue mais le sujet est majeur c'est
l'intelligence artificielle est-elle une
menace cette controverse a présenté par
notre président soi-même pierre-henriet
que je salue je remercie de sa présence
et surtout de son implication moi qui
adore le Parlement je suis vraiment très
heureux que ce soit jeune député qui
reprennent en main l'office et qu'il est
animé avec autant de bon sens et
dynamistes alors deux intervenants sera
déjà châtilhac et professeur de
robotique et d'intelligence artificielle
membre du conseil scientifique de
l'Office oui parce que on sait pas tout
alors on a heureusement un conseil
scientifique je cherche monsieur Chatila
il arrive il arrive il arrive en même
temps voilà et il y aura madame Laurence
Devillers qui est professeur
d'informatique appliquée aux sciences
sociales
et elle arrive aussi alors on va
commencer tout de suite par la première
controverse si vous voulez bien et pour
ouvrir
ce n'est pas courtois mais on va comme
le problème est posé à partir des
énergies renouvelables que Gérard David
Marchal nous présente le point de vue de
l'ADEME dont on peut penser qu'elle est
structurellement proche des énergies
renouvelables puissent nous dire comment
l'agence voit le rôle et je gif
principal subsidiaire des énergies
renouvelables en matière de production
et je vous donne la parole
Messieurs les Présidents
mesdames et messieurs merci beaucoup
d'avoir invité l'ADEME pour cette
cet anniversaire de de l'OPEX auquel on
participe effectivement régulièrement
et merci de me donner la parole alors
l'ADM l'agence de la transition
écologique a effectivement dans ces
missions le fait de lever les freins au
déploiement des énergies renouvelables
levez les freins au déploiement des
énergies renouvelables ça veut dire
éclairer tous les débats autour de ces
énergies qui comme toutes les activités
humaines ont des impacts présents des
opportunités alors quand on dit
lever les freins ça veut dire qu'on
on assure notre rôle d'agence
d'expertise sur ce sujet comme sur les
autres une agence d'expertise et de
financement l'ADEME qui donc tire son
expertise en partie des projets qu'elle
finance on est un opérateur qui finance
la R&D sur ce sujet comme comme sur
d'autres financement de thèse et suivi
de projets de R&D qui nous permettent
d'être au fait des dernières avancées
qu'elles soient technologiques ou
sociales
on ne perd un certain nombre
d'études qui visent à qualifier ces
énergies que ce soit des études
économiques des études sur les impacts
environnementaux des études sur
l'insertion des énergies renouvelables
dans les mixes énergétiques des études
de potentiel
toutes ces études là sont publiques et
puis on est également en contact avec le
terrain puisqu'on est également
financeur du déploiement d'un certain
nombre de ces énergies renouvelables au
titre notamment du fond chaleur qui nous
permet de et du fond de décarbonation de
l'industrie depuis quelques années qui
nous permet de en finançant ces projets
que ce soit de chaleur renouvelable de
décarbonation de l'industrie l'être au
contact du terrain et de voir aussi les
difficultés et les opportunités qu'elles
peuvent représenter
ceci étant dit donc sur le rôle de
l'ADEME
rappelons juste un instant le contexte
notre la question posée sur notre
approvisionnement énergétique déjà doit
interroger la situation actuelle et ce
que nous consommons aujourd'hui nous
consommons environ 1600 en
terrawattheure d'énergie finale en
France en 2021
et cette énergie elle est on peut on
peut la compatibilité
de différentes façons à la fois par
source cette énergie elle est
aujourd'hui essentiellement fossile 60%
de l'énergie qu'on consomme et fossiles
20% nucléaires et 20% renouvelable on
arrive à 100%. cette énergie elle est
aussi
répartie selon différents vecteurs
environ 27% de cette énergie c'est de
l'électricité 23% du gaz et le reste
c'est donc du pétrole en gros et cette
énergie elle est également consommée par
différents secteurs et on peut
approximer que globalement quasiment la
moitié de cette énergie est consommée
par le bâtiment tertiaire ou résidentiel
principalement sous forme de chauffage
et 30% pour les transports donc ça c'est
l'état des lieux actuels cet état des
lieux voilà il les montre notre grande
dépendance aux importations d'énergie
aujourd'hui je rappelle 60% de l'énergie
qu'on consomme est importante et
seulement 20% et renouvelable alors
partant de là quel est effectivement la
place des énergies renouvelables dans le
futur on a mené un certain nombre de
travaux sur ces sujets là à la fois des
études de potentiel des études aux
limites puisque la dame il y a quelques
années maintenant avaient regardé la
question de mix électrique ou de mix
gazier 100% renouvelable c'était des
études véritablement pour pousser les
les limites et vérifier ses potentiels
et on a publié plus récemment fin 2021
un travail qui s'appelle transition
200500 travail de prospective de quatre
scénarios de neutralité carbone
quatre scénarios donc de société
française neutre en carbone dans
lesquelles on a exploré des voies très
variées pour atteindre cette neutralité
carbone
neutralité carbone qui concerne les
aspects qui vont bien au-delà de la
question énergétique puisque on y
interroge à la fois l'alimentation
l'agriculture
l'évolution des mobilités et bien
entendu les questions de mix énergétique
dans ce contexte-là c'est important de
rappeler que on parle dans la question
que vous posez d'énergie et non pas que
dès l'électricité et donc de ce fait les
énergies renouvelables dont on parle
sont assez variés et d'ailleurs dans les
20% d'énergie renouvelable dont je
parlais tout à l'heure pourtant de
savoir qu'aujourd'hui ces énergies
renouvelables sont essentiellement de la
biomasse puis de l'hydroélectricité et
que celles qui ont une très forte
dynamique de développement aujourd'hui
le photovolté qui a éolien ne représente
à ce jour qu'une faible part de
l'énergie renouvelable produite c'est
néanmoins sur elle que l'essentiel de la
croissance à venir
à reposer
à la fois donc des technologies de
production que constitue l'éolien le
photovoltaïque mais également des
technologies pour le chauffage notamment
des pompes à chaleur et de la biomasse
sont les quatre énergies majeures dans
lesquelles dans les différents scénarios
qu'on a pu faire le développement et on
va dire incontournable si on veut
atteindre la neutralité carbone alors
quel est la part des énergies
renouvelables dans ces mix énergétiques
en 2050 dans ces travaux donc très
variés on a une part d'énergie
renouvelable dans 2050 qui qui varie
entre 70% ou plus et ça quelle que soit
les choix on va dire fait sur le
nucléaire par exemple
et je parle de 70% de
l'approvisionnement énergétique et non
pas que électrique donc effectivement
d'après l'Ademe d'après les travaux
qu'on peut mener les énergies
renouvelables ont une belle voix devant
elle ça veut dire multiplier par 3 au
moins leur production par rapport à
aujourd'hui alors
dans ce propos liminaire je veux juste
insister sur quelques points le fait que
on est devant un bouquet d'énergie
renouvelable une diversification notre
mix énergétique on va pas parler et
remplacer le pétrole et le gaz par une
ou deux énergies renouvelables et bien
par une diversité un bouquet néanmoins
faut pas se voiler la face on ne fera
pas la transition uniquement avec les
énergies renouvelables que tout le monde
aime bien parce qu'on ne les voit pas on
entend parler souvent des énergies
marines ou de la géothermie certes nous
on pousse aussi beaucoup la géothermie
et on soutient la R&D sur les énergies
marines mais mais la transition
écologique ne se fera pas sans les
majors les énergies renouvelables major
que je citais tout à l'heure l'éolien le
photovoltaïque la biomasse les pompes à
chaleur
c'est une certaine diversité qui est
facteur de résilience
ces énergies renouvelables représentent
aussi des opportunités en termes de
souveraineté dans nos travaux en 2050 on
peut réduire de 85% les importations de
produits pétroliers
c'est donc bien entendu une production
locale qui va se substituer à des
importations donc facteur de
souveraineté important dans la dans la
période actuelle
c'est également un choix qu'on peut
considérer comme économique on a
longtemps eu des énergies renouvelables
qui présentaient des surcoûts par
rapport aux énergies fossiles et
la crise récente a montré le contraire
et et les progrès technologiques sur les
énergies renouvelables notamment les
énergies renouvelables électriques les
amènent aujourd'hui dans des champs de
compétitivité avec les autres formes
d'énergie dans les études qu'on a pu
mener à la fois sur le mix électrique ou
sur la chaleur juste deux points sur le
mix électrique aujourd'hui ce sont les
travaux de l'ADEME ou les travaux de RTE
montrent que globalement la question
n'est plus d'opposé les énergies
renouvelables et nucléaires mais que du
point de vue économique en tout cas le
choix n'est pas économique il y a peu de
différence entre des mixes électriques
qui iraient vers du 100% renouvelable et
des mixes qui qui renouveleraient le
nucléaire c'est des questions de coûts
financement qui sont derrière il y a
bien entendu des paramètres qui peuvent
faire évoluer un peu ces différences là
mais néanmoins on est assez proche en
terme de coûts sur ces questions là donc
c'est pas un choix économique c'est
avant tout un choix politique un choix
industriel sur la chaleur renouvelable
on est là aussi dans une logique
complètement économique à titre un
exemple que je peux donner le fond
chaleur qui est un fond donc opéré par
ADEME pour subventionner la chaleur
renouvelable
à côté à l'état contribuable environ
3,5 milliards d'euros depuis 10 ans
c'est la totalité des subventions qu'on
a distribué 3,5 milliards d'euros
ça a permis de subventionner des
installations de chaleur renouvelables
qui produisent aujourd'hui environ 40
terawattheure de chaleur renouvelables
uniquement sur l'année dernière avec les
prix du gaz de l'an dernier
le fond chaleur a été remboursé en un an
c'est-à-dire que les installations de
production de chaleur renouvelables de
biomasse de géothermie qui ont produit
l'an dernier alors 40 terrains si elles
avaient dû produire cette énergie à
partir de gaz alors écoutez c'est 3,5
milliards d'euros donc voilà enfin il y
a des choix aujourd'hui qui un contexte
qui change complètement la donne sur le
sujet des énergies des énergies
renouvelables alors deux sujets
importants également pour terminer la
question de l'appropriation locale de
ces technologies comme je disais on est
face à un déploiement très ambitieux
multiplié par 3 leur leur production
elles sont nécessairement déployées sur
les territoires les territoires ont des
gisements différents ont des besoins
différents dans des potentiels
différents il y a une véritable question
en ce moment où la question de la
planification écologique et posée
comment répartir ces énergies
renouvelables comment susciter la
propriét comment répartir l'effort
puisque tout les territoires sont pas
égaux ils ne sont pas enfin il y a des
populations différentes il y a des
territoires plus agricoles que d'autres
avec plus de biomasse que d'autres avec
plus de soleil que d'autres donc on a
une vraie question aujourd'hui de
pouvoir réconcilier des schémas de
planification on va dire remontant qui
viennent des territoires comme les pcaet
comme les schémas régionaux
comme les schéma régionaux avec ces
objectifs nationaux qui jusqu'à présent
ne sont pas réconciliés dans les dans
les précédentes versions de la PPE et
des stradettes et puis un point pour
terminer ces énergies renouvelables
elles ont certes des potentiels
techniques extrêmement importants
néanmoins dans ces scénarios qu'on peut
faire ou on se base scénarios réalistes
de déploiement
ça ça veut dire que notre consommation
doit réduire je vous parlais tout à
l'heure d'une consommation de 1600
amateurs on a effectivement des
objectifs de réduction qui sont fixés
dans la loi mais on ne saura pas faire
un approvisionnement même à 70%
renouvelable sans réduire notre
consommation que ce soit via
l'efficacité énergétique les
technologies ou via l'évolution des
comportements ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui la sobriété qui ne sont pas
nécessairement une privation mais qui
peuvent aussi constituer une opportunité
pour retrouver plus de sens
voilà un dernier point j'ai beaucoup
parlé de 2030 de 2050 on a également
aujourd'hui des nouveaux objectifs au
niveau européen sur l'horizon 2035 avec
fit for fifty-five 2030
c'est très réduction drastique de -55%
des émissions de CO2 change la donne
dans la trajectoire à adopter à court
terme
et je pense que Valérie foudon pourra le
confirmer on a un enjeu sans regret
avant cet horizon là de développer coûte
que coûte les énergies renouvelables
puisque et la sobriété puisque avant cet
horizon on ne pourra pas augmenter la
production nucléaire les nouveaux les
nouvelles installations ne seront pas en
service avant cet horizon là donc pour
atteindre ces objectifs à l'horizon 2035
je pense qu'il y a pas d'opposition à
avoir on a de toute façon besoin des
énergies renouvelables merci beaucoup
et bien David Marshall moi je vous
remercie pour avoir tenu votre
engagement temps ce qui est formidable
et ça permet
d'ouvrir la controverse en donnant la
parole à il faut donc et surtout vous
permettre de préparer vos propres
questions
merci beaucoup merci
[Musique]
on a regardé à cette occasion le débat
de 80 le débat de 2007 donc cette
question
nucléaire renouvelable a été déjà dans
ses débats et je dirais que pour moi la
controverse elle est pas elle est pas
sûre et ce qu'il faut du renouvelable la
controverse c'est vraiment la
controverses les 100% renouvelables en
fait vraiment c'est là qu'elle a
controverse elle n'existait pas en 81
François Mitterrand a dit qu'il voulait
il voulait pas le tout nucléaire mais il
voulait un mix diversifié avec du
nucléaire et pareil dans le débat entre
ses collines royales et Nicolas Sarkozy
en 2016 c'est vraiment une controverse
pour moi qui apparaît dans le débat
public français avec le débat de 2012 en
fait c'est vraiment à ce moment là alors
c'est alors c'est pour moi c'est
vraiment politique
pourquoi c'est parce qu'en fait bon déjà
on le sait depuis longtemps le nucléaire
est porte des halos symboliques d'hiver
il porte le halo symbolique de la bombe
il porte le à le symbolique de de l'état
de la place de l'État
il porte le symbolique de la science
alors bizarrement de la croissance alors
qu'il y a des gens qui sont pour le
nucléaire et pour la décroissance
plus récemment plus récemment le
patriarcat moi j'ai été invitée dans des
colloques éco-féministes voilà donc on a
des débats sur Twitter sur ces sujets
voilà donc il y a beaucoup de gens qui
sont opposés pour le nucléaire mais
principalement je crois au-delà avec le
halo symbolique qu'il porte voilà alors
cette controverse elle est compliquée
parce qu'elle est
elle utilise des des outils
scientifiques qui sont les modèles
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait chaque
chaque porteur d'un projet à son modèle
qui valide techniquement ce qu'il dit il
n'y a pas que la France vous savez bien
sûr le rôle du scénario Negawatt
l'utilisation politique du scénario aux
États-Unis Bernie Sanders y porte aussi
un scénario anti-nucléaire 100%
renouvelable par un qui fait par un prof
de Stanford donc c'est un peu compliqué
pour les citoyens parce qu'en fait à
chaque fois il y a une position qui est
prise et puis rien on dit mais moi j'ai
mon modèle scientifique paru dans telle
revue à comité de lecture qui dit que
finalement ma position elle est vraie
elle est tenable elle a une alors c'est
extrêmement compliqué pour les citoyens
parce qu'il faut quand même rentrer dans
le détail de ces modèles pour comprendre
la différence méthodologique et puis
vous savez comment un modèle ben il
dépend de laquelle de l'information qui
est rentrée dedans et l'information qui
est entraînement sincèrement on la
connaît pas un modèle à 2050
quel sera les comportements des Français
en termes de consommation quel sera le
prix des technologies quel est le prix
du salaire en 2050 voilà
la disponibilité des technologies
qu'est-ce qui se passera dans le monde
d'un point de vue géolé politique tout
ça on ne le sait pas et on peut avoir
des experts très très forts faut quand
même faire preuve d'humilité puisque je
vous rappelle qu'on n'avait pas prédit
le choc pétrolier de 73 on n'avait pas
prévu l'arrivée du gaz de schiste aux
États-Unis dans les années 2000-2010 et
on a juste pas prédit la crise en
Ukraine avec la crise du gaz européen
donc il faut quand même être extrêmement
humble en matière de modélisation
ce qu'il faut c'est utiliser des
trajectoires les comprendre les partager
et se dire qu'elle est finalement la
trajectoire la plus robuste que je que
je peux suivre sachant que il y a rien
de plus instable que l'énergie il y a
plein de choses que je ne sais pas donc
qu'est-ce qui est finalement robuste
pour moi et résilient ces mots étaient à
la mode voilà je crois que c'est moins
important alors
il y a eu des travaux comme l'a dit
David à la dame il y a eu des travaux
chez nagawatt
il y a aussi des travaux côté
pronucléaires il y a des travaux avec
beaucoup de nucléaires j'insiste que je
pense pas enfin David va peut-être me
contredire qui est des travaux 100%
nucléaires je crois qu'on n'est jamais
vu
de notoriété et donc de toute façon les
scénarios même portés par jean-lucléaire
il y a des renouvelables et d'ailleurs
je vous rappelle que le club nucléaire
créé par Madame l'administralie
espagnole il est aussi pro renouvelable
c'est le club renouvelable qui est
anti-nucléaire au niveau europ éen
alors ce que je voulais vous dire
je vais insister sur les scénarios RTE
pourquoi c'est parce qu'en fait ils ont
été partagés c'est à dire que c'est des
scénarios ou à peu près tous les acteurs
français il y a concertation à durée 2
ans tout le monde connaît bien la
méthodologie puisque tout le monde a
bossé dessus en fait voilà on a donné
nos inputs donc on sait comment il est
fait et là où je trouve qu'ils ont créé
une
je veux pas laisser penser que je
critique le travail qui a été fait par
David évidemment et puis je parlais de
travaux RTL auquel il a participé aussi
c'est qu'il est intéressant parce que
justement vous savez que des premiers
sujets sur lesquels j'en sont pas
d'accord c'est le niveau de consommation
donc il y a trois niveaux de
consommation
donc la ville l'a dit bon il y a un
niveau moyen de référence qui était à
l'époque scénario SNBC et puis il y a un
niveau sobre de sobriété donc un niveau
de consommation plus faible et puis il y
a un scénario avec un scénario de
consommation plus haute qui
correspondait à réindustrialisation
profonde une augmentation de la part de
l'industrie dans le dans le PIB 2050 qui
a des effets vertus à la fois pour la
croissance économique française pour
l'emploi mais aussi rappelons-le pour
des carbonation puisque tout ce qui est
produit en France s'est produit avec une
électricité bas carbone donc on y met
moins
que quand on importe des produits donc
il y a trois niveaux là je fais une
petite parenthèse puisque ce scénario
est en pleine pas révision à 2050 en
tout cas il y a un nouveau scénario en
cours de RTE on est actuellement dans
une une perspective aussi de la
consommation d'électricité très forte
qui est à la fois
qui a un scénario de réindustrialisation
profonde et de sobriété en même temps et
malgré ça on est quand même des niveaux
de 600 tiers à wattheure en 2035 ce qui
a joué pas mal ça a été que les input à
la fois de
en termes de demande d'hydrogène de
l'industrie parce que faire de
l'hydrogène ça demande beaucoup
d'électricité et puis
et puis aussi les if Youle qui arrivent
dans l'aviation en particulier donc ça
aussi ça demande beaucoup d'électricité
donc actuellement on est vraiment dans
une situation et ça je crois que ça a
été aussi un des points importants
d'avis dans un parlait pas mal il y a eu
dans le débat public on a pas mal étudié
une confusion complète entre énergie
électricité pendant très longtemps
quand vous regardez par exemple des bas
des NT1 de 2012 on mélange les deux
allègrement
et donc alors qu'en fait et c'est pas
forcément facile à comprendre pour pour
des non initiés il faut à la fois
baisser notre consommation d'énergie
mais pour baisser la consommation
d'énergie il faut augmenter la
consommation d'électricité
je vais le débat le débat présidentiel
du deuxième tour 2017 il mélangeait
agrément les deux elle se tromper sur
les chiffres etc donc il faut vraiment
insister là-dessus je pense aux citoyens
c'est vraiment faire la différence entre
les deux donc on va avoir besoin de
beaucoup d'électricité ça je crois que
c'est relativement consensuel alors ce
que disait David l'a évoqué l'étude 2050
RTA donc je vous disais trois niveaux de
consommation c'était pour mettre un peu
tout le monde d'accord enfin chacun est
ce qu'il voulait et puis il y avait six
trajectoires trajectoires sans
renouvellement du parc nucléaire et
trois trajectoires avec renouvellement
du parc nucléaire à différents niveaux
de renouvellement
il faut savoir qu'à l'époque puisque ça
date de fin 21 on fermait les réacteurs
puisqu'on avait suivi la PPE donc
enfermé 12 réacteurs et l'hypothèse
aussi c'est qu'on à l'époque l'autre 60
ans sur les réacteurs actuels donc on a
une sorte de d'effet falaise terrible à
partir de 2040 puisqu'on les a
construits extrêmement vite donc ils
arrivent tous à 60 ans en même temps la
boum
et alors ce que nous disait ce que nous
dit cette étude elle nous dit plein de
choses
alors bon il y a une différence de coût
c'est vrai que David a dit que la
différence de coût était principalement
liée à la façon dont est financée le
nucléaire en particulier parce que
l'étude mettez un financement à 4% sur
sur l'ensemble des technologies
avec une année de sensibilité à 7%
ce qui est vraiment très intéressant
c'est que la grosse différence c'est pas
le coût de production des technologies
c'est un peu terminé c'est à dire quand
vous regardez comme production nucléaire
à renouvelable c'est à peu près la même
chose ce qui fait la différence c'est
les coûts de réseau
inéditrte et puis les coups de
flexibilité du réseau
dans des groupes de travail actuellement
pour la préparation de la loi elbeke
enedis ils ont quand même annoncé 90
milliards d'investissements d'ici à 2040
sur juste le réseau de distribution
d'électricité donc c'est vraiment ces
couleurs qui font la différence ce qu'on
appelle aujourd'hui en science
économique l'écosystèmes aujourd'hui en
sciences économique on dit plus il y
avait le LCO vous avez le live cost of
electricity qui était le coût de
production des outils maintenant regarde
de plus en plus et ce que fait l'étude
RTE le coup système qui inclut la
distribution
le transport d'électricité et puis les
coûts d'équilibrage du réseau dans le
cadre de RTE ce sont des il y a
évidemment de la flexibilité de la
demande et il y a aussi des turbines à
hydrogène ma carbone pour équilibrer le
réseau
donc ça c'est très important et puis je
vais pas prendre autant je vais finir
voisin parce que vraiment aussi
intéressant je trouve dans le scénario
RTUP ce qui se pose la question de la
robustesse et ça je pense que c'est
vraiment important
contenu du passé qu'on a pu avoir sur la
sur les chocs énergétiques et donc
chacun ses forces et ses faiblesses je
dirais
donc je vais commencer par les
faiblesses du nucléaire
la faiblesse nucléaire c'est est-ce
qu'on va réussir à construire tous ces
EPS
donc il y a eu un grand débat donc vous
le savez le choix qui a été fait c'est
le N2 c'est le 14 réacteurs avant 2000
50 donc chez les différents associations
nucléaires il y a eu un grand débat
là-dessus mais pourquoi on peut faire
que 14 on peut en faire 20 on peut faire
25 c'est avant ce qu'on a dit nous on
est tout à fait d'accord avec
sur le choix qui a été fait c'est qu'en
fait l'important pour nous c'est surtout
de commencer à les construire et
d'arriver à faire un rythme de croisière
après on verra combien on est capable en
faire mais la question c'est ce qu'on
est capable de se remettre en capacité
de construire d'avoir un vrai programme
industriel pour commencer à construire
donc ça c'était le premier sujet il y a
un deuxième sujet
qui a pas vraiment été controversé à
l'époque mais qui est un sujet
aujourd'hui c'est ce qu'on peut aller de
la 60 ans je vous dis à un effet falaise
on va pas tout fermer en même temps donc
est-ce qu'on peut avoir des réacteurs
qui vont de la 60 ans ça se fait aux
États-Unis mais on n'a pas la même
autorité de sûreté donc je pense que
d'ailleurs sur ces sujets lopex va être
beaucoup saisi
de savoir est-ce qu'on peut prolonger de
la 60 ans enfin pour l'instant faut
prolonger pour être 50 ans mais c'est
extrêmement important pour la politique
énergétique de française de savoir le
plus tôt possible si on peut aller au
delà de 60 ans parce que si on peut pas
aller loin de 60 ans on n'est pas très
bien quoi voilà
ça c'est les faiblesses côté nucléaires
il y a la question du financement dont
tu as parlé David ce qui a été mis dans
les rapports C4 %. donc ce qui a été
choisi dans la méthodologie c'est qu'en
fait on pouvait pas savoir comment
serait financer le nouveau programme
donc on a mis tout le monde à 4 %. faut
savoir qu'il y a des programmes qui sont
financés à 4 % dans le monde en Hongrie
ils sont à 3 %
tout dépend du schéma financier qui est
mis en place et surtout dans
l'implication des deux des deux seuls
qui peuvent vraiment porter le risque de
tel projet parce que faire porter le
risque de ces projets sur le
constructeur on l'a vu à on a vu la
faillite d'arriver en France pour la
Finlande et aussi les difficultés de
westinien sur le premier chantier
américain donc donc il y en a que deux
grands acteurs qui peuvent porter le
risque c'est passer le contribuable le
consommateur voilà
donc si à cette question du financement
qui n'est pas tranchée aujourd'hui et
puis et puis voilà alors ça c'est la
partie force et faiblesse du nucléaire
ça fait faiblesse risque sur le
nucléaire la risque côté renouvelable
identifié par l'OPEX alors c'est d'abord
le risque de notre capacité à déployer
au vitesse requises parce qu'on est
vitesse très élevées qui vont parfois
au-delà de ce qu'on fait nos meilleurs
voisins que ce soit sur l'éolien
offshore ou solaire on est capable de
faire la même vitesse que à la fin de
gestion de projet de capacités
industrielle et puis en terme de ce que
le public va comment le public va avoir
le diplôme de ces projets et puis aussi
les disponibilité à l'échelle
industrielle des technologies de
flexibilité
en particulier les questions de stockage
voilà un petit peu donc le bout du
compte en fait moi ça sera ma position
nous on est vraiment évidemment
convaincu de la valeur du nucléaire dans
le système électrique pas seulement
français mais européen puisqu'il est pas
carbone et pilotable donc il stabilise
l'ensemble du réseau d'autant plus et ça
RTE disait récemment tous nos voisins
vont faire énormément de renouvelables
donc on sera le rôle du nucléaire sur la
plaque électrique européenne le il est
extrêmement important pour stabiliser le
réseau
on est convaincus évidemment de la place
que le nucléaire a dans la stratégie
industrialisation française puisque
c'est notre troisième secteur
et
voilà mais je pense que j'espère que la
controverse est en cours d'extinction et
on arrive vers un consensus parce que
évidemment on a besoin d'une claire et
du renouvelable voilà merci
donc perspective
perspective d'un abaissement de du taux
de
conflictualité de cette controverse bon
très honnêtement on a un petit peu de
temps mais pas beaucoup alors il faut y
aller ceux qui veulent intervenir
oui sur les la comparaison des coûts
effectivement le c'est plus les coups de
production mais les coûts systèmes
complets qu'il faut comparer donc mettre
en avant les seuls coups de production
quand même assez discutable entre les
scénarios RTE donc au maximum de 50% de
nucléaire puisque RTU n'a pas voulu
monter au dessus dans la première dans
la première mouture et les scénarios le
plus
le plus renouvelable c'était en gros 20
milliards d'euros par an il y a une
étude très importante de l'OCDE Nea qui
est basé sur le même principe la
comparaison des coûts des systèmes
complets mais cette fois avec peut-être
des scénarios un peu plus réalistes qui
vont de 90% de nucléaires 10% de
renouvelables à 70% ren 30% nucléaires
qui est bizarrement abouti à peu près à
cet ordre de grandeur aussi c'est à dire
20 milliards d'euros par an de coûts
entre les entre les deux systèmes voilà
et puis vous avez parlé vous avez eu un
raisonnement en parlant du coup du gaz
l'année dernière sur les infrastructures
et les programmes d'investissement de
gaz si on fait le même raisonnement pour
le nucléaire en partant des coûts de
l'électricité l'année dernière
le père de Flamanville qui est ce qu'il
est et rentabilisé en trois ans avec ce
même raisonnement à ce même donné voilà
cette plante exceptionnelle une autre
intervention
oui
pardon
j'avais une pardon j'avais une petite
question pour David Marshall en fait
puisque
Valérie a parlé des modèles et de leur
complexité et on a des expériences
réelles et je voulais parler du cas de
la Bretagne par exemple parce qu'en
Bretagne on a en fait une région qui n'a
pas de capacité nucléaire et dont les
derniers rapports de RTE montrent que
80% de l'électricité doit être injecté
en fait par le réseau RTE donc en fait
indirectement nucléaire et il y a eu 12%
d'augmentation des fossiles en 2021 par
rapport à 2020 avec la mise en place de
Landivisiau il y a quelques années pour
pouvoir injecter dans le réseau est-ce
qu'on peut par exemple envisager que
l'ADEME travaille avec les régions à un
contrat qui montre au fond comment
évolue
un pilote d'un renouvelable et comment
on voit diminuer en fait le taux
d'importation et donc indirectement la
consommation d'électrons nucléaire en
Bretagne puisque les problèmes au niveau
national c'est assez gros ça peut être
assez compliqué mais on peut là avoir
une expérience en temps réel voir où on
est en 2030 voir on est dans 1050 et
voir si on y arrive on n'y arrive pas
je voudrais compléter votre question sur
les plaques territoriales est-ce que
pour l'ademption ce concept de bactéries
toriales et de coopération européenne
avec par exemple la Lotharingie
industriel d'un côté ou au contraire les
relations avec avec l'Espagne qui est un
pays en demande permanente d'énergie
puisque constatez d'ailleurs que
là où il y a le plus de voté que l'eau
il y en général le moins de d'éoliennes
je le vois dans le Grand Est il y en a
beaucoup
partout sauf en Alsace
c'est normal il y a des Vosges qui
empêchent le vent de circuler mais enfin
bon quand même
une troisième et dernière petite souris
merci j'ai noté avec beaucoup d'intérêts
les questions de souveraineté qui sont
sous-jacentes
la production locale d'énergie
je voudrais quand même signaler un
absent dans dans ce que j'ai entendu
c'est la question de des ressources
minérales qui vont être nécessaires pour
le redéploiement de que ce soit le
nucléaire de d'un côté et les
renouvelables de l'autre tout ça dans un
contexte de déploiement massif à
l'échelle mondiale et donc de
compétition sur les marchés vous
échappera pas que la position de la
Chine ces derniers jours peut impacter
les scénarios vous avez 1000 fois raison
c'est un élément c'est pour ça qu'on
parle de système je trouve que le
concept de système est tout à fait
pertinent parce que si on doit régler un
problème en en créant un supplémentaire
supérieur nous sommes dans la situation
des apports camembert qui a été puni par
son
adjudant pour avoir creusé un trou
insuffisamment profond pour
accueillir les déblais du premier trou
et du second
voilà nous allons vers le serveur cam
de répondre à ces différentes questions
alors effectivement
pardon excusez-moi
je voudrais savoir dans quelle mesure
donc l'édit dans les différents
scénarios on intègre la question
fondamentale qui est pas seulement de la
souveraineté énergétique mais la
souveraineté industrielle et
technologique je voudrais savoir dans
quelle mesure ce paramètre est inclus
dans les prospectives que vous faites
je laisse à
David Marshall et Valérie fodon le soin
de d'apporter leur point de vue
sur les différentes questions évoquées
alors effectivement par rapport aux
différentes questions évoquées alors
j'ai finalement assez peu parlé
l'électricité mais les questions que
vous posez portes essentiellement sur le
sujet de l'électricité alors sur le
sujet du mix électrique on réalise des
études effectivement
à l'horizon 2005 ans depuis depuis 2017
une période à laquelle RTE n'était pas
encore sur cette horizon là donc RTE
maintenant y est ce qui est très bien et
fait des travaux extrêmement sérieux sur
le sujet
les travaux de l'ADEME utilisent les
mêmes types d'outils donc on parle bien
les chiffres que je vous donnais sur
l'équivalence des coûts voilà c'est on
modélise aussi le mix électrique dans
son ensemble on prend en compte les
coûts complets du mix avec les questions
de coût de réseau et de coût de
flexibilité
je pense c'est important de pas
interpréter ce que j'ai pu dire par
exemple sur le remboursement de la du
fond chaleur
en un an comme une opposition au sujet
du nucléaire enfin je crois que c'est
vraiment
faut pas faut juste pas oublier que 50%
47% aujourd'hui de l'énergie qu'on
consomme c'est de la consommer sous
forme de chaleur
et que l'électricité nous aussi dans nos
scénarios l'électricité prend une part
beaucoup plus importante dans le mix
électrique dans le mix énergétique alors
ils ont 2000 50 mais il reste 45% de
l'énergie qui sera pas d'électricité et
qu'il faudra produire aussi en réduisant
nos dépendances donc c'est important
aussi qu'on développe cette chaleur
renouvelable
sur la question de l'interdépendance
entre les régions c'est effectivement un
changement majeur qui va survenir
aujourd'hui quand on fait des études au
niveau régional on se rend compte que on
importe énormément enfin finalement les
tous nos territoires dépend énormément
aussi des importations d'énergie qui
viennent à la fois dans dehors de la
France ou d'ailleurs en France et
l'augmentation de la production locale
d'énergie renouvelable ne signifie pas
autarcie des régions ou autarcie des
territoires c'est important de l'avoir
en tête même dans des travaux qui
peuvent être faits sur les régions
énergie positives des territoires
énergies positives
on va dans un monde où il y aura plus
d'interdépendance plus de solidarité
nécessaire entre territoire puisque même
si on produit tous plus localement
davantage qu'aujourd'hui on va être sur
des profils de production qui vont
nécessiter effectivement une entraide
une solidarité c'est important de le
rappeler
l'importance de cette péréquation et de
du partage de l'effort dont je parlais
tout à l'heure alors on peut
effectivement mener des études plus
locales
sur les territoires aujourd'hui on est
en train de voir comment décliner
régionalement les mix énergétiques qui
sont étudiées au niveau national dans
transition 2050 c'est pas évident ce que
je disais ça dépend beaucoup des
potentiels de chaque territoire
et on va arriver à des valeurs guides
qui peuvent qui vont servir aux régions
pour se doter de trajectoire mais dans
certaines régions il faut avoir
conscience qu'on va être au-delà de
l'énergie positive puisque dans d'autres
régions je pense à l'Île-de-France
notamment on pourra pas bien entendu
produire autant d'énergie qu'on en
consomme donc il y a il y aura
nécessairement des des enjeux de
transferts importants on mène de tels
travaux aussi sur les zones non
interconnectées sur les outre-mer ou là
l'objectif est encore plus ambitieux
avec l'autonomie énergétique de ces
territoires la question de plaque
territoriale
aujourd'hui on étudie ces questions de
grandes zones industrielles au travers
des des
ibac un zone industrielle bas carbone
qui sont des travaux de prospective qui
sont des soutiens qui sont apportés via
France 2030 pour aider ces grosses zones
industrielles à faire de la prospective
évaluer leurs besoins en termes
d'infrastructures de CO2 d'hydrogène etc
je pense pas qu'à ce stade elles sont
ouvertes très largement au delà des
frontières par rapport à votre question
sur les plaques et puis sur les
ressources minérales effectivement c'est
un sujet qu'on regarde aussi beaucoup
les quatre scénarios ont donné lieu à
une évaluation des besoins en matériaux
et ce qui est important de d'avoir en
tête c'est que certes les productions
d'énergie vont nécessiter davantage de
matériaux mais c'est surtout l'évolution
de nos consommations de ce qu'on
constate c'est les points les plus
criants en termes de besoins notamment
sur le lithium sur le cuivre sont tirés
par le développement du véhicule
électrique qui est nécessaire dans tous
les scénarios mais qui représente des
volumes plus importants que les énergies
renouvelables notamment
et sur la question de la souveraineté
alors effectivement on a dans nos
scénarios une volonté de de relocaliser
un certain nombre de productions
industrielle moins sans doute que n'a pu
le faire RTE dans son scénario rien
industrialisation profonde
je pense que c'est aussi important de
voir d'un point de vue opérationnel ce
qui est fait aujourd'hui il y a des
soutiens publics très importants qui
sont octroyés sur les questions de
production de réindustrialisation on est
opérateur France 2030 et donc on finance
à ce titre à la fois des
infrastructures de production
notamment futurs
usines on voit qu'il y a aujourd'hui des
projets d'usine de batterie de
production de photovoltaïques
de production aussi sur l'éolien
offshore donc cette souveraineté elle se
construit elle se construit aussi avec
de la visibilité puisque comme dans le
cas du nucléaire a besoin de visibilité
pour que les investissements puissent
être faits mais nul doute que au niveau
français et européen le marché des
énergies renouvelables est-elle à
l'horizon 2050 que des investissements
sont possibles et rentables
alors sur la question
de la des matières il y a un certain
nombre de travaux qui qui sont publiés
je pense un scénario mondial de l'Agence
internationale d'énergie sur la
transition énergétique qui s'appuie
justement sur leur NZ
donc il y a il y a un vrai enjeu sur le
système électrique il y a un mode commun
qui est le cuivre la consommation de
cuivre
mais c'est assez impressionnant ça
double au moins voir plus enfin il y a
des ratios extrêmement importants et ça
on en a tous besoin évidemment
le nucléaire est assez sobre il y a deux
il y a deux dimensions il y a la
dimension de la construction alors on
est sobre parce que quand on construit
on construit pour 60 ans 80 ans alors
évidemment
rapporté au kilowattheure et comme en
plus on est pilotable et qu'on produit
beaucoup on est très sobre en matière il
y a un peu d'acier évidemment ils sont
en train nucléaire il y a aussi un peu
de nickel et un peu de chrome pour les
alliages de la chaudière
mais on est assez moins la question se
pose sur l'uranium et c'est vrai que
actuellement on est dans des scénarios
de relance forte avec un potentiellement
un doublement du de la production
nucléaire et de la capacité nucléaire
pour 2050 donc là on attend septembre un
nouveau rapport de la World nucléaire
associé Sean pour faire une évolution
des ressources minières en uranium
sachant que comme vous le savez qu'on a
des ressources des puisque l'OPEX a
publié un rapport dessus on peut faire
de la gêne 4 et auquel cas on a sur
notre sol tout ce qu'il nous faut au
portrait longtemps voilà si on est
capable de valoriser en particulier
notre uranium appauvri voilà
alors donc ça c'était sur la partie sur
la partie ressources sur la partie
souveraineté donc en effet on a la
chance d'avoir une industrie nationale
on n'est pas 100%, il y a un certain
nombre de pièces il y a un certain
nombre d'opérations actuellement de
relocalisation qui sont pas forcément
visibles mais actuellement par exemple
franc-maône sur leurs usines de
Saint-Marcel et de Creusot sont en train
de relocaliser un certain nombre de
fabrication qui était faite
en République tchèque au Japon par
exemple donc il y a un travail
actuellement qui est fait sur ce sujet
alors on a une chaîne française il faut
penser à la chaîne européenne pourquoi
c'est parce qu'on a donc cet objectif de
150 gigawatts de nucléaire en 2050 qui
voudrait dire qu'on construirait 120
gigawatts en Europe donc 15 pays qui ont
ou plus le 16e
UK qui en dit qui souhaitait compter sur
le nucléaire dans le futur on a des
projets je disais ce matin que les que
les que les le Pays-Bas sont en train de
considérer trois pays dont la France
pour la construction de nouveaux
réacteurs nucléaires et donc la seule
chaîne industrielle
plus clair en France c'est celle de la
France voilà donc il faudra que cette
chaîne devienne européenne
si on veut pouvoir accompagner
l'ensemble des pays européens dans ces
programmes de construction neuve et je
vous dis ça parce que les Américains
sont là ils sont arrivés en Pologne en
Roumanie avec avec beaucoup de
financement
et je pense qu'il faut vraiment qu'on
réfléchisse à notre souveraineté sur ces
sur ces projets de construction neuve
européenne et la France peut être
vraiment un allié de l'ensemble des pays
européens sur ce sujet puisque j'ai la
main j'en profite quand même parce que
je n'ai pas dit dans mon introduction et
je voulais faire de remercie lopex
évidemment pour le travail
d'accompagnement du programme nucléaire
qui a été fait depuis sa création dans
le débat qui a eu sur les opère à panli
un moment donné il y a eu un débat sur
le fait que nucléaire n'était pas
démocratique et même eu des expressions
un peu extrêmes genre la démocratie
française est malade du nucléaire ça a
été dit et regardant justement
l'occasion de nous ça contents
l'histoire et on en a parlé à l'occasion
d'ici de la de l'événement organisé par
la Fondation Giscard d'Estaing
le nucléaire en fait les décisions sur
nucléaires ont été prises avec la
pratique démocratique française de
l'époque dans les années 70 et ensuite
évidemment la création de l'OPEX le
nucléaire a été un des sujets de travail
de lopex tout à fait naturellement et
puis aussi l'arrivée de la démocratie
française la démocratie participative
plus tard même et donc voilà je voulais
vraiment remercier le texte d'avoir
accompagné justement
le développement du nucléaire dans avec
la pratique démocratique que le peix a
permis de mettre en place merci merci
beaucoup je vais reprendre la parole et
malheureusement contrôler le temps parce
que sinon je vais priver des autres
intervenants de la possibilité de
présenter leur controverse je voudrais
simplement
[Musique]
dire il s'agit d'une grosse reverse ce
que l'on peut dire raisonnablement c'est
que la controverse c'est d'une qualité
croissante c'est à dire que les
oppositions continuent d'exister elles
sont plus respectueuses des points de
vue des uns et des autres ce qui sur le
plan de l'intelligence collective et
plutôt un signal favorable
Valérie vous avait dit la
nucléaire la démocratie française est
malade du nucléaire dit certains j'avais
plutôt envie de penser le contraire le
nucléaire était malade de la démocratie
et du scrutin majoritaire à deux tours
parce que le coût marginal des voix
qu'il faut mobiliser pour être
majoritaire est un coût extrêmement
élevé pour toutes sortes d'activités
pour toutes sortes d'engagements pour
toutes sortes de promesses et le
nucléaire à partir du moment où il y a
pas de problème d'électricité à partir
du moment les gens ont une électricité
abondante est bon marché le nucléaire
est une valeur d'AJ pour la screuser
majoritaire à deux tours parce qu'on
peut se payer sur la bête sans avoir de
grands risques politiques tant que ça
marche puis un jour ça marche moins ça
marche moins parce que les entretiens
n'ont peut-être pas été fait parce que
les fêtes falaise n'est pas
imaginé dans ces conséquences et dans
ces solutions et à ce moment-là la
nature du débat change et ce qui ne
concernait qu'une minorité de gens
passionnés et convaincus concerne tous
les usagers et le comportement change
donc c'est
et on le voit bien à travers les hommes
politiques sont moi le premier
d'ailleurs des opportunistes et si il y
a des déclarations fortes qui ont été
faites c'est 18 derniers mois c'est
parce que il y avait une conscience d'un
problème immédiat qui devenait prégnant
pour pour l'ensemble des participants ce
qui prouvent que les controverses sont
d'autant plus peuvent être d'autant plus
raisonnés qu'on arrive sur la réalité
des difficultés et c'est plutôt
rassurant pour la démocratie française
même si tout n'est pas encore réglé
d'ailleurs ça veut dire pour passer la
parole à Jean il tient pour ma place ça
me permettra d'aller prendre un petit
café mais ça permet ça veut dire que
quand les gens auront faim il y aura
beaucoup moins de contrefaire sur les
problèmes phytosanitaires dans
l'agriculture
merci on aborde la deuxième
la deuxième chambre
c'est beaucoup plus confortable
il y a la deuxième on passe à la
deuxième controverse sur réduire l'usage
des produits phytosanitaires agricoles
est-ce mettent en danger la production
alimentaire c'est un sujet majeur je
crois qu'il a été peu abordé par
addoxalement par le fils dans le dans le
passé sauf avec Catherine procacia le
président l'archet en a dit on a on a
tous les deux fait un rapport sur la
chlordécone il y a eu d'autres rapports
qui ont peut-être
dont on a peut-être moins parlé mais
mais c'est un sujet qui aujourd'hui est
au cœur de l'actualité et parce que
pourquoi on va pas plus vite il y a un
échec dans les objectifs qu'on avait de
réduction des pesticides on n'arrivera
pas à 50% de réduction en 2030
vraisemblablement on est encore à 43000
tonnes aujourd'hui
pourquoi pas aller plus vite vers une AG
la culture sans pesticides mais il y a
plein de questions qui se posent à
travers une question générique c'est de
quelle pesticides on parle
et je crois que là c'est pas clair y
compris y compris sur les chiffres parce
que quand stagne ça baisse légèrement
quand même au niveau national c'est très
variable suivant les pays européens mais
quand les les pesticides de synthèse
baissent légèrement augmentent très
fortement les produits de biocontrôle
et
se pose donc une première question
qu'est-ce qu'elles sont les les
pesticides autorisés aujourd'hui
est-ce que les pesticides qui restent et
très dangereux est-ce que c'est des
pesticides à faible risque est-ce qu'on
peut parler de pesticides à faible
risque qu'est-ce qu'on autorise pour
l'agriculture biologique est-ce que par
exemple des substances chimiques comme
le fer que comme le cuivre ou le soufre
c'est c'est pas nocif y compris pour les
sols ces questions sont sont peut-être
pas suffisamment abordés ensuite
est-ce que ça peut entraîner une baisse
de la production alimentaire c'est la
question c'est la question principale je
crois que c'est une question majeure
majeure non pas pour les pays du Nord
parce que quand on voit les arguments
qui sont développés on peut très bien le
faire parce que 60% c'est pour
l'alimentation du bétail parce que il y
a une grosse partie qui est pour la
grosse chimie est-ce que c'est valable
dans tous les pays du monde
et enfin je crois qu'il y a une question
que je que je poserai à Christian wig
d'abord puisque il a participé
à en tant que directeur scientifique de
l'inrae et que ingénieur agronome
docteur en génétique et en amélioration
des plantes de formation Christian oui
qui a supervisé de nombreux programmes
scientifiques on a travaillé ensemble
d'ailleurs sur dans une audition
publique décentralisée déjà à Gruissan
sur la transition des systèmes de
production agricole il est actuellement
animateur du programme de recherche
cultivé et protéger autrement dans le
cadre du travail de prospective sur
l'agriculture européenne sans pesticides
en 2050 et
l'Inra lineray a bien fait de travailler
de manière systémique et non plus par si
loin indépendant sur ces questions mais
est-ce que pour arriver à ces solutions
les pour arriver à ces solutions et
est-ce que c'est du seul ressort du
monde agricole
est-ce que le changement dont vous
parlez est-ce que il faut pas associer
la totalité des des la totalité de ceux
qui sont concernés enfin
les pesticides nuisent à la biodiversité
et on a parlé d'extinction
d'insectes on a parlé des seuls pollués
on peut arriver
si certains à des baisses très fortes de
pesticides sans perte de rendement quel
est l'impact et on vous demandera
Madame Valérie Chancy chancigo de
traiter de cette question Quel est qui
vous est cherchera ceci en histoire des
sciences et de l'environnement dans le
laboratoire sphère sciences philosophie
histoire de parité ou vos travaux
portent sur l'étude des relations entre
les êtres humains et la nature et on
vous demandera de traiter de cette
question de l'impact sur l'environnement
et de l'impact sur l'homme et enfin
dernière question à l'échelle de la
planète je parlais de la planète tout à
l'heure est-ce qu'on va pouvoir nourrir
10 milliards de personnes aujourd'hui
sans produit de synthèse et est-ce qu'il
faut combiner des bouquets de solutions
avec
de l'agroécologie avec des solutions de
biocontrôle avec du numérique avec de la
génétique un peu comme les les gens qui
sont contre le nucléaire sont maintenant
contre les éoliennes dans les mêmes où
c'est ce que disait Gérard Longuet tout
à l'heure on voit aujourd'hui
des gens qui à la fois sont contre les
pesticides mais qui sont aussi contre
les solutions génétiques est-ce que il
faut combiner ces solutions pour arriver
à traiter de cette question c'est une
question majeure voilà je vous laisse la
parole dans l'ordre Christian 8 puis
Valérie chancigo et en abordera le débat
avec la salle merci monsieur le
Président merci Messieurs les Présidents
et mesdames
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
merci de l'invitation
le sujet il est effectivement un sujet
de controverse ici c'est un sujet de
controverse sociétale qu'on a tous les
jours et j'ai beaucoup aimé la façon
dont le titre est rédigé réduire l'usage
des phytos = réduire la production
alimentaire point d'interrogation en
fait ça traduit une question qu'on
trouve souvent mais ça traduit en fait
un billet majeur de la question à savoir
que quand on fait ça ça revient à dire
qu'il y a une équation ou y = fonction
de x à savoir que les pesticides sont
regardées comme un intrant pour lequel
il y a une courbe de réponse et à partir
du moment où vous avez une courte de
réponse ça veut dire que jusqu'à un
certain niveau plus vous en met plus
vous en mettez mieux ça vaut jusqu'à un
optimum et que l'optimum fait peut être
légèrement modulé par le prix de
l'intrant c'est typiquement ce qu'on
fait avec des engrais et la question
c'est de savoir si les pesticides sont
un intrant la réponse elle est non parce
qu'en fait la question elle est de
savoir s'il y a une pression de
biogresseur et donc la vraie question
elle est pas faut-il réduire l'usage des
phytos c'est faut-il et là la réponse
serait oui maintenant la protection des
cultures et donc la protection des
cultures qu'il faut assurer c'est pas la
quantité de des phytos
et cette protection des cultures allait
comme objectif de maintenir les bureaux
agresseurs en dessous d'un usage d'un
niveau de nuisibilité
plutôt que de chercher à complètement
éradiquer alors vous avez mentionné
quelques éléments de volume
effectivement cette question elle est
souvent mise en avant est-ce que il y a
un échec du plan Écophyto fait l'action
c'est savoir système le système bouge
effectivement depuis que le plan écofito
a été mis en place en 2009 pendant à peu
près 10 ans il y a pas eu de réduction
de volume
et des pesticides chimiques des
pesticides de synthèse il y a pas une
réduction de volume et puis il y a un
fléchissement sur les dernières années
et qui s'accompagne et là avec une
trajectoire relativement régulière de
l'augmentation des produits biocontrôle
ou effectivement les gros dévolubles
sont aujourd'hui occupés par le soufre
le souffre ayant un champ d'application
qui est plus large et qui en particulier
vont être très utilisés en viticulture
et commence à être utilisé contre les
maladies foliaires en protection des
céréales et puis il y a beaucoup
d'autres produits qui aujourd'hui
émergent en produits biocontrôle donc il
y a une trajectoire et avec un
croisement donc je sais pas s'il y a
échec ou pas en tout cas il y a un vrai
changement dans l'offre un vrai
changement dans l'utilisation et la
question est de savoir jusqu'où ce
système peut aller en fait je disais il
y a un effet il y a un biais dans la
question qui est posé en fait on
rencontre deux autres biais ou plutôt
deux autres effets de fixation
majeurs et très fréquents dans les quand
on parle de pesticides d'abord on parle
souvent de quels sont les alternatives
aux pesticides et le mot alternatif
induit un biais c'est que vous faites
l'hypothèse que on fera exactement la
même chose tout comme avant
et donc on cherche la solution miracle
qui remplace la solution des pesticides
et en fait ne rien changer dans le
système de production signifie qu'on a
très peu de degrés de liberté et donc on
inversant un peu la question c'est où
peut-on trouver des degrés de liberté et
elle vient pas de réduire la production
alimentaire et bien de savoir quelle est
la production qu'on fera demain et donc
qu'elle sera la demande alimentaire de
demain donc il y a un premier effet de
fixation qui est traduit par le mot
alternative et puis le deuxième effet de
fixation qui est très fort c'est
l'hypothèse qui est que l'on aura
toujours des pesticides disponibles et
cette question c'est ce point là il est
totalement présent dans ce qui cadre
aujourd'hui les autorisations de mise en
marché ou l'homologation de molécule à
l'échelle européenne c'est le règlement
11 07 2009
qui est basé comme si il y aurait
toujours une ressource disponible et en
fait cette hypothèse là elle est
aujourd'hui totalement battue en brèche
alors le monde agricole dit bah oui mais
de fait il y a moins de pesticides parce
qu'elles sont retirées pour des raisons
d'impact et aujourd'hui en ce moment le
gouvernement malin travaille mission
d'agriculture mystère de la recherche de
l'environnement et de la santé mènerait
sur en particulier les 75 substances
actives qui sont potentiellement on va
pas dire menacés mais les plus impactés
par le moment de réévaluation dans
lequel ils vont se substances vont se
situer au cours des cinq à sept
prochaines années ça c'est une des
questions effectivement c'est les
impacts sur la santé les impacts sur
l'environnement et puis il y a une un
critère nouveau qui a été introduit en
2017 qui est les risques de génotoxicité
liés aux molécules
mais c'est qu'un tout petit bout de
l'histoire en fait le deuxième pan de
l'histoire c'est qu'on a des pertes
d'efficacité sur les molécules c'est à
dire les molécules elles tapent sur des
organismes vivants qui n'ont qu'une
seule envie c'est de rester en vie et
donc de s'adapter et donc on a des
phénomènes évolutifs par apparition de
résistance et c'est extrêmement visible
dans les herbicides de vous avez
aujourd'hui des
champs de blé vous avez très souvent
beaucoup beaucoup de raies gras ou
beaucoup de vulpins ou beaucoup de fois
Lavoine c'est uniquement liées au fait
que vous avez des populations qui sont
devenues résistantes à quelques classes
d'herbicides très utilisées en
particulier sulfonyurés et puis vous
avez des résistances parmi les insectes
et c'est une des causes de de la perte
totale des faits des pyrénoïdes parce
que les pucerons ou les altises sont
devenus résistantes à ça donc il y a des
pères d'efficacité et puis l'élément qui
est le plus problématique c'est que le
pipeline et les vides si vous regardez
le nombre de molécules ou le nombre
d'options qui sont proposés à
des autorisations sur l'échelle
européenne sur des autorisations de mise
en marché en France mais il y a de moins
en moins de demandes parce qu'il y a de
moins en moins de de levier d'action et
donc de cible qui sont trouvées par les
les substances chimiques donc de fait le
système doit être amené à bouger alors
je vais pas parler de du deuxième terme
mais on pourra en reparler à la fin le
deuxième terme de l'équation réduire la
production alimentaire ou l'affaire
évoluer on pourra en reparler tout à
l'heure mais si on reste sur la question
des pesticides la question elle est
est-ce qu'on peut assurer la protection
des cultures avec moins de pesticides et
donc assurer l'efficacité
fonctionnelle de découvert végétaux il y
a de fait comme vous l'avez introduit
monsieur le déo dans votre propos
liminaire
différents leviers qu'il faut qu'il faut
combiner et qui sont disponibles le
premier levier qui est potentiellement
celui qui est le plus puissant et qui
pourtant est celui le plus difficile de
mettre en oeuvre c'est de travailler sur
tout ce qui contribue à réduire la
pression si vous avez moins de
biogresseur vous avez moins besoin de
produits de protection des cultures et
deux grandes voies le fait que l'on peut
mobiliser c'est comment on mobilise les
régulations
naturelles il y a eu un travail
d'expertise scientifique collective qui
a été publiée par inray au mois
d'octobre l'année dernière qui montre
quand vous augmentez les la diversité
fonctionnelle à l'échelle d'une parcelle
d'une série de parcelles ou d'un
territoire vous avez un effet
de réduction forte de l'abondance des
bureaux agresseurs et donc de fait si
vous avez une réduction de l'abondance
et bien agresseurs il arrive que vous
passiez en dessous de du niveau de
risque pour la culture
puis un autre levier c'est ce qu'on peut
dans la même logique augmenter la
complexité des paysages agricoles
basé sur les logiques de de
l'agroécologie et donc il consiste en
fait à augmenter la diversité
fonctionnelle pour augmenter le service
vous pouvez augmenter les services pour
réguler davantage les populations vous
pouvez aussi augmenter les services pour
augmenter la production et donc il y a
des tout plein d'éléments qui montrent
que l'agroécologie et l'évolution des
systèmes de production permet de faire
augmenter le Land équivalent Raichu donc
vous produisez plus par unité de surface
et par an que le standard qui est les
cultures annuelles telles qu'on les
connaît aujourd'hui j'avais oublié que
les cultures annuelles ce qu'on appelle
culture annuelles elles occupent le sol
de 6 à 10 mois par an donc il y a
beaucoup de temps disponibles au milieu
de tout ça donc il y a des possibilités
autour de ça c'est extrêmement efficace
très peu cher et bizarrement très peu
utilisé
parce que la transition impose une
transition et donc ça se confronte à
l'idée que le système ne bougera pas
deuxième levier monsieur le déo vous
connaissez très bien tout ce domaine là
c'est la génétique et les variétés et
donc faire des variétés tolérantes aux
maladies c'est quelque chose que l'on
fait depuis très longtemps
qui a été tout compte fait assez peu
utilisé quand vous regardez les outils
d'aide à la décision pour piloter le la
protection des cultures et ben il a
fallu attendre pratiquement la fin des
années 2010 pour les voir apparaître
pouvoir apparaître le niveau de
résistance variétale dans les outils
d'aide à la décision et pourtant ce sont
des choses qui marchent très bien
on a un exemple que l'on connaît que
j'ai eu l'occasion d'évoquer à des
auditions avec l'OPEX qui est l'exemple
des vignes résistantes qu'on a fait des
cépages où on a plusieurs gènes de
résistance au mildou et on avait parlé
de ça quand nous étions un gruissants
plusieurs gènes de résistance au milieu
plusieurs jeunes de résistance à l'audio
mais on arrive sur un déploiement en
conditions agricoles à faire en moyenne
moins 87% de fongicides utilisés sa
culture là et comme sur la vigne il y a
quasiment que ça une vraie réduction et
où la question qu'on se pose aujourd'hui
c'est en fait on gère à terme le
déploiement de ça pour éviter les
contournements là aussi le la diversité
biologique n'a qu'une seule envie c'est
de vivre et au milieu de ces levier là
et c'est dans ce contexte de levier-là
que sincère les les NBT ou les NGT comme
on veut donc les nouvelles techniques
d'édition du génome c'est une
technologie et comme on a eu l'occasion
souvent d'en parler la technologie ne
dit rien de l'endroit où on veut aller
et voilà la vraie question que l'on a
sur les l'édition du génome c'est à quoi
on l'utilise et comment on l'utilise
donc ça c'était le deuxième levier le
troisième levier c'est tout ce qui va
concerner les agro-équipements et je
vais les étendre en les tendant à la
question du digital c'est quelque chose
qui compte aujourd'hui est assez peu
mobilisé hormis l'évolution sur les
techniques de pulvérisation de précision
mais on voit apparaître des potentiels
absolument considérables sur le
désherbage mécanique alors tout le monde
connaît le principe des bineuses mais il
y a des offres aujourd'hui par des
constructeurs et notamment le plus
avancé dans ce secteur là est un
constructeur allemand qui s'appelle
Lemken qui a fait une bineuse qui
viennent à la fois entre les rangs et
sur le rang avec une efficacité
totalement absolument redoutable tout ça
est piloté par des capteurs qui
reconnaissent les plantes et par un
outil d'aide à la décision fin de pardon
de une intelligence artificielle qui est
capable de piloter tous les droits les
doigts qui courent en dessous de cette
machine là et elle le fait en fait avec
une vitesse de déplacement qui est très
élevée puisque la machine peut se
déplacer jusqu'à 8 km/h sans jamais
couper la moindre plante que vous
cherchez à protéger il y a des robots le
plus robot le plus intéressant c'est le
robot qui s'appelle farm droïne où en
fait on a à la fois c'est le même robot
qui sème et qui désherbe donc il sait en
fait où il a semé les les plantes et
donc il va désherber autour il y a des
avancées sur les drones qui sont
utilisés aujourd'hui pour pour déposer
certains produits de biocontrôle et puis
à des choses auxquelles auxquelles on
pense pas mais qui sont d'une efficacité
redoutable et très peu cher on utilise
par exemple des produits pour faire de
l'éclaircissage sur les pommiers sur les
pruniers sur les les
[Musique]
gérer complètement contrôlé complètement
la charge en fruits et là aussi c'est
très peu cher mais bizarrement très
difficile à adopter puis le dernier
levier c'est celui que vous avez
mentionné sur le déo qui est levier du
biocontrôle en fait le biocontrôle
marque pour l'essentiel une rupture
totale dans la façon de penser la santé
des plantes en fait par rapport et vous
posez la question de est-ce que c'est ce
qu'on fait des pesticides moins
dangereux en fait un pastille il est là
pour l'objectif de tuer le biocontrôle a
pour l'objectif de contrôler et ça veut
dire que vous cherchez à réguler une
population pour la maintenir en dessous
du niveau de seuil mais sans jamais
l'amener à zéro et donc les différents
leviers que vous avez dans le les
différents blocs dans le dans le
biocontrôle il y a quelques substances
naturelles comme le soufre et le cuivre
mais l'essentiel et les grands champs de
développement c'est autour des trois
autres grands leviers pour lequel il y a
des avancées de science qui sont
majeures c'est les micro-organismes et
je rajouterais à ça à cette question des
parents des parents des macros
organismes
pour les coccinelles et les chrysopes
mais à laquelle je rajouterai la
question la technologie des insectes
stériliques c'est-à-dire on régule une
population en mettant des mâles que l'on
a stérilisé comme les la plupart pour la
plupart des
insectes il y a qu'un seul accouplement
et ben en fait si vous mettez des
insectes stériles il y a des mâles
stériles il y a peu de descendants donc
il y a pas la population elle baisse
mais elle n'est jamais mise à zéro en
fait parce qu'il y a toujours quelques
mâles qui traînent le deuxième grand
bloc c'est les micro-organismes et en
fait avec des champs de découverte
absolument considérables qui est la
découverte qui a un microbiote sur le
végétal dans le végétal et un microbiote
du sol et tout ça en fait va moduler à
la fois la façon dont la plante va se
protéger la façon de la plante va se
nourrir c'est un champ d'innovation
absolument considérable et extrêmement
prometteur pouvant aller jusque
l'analyse du microbiote des semences et
utiliser la semence comme étant en fait
nos vecteurs d'un microbiote permettant
la protection de la plante après et puis
le troisième grand bloc c'est les
phéromones
alors les phéromones et les phéromones
c'est la découverte du fait que les
insectes se déplacent en fonction d'un
champ d'odeur et il se déplace que pour
deux raisons la première c'est se
reproduire et la deuxième c'est manger
et ils sont sensibles à très très peu de
composés
organiques donc il y a des composés
organiques volatils sont soit les
composés organiques volatils de
reproduction et donc c'est des
phéromones et si vous saturé un espace
avec des phéromones
le mal ne trouve jamais la femelle
mais il prend son pied en permanence et
c'est une boutade et mais c'est utilisé
en fait à des échelles relativement
grandes dans des vergers ou dans des
vignobles et ça suppose en fait des
organisations collectives parce que si
vous êtes vous pouvez pas faire ça dans
votre jardin si vous avez un arbre en
fait il faut que ça soit sur des
paysages relativement grands et puis le
deuxième élément c'est il se déplace
pour aller se nourrir donc en fait il
repère sa proie sa cible et c'est vrai
pour un macro-organisme comme pour un
puceron qui a envie d'aller manger une
betterave et donc on peut changer en
fait ces paysages olfactif en apportant
très très peu de molécules et donc à ce
moment là on modifie et la traction et
son niveau de d'alimentation bref on
dispose aujourd'hui d'un ensemble de
leviers techniques qui sont à combiner
et avec en plus avec des innovations
fortes extrêmement importantes et je dis
il sera combiné entre eux et ils sont à
combinés avec les molécules chimiques
qu'on utilise en dernier ressort et pas
en premier ressort et ce qui fait qu'en
fait la capacité à bouger elle va varier
selon l'espèce et la culture et la
culture sur lesquelles le champ est plus
élevé vous pouvez difficilement faire
des rotations dans des vignes quoi voilà
donc il y a des il y a des possibilités
qui existent qui sont pas les mêmes
partout et donc il va falloir réfléchir
à tout ça alors la vraie question c'est
pourquoi de compte fait sa bouche pas
plus vite que ce que l'on a vu sur les
dernières années ont d'abord ça bouge
pas plus vite parce qu'en fait il y a un
problématique d'offres qui doit se qui
doit s'aligner mais il y a aussi des
phénomènes ce qu'on appelle en sciences
de gestion les verrouillages sociaux
techniques à savoir l'ensemble du
système est organisé parce que les
phytos c'est facile à utiliser et tu
comptes fait c'est très peu cher par
rapport à l'ensemble du système de
production donc il faut déverrouiller ce
système là et un des acteurs essentiels
au déverrouillage c'est l'aval et le déo
vous posiez la question de qu'est-ce qui
du ressort du seul mode de la production
et comment on associe les autres mais il
peut pas y avoir de mouvement s'il y a
pas Laval qui a un moment donné prend
ses responsabilités là-dedans
et la valent en fait il doit et ça
rejoint le titre de la controverse il
doit aussi anticiper l'évolution de la
demande alimentaire la demande
alimentaire elle bouge elle change et
donc comment on arrive à l'anticiper en
travaillant avec le l'ensemble de la
production jusqu'à la transformation il
y a une question pour le pour le
mouvement qui est la gestion du risque
et donc comment on couvre le risque non
pas d'une maladie mais comment on couvre
le risque de la transition parce que le
déplacement d'un système très connu vers
un autre système engendre un risque et
puis un rôle central sur le conseil et
la formation
il y a un point que je n'ai pas
mentionné qui est quelque chose qu'il
faut obligatoirement réfléchir pour
demain c'est anticiper les effets du
changement climatique dans ce contexte
là ça va avoir une un impact sur les
cultures est-ce que l'on pourrait faire
est-ce que l'on pourra faire et en même
temps savoir un impact sur les risques
liés agresseur et en particulier les
biogresseurs émergents et pour finir je
pense avoir été un petit peu trop long
pour la recherche en fait il y a une
forme de responsabilité autour de ça et
je bouclerai avec le programme
prioritaire de recherche que vous avez
mentionnées il est de la responsabilité
de la recherche d'attaquer des fronts de
sciences si on fait la même chose que ce
qu'on faisait depuis toujours il faut
qu'on arrête d'être chercheur et donc
c'est pour ça qu'on a mis un objectif un
programme de recherche autour de d'une
idée zéro pesticides c'est pas un
scénario prescriptif c'est de dire si on
met ce scénario là quels sont les fronts
de science qu'on est amené à explorer et
c'est ce qui permet d'aller aujourd'hui
de faire des avancées considérables sur
les micro-organismes sur les phéromones
et sur les questions d'épidémie
surveillance voilà ce que je voulais
vous dire le seul président
beaucoup donc tout de suite madame
chancigo vous vous traitez de la
question des rapports entre les
pesticides et l'environnement et l'homme
bonjour bonjour
monsieur le Président
je vais apporter un éclairage un petit
peu un petit peu différent parce que
j'ai abordé la question des pesticides
d'un point de vue historique
de et c'est utile en fait de revenir sur
sur le passé non pas parce que c'est une
question d'érudition mais parce que très
souvent ça éclaire sur des
problématiques actuelles et qu'on ne
peut pas avancer sans avoir la mémoire
de ce qui nous a précédé
les pesticides modernes naissent à la
fin du 19e dans un univers assez
particulier qui sont les États-Unis
d'Amérique
et qui possède une agriculture très
différente de l'ancienne Europe avec des
monocultures beaucoup plus vastes avec
des espèces cultivées qui ne sont pas
originaires de ce continent et qui se
trouve dans un système on va dire
écologique complètement nouveau
imaginez des plantations à perte de vue
d'une seule espèce c'est un peu le le
paradis pour une espèce d'insecte qui
peut se mettre très facilement en
proliférer et comme les espèces
d'insectes ravageurs ravageuses sont
également introduites il se elle se
trouve confronté à la même chose c'est à
dire aucun
aucun concurrent aucun parasite ou
parasitoïde ne pourrait les limiter
cet agriculture est donc frontalement
touché par des questions d'entomophones
vraiment dramatique et le monde agricole
américain réclame une solution technique
scientifique
le gouvernement de Washington dans le
dans les années
70-1870 commissionnent des scientifiques
qui fait des préconisations assez
simples dans les plantations de coton
qui fait face à l'attaque du charançon
du cotonnier c'est de faire de la
polyculture lorsqu'une parcelle est
atteinte par le charançon il faut brûler
la récolte ainsi que les champs à
foisinents et ça c'est quelque chose qui
heurte complètement le monde agricole
qui refuse
d'envisager ce type de solutions on a
des témoignages extrêmement clairs qui
réclament de faire la même agriculture
que son père et son grand-père
les
les agriculteurs expérimentent
énormément de choses ils sont très
imaginatifs par exemple de faire courir
sur le sol des câbles électriques pour
électrocuter les larves qui vivent dans
le sol bien évidemment ça n'a aucune
efficacité et il se tourne vers divers
procédés chimiques que ça soit du
pétrole ou que ça soit et surtout de
l'arsenic l'arsenic va devenir la
molécule phare de cette agriculture
comme d'ailleurs c'est la molécule
phare de de l'Occident on la retrouve
absolument de partout notamment et je
cite souvent ça parce que ça montre cet
usage dans les bonbons pour enfants
parce que ça donne une jolie couleur
verte
cesarsenics sont produits en Allemagne
il y a pas d'industrie réellement
chimiques aux États-Unis et quand on
regarde la
littérature agricole on est fasciné de
voir à partir de ces années 1870 la
multiplication de tout ce qui est
appareillage pour pulvériser y compris
sur des surfaces très grandes ou des
végétaux très hauts de l'arsenic
c'est
cette question va changer radicalement
avec l'arrivée de la première guerre
mondiale et le blocus qui limite les
importations de produits chimiques
venant d'Allemagne et va se développer
sur le sol américain les grandes
compagnies chimiques que l'on connaît
aujourd'hui
la fin de la guerre entraîne un
recyclage cette industrie chimique vers
la production
davantage de pesticides d'autant que il
y a une arme de guerre qui va être
également recyclée à savoir les avions
et les pilotes qui reviennent du front
et on assiste aux premiers épandages
aériens
cette question est intéressante parce
que pour la première fois durant
l'entrée de guerre on voit apparaître
aux États-Unis toujours les premiers
mouvements de conservateur de
consommateurs et en 1933 paraît un livre
absolument passionnant de deux militants
de la cause des consommateurs qui
attirent l'attention sur les dangers
qu'il y a à s'alimenter mais également
les dangers que l'on a à se soigner ou à
prendre utiliser des produits de beauté
en raison des risques sous-jacents
ils estiment que le
dans une analyse qui est assez
foudroyante à lire par rapport aux
problématiques actuelles que le grand
problème est un problème en fait de
fonctionnement de la démocratie parce
que les grandes compagnies en fait
empêchent la circulation des
informations
libres et objectifs et bien sûr humili
pour la fabrication de cette
connaissance
l'arrivée de la Seconde Guerre mondiale
va marquer une étape décisive dans
l'accélération de l'utilisation des
pesticides
notamment parce que l'armée américaine
fait face à deux problèmes liés aux
insectes le paludisme sur le front du
Pacifique parce que les troupes
japonaises ont occupées l'Indonésie il
n'y a plus d'obtention de quinine
nécessaire
soigner le paludisme et sur le front
européen il y a la menace du typhus qui
peut ravager comme le paludisme
d'ailleurs une armée beaucoup plus
efficacement que les armes et demi
les États-Unis vont découvrir le DDT qui
est mise au point du moins la toxicité à
l'égard des insectes et découvertes par
un chimiste suisse qui de façon très
neutre propose sa molécule tant aux
forces de l'Axe aux alliés
les Allemands en fait ne sont pas
intéressés par le DDT parce qu'ils ont
assez de stocks de produits
végétaux et par contre pour les
Américains l'intérêt est très grand et
le premier usage va se faire à Naples où
il y a un début d'épidémique typhus
et on observe en fait la première
pulvérisation comme arme j'irai de
guerre même si ça ne change absolument
pas la direction du conflit
ça c'est en 43 en 46 on observe le
premier cas de résistance chez des
insectes justement à Naples les choses
sont extrêmement vides dans le monde des
petites bêtes
et en 45 il y a un engouement absolument
fabuleux à l'égard du DDT qui est
considéré comme la bombe atomique de
l'insecte qui est capable en fait de
résoudre définitivement tous les
problèmes posés par par les insectes
quel qu'il soit et immédiatement
également n'est toute une activité de
d'examen attentifs et critiques de cela
de la part d'associations de naturalisme
qui ont des tailles largement
supérieures qu'on peut connaître en
France avec les sociétés ou du bon de
protection des oiseaux qui organise des
45 des tables rondes de réflexion sur
ces sur ces usages
et on va voir une production de
littérature scientifique à ces sur ce
sujet absolument important des 45 avec
d'ailleurs des des spécialistes qui
lancent des avertissements en disant que
si on a une substance capable de tuer
tous les insectes en fait l'humanité va
suivre parce que l'humanité ne peut pas
survivre sans insectes
7 littérature qui continue à s'accumuler
ne circule guère en dehors des cercles
soit de naturalisme soit de
scientifiques spécialisés de ces
questions et c'est Rachel Carson en 63
avec son livre printemps silencieux qui
va faire la synthèse de ses
connaissances scientifiques et elle va
faire quelque chose qui va être une
révolution dans le domaine de
l'environnement c'est que jusqu'à
présent ces questions ne comment dire
n'était abordé que par quelques
scientifiques
des instances politiques les producteurs
chimiques et le monde agricole et elle
fait rentrer un nouvel acteur dans cette
question à savoir le grand public Rachel
Carson est quelqu'un d'extrêmement
célèbre sont les c'est une biologiste
marin qui a fait plusieurs ouvrages de
vulgarisation et le deuxième est resté
en tête des ventes du Nord Times pendant
plus d'un an
et elle met en fait au service de cette
cause
sa notoriété et effectivement ça va très
bien marcher parce que son livre va être
vendu à des millions d'exemplaires et va
provoquer en fait la naissance du
mouvement environnemental
contemporains qu'on peut le connaître
et entraîner en 70 l'interdiction du DDT
il est intéressant de noter que Rachel
Carson va être traduite assez vite en
français avec deux modifications
notables d'une part toute sa
bibliographie amputée
ce qui en fait juste une sorte d'essai
c'est plus un ouvrage de synthèse tel
qu'elle l'avait conçu et il est présenté
par Roger him directeur du Muséum comme
une journaliste ce qu'elle n'est pas
puisque c'est une scientifique qui
travaille qui a travaillé longtemps pour
le bureau des pêches
cette question est intéressante parce
que on voit que pendant très longtemps
le développement de cette industrie
chimique et de cet usage de la chimie
s'est faite sans intervention du tout du
ou sans participation du tout du public
il a fallu effectivement une action
particulière pour rendre cette question
visible par le grand public on considère
à schel Carson comme une lanceuse
d'alerte ce qui est faux c'est bel et
bien en fait son travail est
fondamentalement un travail de
vulgarisation scientifique
il est d'ailleurs intéressant qu'il y a
d'autres d'autres sujets qui
effectivement sont très peu abordés par
exemple cette question de la résistance
des insectes qui est connue dès 43 les
premiers exemples de résistance aux
arsenicaux sont
repérés dès les années 20 en 43 ces
théorisé du point de vue de la biologie
évolutive et en fait on se rend compte
que dès que le DDT arrive on sait les
problèmes que ça va faire surgir en
termes de résistance on a une situation
totalement similaire et étudier les deux
en parallèle et absolument fascinant
avec la question des antibiotiques et de
la résistance aux antibiotiques qui
pronostiquait quasiment tout de suite
dès la découverte de la pénicilline sans
que ça entraîne un changement de
pratique il y aura interrogé d'ailleurs
sur l'influence des connaissances sur la
la prise de décision parce que dans
certains cas et dans certains problèmes
liés à l'environnement on a l'impression
que les connaissances savent pas à grand
chose pour prendre des décisions
intelligentes vous êtes l'exemple
absolument contraire et vraiment je vous
en remercie
les la question de ces de ces insectes
posent aussi un autre aspect qui est
largement
ignoré du grand public qui est la
question de l'introduction des espèces
envahissants
on peut d'ailleurs se féliciter d'avoir
eu la chance d'avoir une épidémie de
covid sans insectes vecteur parce que ça
aurait changé je pense pas mal la donne
en termes de contrôle de l'usage des
pesticides
et on assiste à une situation assez
paradoxale contradictoires entre
l'augmentation du nombre d'espèces
envahissantes qui posent des problèmes
absolument
grandissant et redoutable et la volonté
de diminuer l'arsenal chimique il y a
une sorte de contre-indiction cognitive
absolument absolument parfaite le fait
que le public soit peu concerné par ces
questions d'espèces envahissantes
explique peut-être cela
juste pour terminer puisqu'on a fait
référence au chlore des cônes
il y a une grande différence
chronologique entre la France et les
États-Unis en termes de contrôle du
chlordécone et
j'expliquerai cette différence par le
tissu relativement plus faible en France
des associations naturalistes qui n'ont
pas du tout la même taille
aux États-Unis et qui ont une puissance
de frappe absolument considérable en
matière de de d'épaulement de la
recherche scientifique et de diffusion
des connaissances dont on commandait un
don n'a pas du tout d'équivalent c'est
pas la taille du pays qui explique cette
différence c'est vraiment une
popularisation beaucoup plus forte et ça
ça explique sans doute cette difficulté
qu'il y a eu à reconnaître un problème
qui était reconnu depuis assez longtemps
aux États-Unis
mais je crois que c'était très
intéressant d'avoir cette cette vision
historique notamment le DDT et puis la
chlordécone avec quand même une
peut-être puisque avec Catherine qui est
pas là donc je verrai on l'a fait ce
rapport ensemble avec une différence
aussi c'est qu'ils ont un accident aux
États-Unis et quand on a un accident et
quand on a près d'une usine qui
fabriquait la chlordécone qui a brûlé un
certain nombre de personnes qui
souffrent de problèmes neurologiques et
bien
il y a une prise de conscience plus
rapide il y a les deux sur les deux
sûrement alors on a des contraintes de
temps Gérard et Pierre me le rappelait
on va faire 10 minutes de débat ça nous
fait quand même un retard d'une bonne
demi-heure dans l'organisation et on va
essayer
après de le rattraper un peu donc 10
minutes de débat qui souhaite intervenir
donc
Florence et Florence assarade sénatrice
de la Gironde je suis contente que le
vin soit retenu comme un aliment
et non pas comme un mauvais alcool
je remercie le directeur de l'inride de
tout ce qui nous a exposé concernant
l'utilisation des intrants ou des
pesticides ou des phytosanitaires en
viticulture dont nos viticulteurs ont
été stigmatisés
il y a quelques années mais
malgré tout on constate que le climat
change complètement on a une saison
sèche une saison des pluies le cette
année les viticulteurs sont extrêmement
inquiets qui soient bio ou qui soit
traditionnel ou en Haute Qualité
Environnementale l'utilisation des des
intrants va être considérable malgré les
techniques dont vous nous avez parlé de
de
de robotique et autres qui qui qui
améliore au plus près de la plante
l'utilisation de ces de ces produits on
a on a quand même une vie bien
inquiétude sur le sur le ce changement
climatique vers une saison des pluies
bien qu'on est également des problèmes
d'irrigation donc ce problème de l'eau
risque de prendre le pas finalement sur
le phytosanitaire
qu'en est-il des cépages résistants
lorsque les les
INAO enfin l'INAO et les les
AOC
bloque l'évolution et on a un vrai un
vrai sujet là-dessus c'est-à-dire que ça
va beaucoup plus vite que que le climat
va beaucoup plus vite les besoins en
pesticides
augmente or il existe des cépages
résistants mais les les AOC ne veulent
pas forcément évoluer aussi vite voilà
c'est une question simple parce qu'il y
a beaucoup de choses je vais pas parler
de l'extinction des des
j'ai fait un rapport sur biodiversité et
réchauffement climatique également sur
la médecine environnementale donc c'est
des sujets qui me préoccupent
corps avec le les présidents alors on va
prendre toutes les questions et vous
essayez d'y répondre de manière courte
qui souhaite intervenir Catherine
ça fonctionne oui une rapide question en
particulier monsieur huit vous avez
parlé d'un ensemble de mesures qui
pourraient permettre de limiter les
intrants et de lutter alors
effectivement par rapport au fait homon
par rapport au plan de couverture ça
fonctionne on l'a vu avec Jean-yves
quand on a travaillé sur la chlordécone
ça fonctionne pour les bananes par
contre vous avez parlé des betteraves je
fais partie du comité
qui s'occupait des nouveaux nicotinoïdes
sur les betteraves on a vu que toutes
les solutions et le mélange de toutes
les solutions n'étaient pas efficaces et
en tout cas s'il était efficace sur des
parcelles minimales il n'était pas sur
des grandes parcelles et là les
interdictions font que on l'a vu moins
de production de betteraves fermeture
d'usine importation de sucre qui n'est
absolument pas produit dans les bonnes
dans les mêmes qualités donc je faut
savoir qu'est-ce que vous pensez de ces
contradiction
ction merci beaucoup est-ce qu'il y a
d'autres questions
c'est très bien
donc si il y en a pas je vous laisse
répondre tous les deux en conclusion le
plus synthétiquement possible merci
beaucoup
il y a pas de rapport entre le sucre et
le vin la chaptalisation c'est fini
depuis un certain temps un changement
climatique et a contribué dans la
question que vous posez madame la
sénatrice sur le sur la question du 20
et la question en fait de la vitesse à
laquelle il y en ao bouge ou ne bouge
pas en fait ça montre que les
cahiers des charges définis par les
yanao sont des constructions humaines là
où les problématiques d'insectes les
problématiques de climat l'humain a pesé
sur le climat mais c'est chose des
contraintes qui viennent de l'extérieur
et donc la vraie question elle est
comment les cahiers des charges peuvent
évoluer d'une part en fonction de
l'objectif qu'il poursuivent et d'autre
part pour intégrer le changement
climatique comme vous l'avez dit ou
intégrer les problématiques de réduction
des phytos d'autre part et donc l'action
c'est logique enfin les temporalité
d'une part l'élection de cohérence entre
politique publique ou cahier des charges
privées et donc effectivement cette
question là les débattue aujourd'hui
avec lianao et il y a une petite
ouverture qui a été faite par exemple
les cépages résistants qui soient qui
soit autorisés à hauteur de 5 à 10% ce
qu'on appelle les FIFA pour
pour justement permettre la introduction
et puis dans le cadre des cépages
résistants en situation d'appellation
c'est la possibilité de les localiser en
bordure de de parcelle et à proximité
des habitations pour gérer les zones non
traitées et madame la sénatrice
concernant la betterave c'est un sujet
que je connais plutôt assez bien étant
responsable du comité de coordination
technique du plan néonicotinoïde enfin
sorti des néonicotinoïdes la question
elle est intéressante au fait quand vous
la regardez de tas de points de vue en
fait d'abord on inévitablement on est
amené à s'interroger pourquoi on a
commencé à traiter ce plan cette
question des néonicotinés dans des
travaux si tard c'est-à-dire on a dû
attendre la catastrophe de 2020 on a de
fait perdu 27% de de la production en
moyenne française alors qu'on sait
depuis 2014 que l'on va sortir des
choses et en fait il a fallu qu'on
attende d'être dans le mur pour
commencer à dire qu'est-ce qu'on fait ça
montre en fait juste que on est
extrêmement verrouillé autour d'un
intrant qui était un intrant
incroyablement simple
savoir que il est tellement simple qu'on
avait même pas à l'appliquer vu qu'il
était sur la graine et il nettoyait
absolument tout vu que les
néonicotinoïdes en fait on tape sur une
cible qui est partagée par l'ensemble
des insectes et un grand nombre
d'arthropodes et donc
de fait c'était le vide alors c'était le
Silent Spring appliqué aux parcelles de
betterave et en plus avec des produits
qui sont systémiques donc qui circulent
dans la plante et qui ont un temps et le
vrai problème il est celui-là en fait
une des demi-vie incroyablement vu que
on a utilisé pendant longtemps de
luminacloprint qui a une demi-vie 228
jours ça veut dire que beaucoup au bout
de 228 jours vous avez encore 50% du
produit qui est dans le milieu et donc
si vous faites deux fois ça vous avez
encore 25% ce qui fait qu'au bout d'un
an et demi vous avez encore dans le plan
dans le sol suffisamment de produit pour
flinguer à peu près tout ce qui
ressemble à un insecte donc de fait il
fallait sortir de ce truc là alors quand
on dit en fait ça ne marche pas et
effectivement les au bout de deux ans de
travaux les les différents leviers sont
pas tous au même niveau de maturité les
variétés résistantes ou plutôt les
rentes elles sont juste encore en cours
de création et les et les autres leviers
ils sont tous des leviers à effet
partielle et c'est là que je dis c'est
le point central c'est il y a pas
d'alternative effectivement le monde des
betteraviers
ce après quoi il court c'est le produit
qui fera exactement la même chose donc
ils rêvait d'avoir un insecticide qui
appliqué en foliaire ferait la même
chose en nettoyant absolument tout
ce que l'on sait c'est qu'il faut
utiliser nvid différents et donc les n
de vie qu'on utilise c'est effectivement
travailler sur des variétés qui vont
supporter une présence de virose
deuxième point c'est retarder énormément
l'arrivée des pucerons alors les
pucerons on est capable de modéliser
aujourd'hui pratiquement au jour près le
jour ils vont arriver des qu'on arrive
aucun février et qu'on a enregistré les
températures on peut vous dire donner
une carte cette annonce et tromper de 0
jours voilà quel que soit l'endroit où
on était c'est lié au fait que les dates
à laquelle ils arrivent est lié à une
courbe exponentielle de développement
dans le début est basé sur les
températures
donc on connaît leur date d'arrivée si
l'arrivée très précoce bah il faut peser
pour que quand ils arrivent ils se
développe très peu d'où le fait qu'on
utilise un levier qui est les plantes
campagnes alors ça pour le monde
agricole c'est très compliqué à
comprendre parce que on dit on fait des
betteraves qui sont très sensibles à la
compétition et on ajoute quelque chose
d'autre il faut l'ajouter pour couvrir
le risque s'il est très précoce ensuite
on joue sur des des phéromones
c'est-à-dire des de produits répulsif il
y a des choses qui sont testées cette
année en très grande échelle et les
résultats que j'ai depuis la semaine
dernière montre qu'on arrive à réduire
de façon extrêmement forte la population
de pucerons à très grande échelle ce qui
est plutôt une très bonne nouvelle et on
réduit la population mais on maintient
le même niveau de la population de des
auxiliaires ça veut dire qu'ils prennent
le relais et donc ça c'est plutôt un
très très bon point et puis le troisième
levier qui a enlevé qu'on n'avait pas
identifié au début qui était de dire il
faut qu'on réduise les réservoirs viraux
c'est un puceron il nait il est propre
donc s'il a aucun endroit où il peut
aller récupérer un virus bah il peut
venir il fera rien et en fait la
question c'est où sont les réservoirs
environ et on sait aujourd'hui qu'ils
sont à deux endroits pour l'essentiel
puis enfin deux et demi je vais donner
le demi après le premier c'est que dans
le sud du Bassin parisien il y a 800
hectares de production de semences de
betteraves qui sont semés à l'automne et
récolter au printemps d'après et donc en
fait ils font la jointure entre deux
saisons et ils sont plein de virus tous
les virus sont dedans dans toutes les
parcelles et l'autre c'est toutes les
repousses de betteraves il y a 400000
hectares de betteraves en France
ça a quasiment pas bougé il y en a 50%
pour l'essentiel c'est suivi par une
céréale et 50% de céréales sont semées
en semis direct ça veut dire que tous
les résidus de culture de la culture
d'avance sont encore à la surface du sol
il y a en moyenne sur les 80 tonnes
qu'on récolte il y a une tonne qui n'est
pas récolté c'est des petites betteraves
elles restent à la surface du sol on a
rien perdu sauf qu'elles vont repousser
au printemps d'après et elles vont faire
des feuilles et ça va devenir des
sources pour les virus et en fait faut
changer les programmes de désherbage sur
les céréales
vous allez dire j'ai dit qu'il fallait
mettre moins de désherbant bah oui il
faut apprendre à les gérer aussi pour
que en fait on passe un antidicote avant
l'antigraminées et puis il y a ce qui
s'appelle les cordons de des terrasses
c'est-à-dire quand les silos sont
récoltés et ils sont récoltés la terre
reste là et elle il y a des tas de
repousses en fait c'est des montagnes de
feuilles de betterave et quand vous
regardez c'est tout plein de virus et
donc il faut les apprendre à les gérer
et l'élément intéressant je le disais
c'est maîtrise de prévu juste avant
c'est qu'en fait cette année on a tiré
cette sonnette d'alarme auprès des
professionnels et en fait cette année il
y a une action extrêmement forte de tous
les agriculteurs pour qu'il y ait pas se
repoussent là
il y a pas il y a pas de solution
miracle les miracles il y en a plus
depuis longtemps et sur ce truc là ça va
être la combinaison de N levier qui va
permettre d'y arriver et moi je suis pas
inquiet objectivement ça va supposer que
la représentation que l'on fait se fasse
de cet objet là change beaucoup au cours
du temps mais on va y arriver
oui c'est vraiment le point je pense le
plus important c'est que toutes ces
questions qui semblent relever de la
biologie que ça soit de l'écologie de la
biochimie de la génétique etc soit
associer sans doute je vais faire la
promotion pour m'échapper aux sciences
humaines et sociales pour qu'on
comprenne les mécanismes qui peut
freiner en fait l'adoption de de
nouvelles techniques le fait de quels
sont les freins au changement pourquoi
le changement fait peur pourquoi il peut
y avoir des attentes contradictoires par
exemple dans le grand public c'est clair
qu'il y a à la fois une sorte de
détestation rampante des pesticides et
en même temps de détestation tout à fait
flagrante des insectes on imagine pas
comment dire vivre en paix et en
harmonie et ça ça relève effectivement
d'une approche qui mériterait vraiment
d'être conduite toujours en parallèle
pour pas oublier une partie de la
question merci beaucoup donc de une
minute de conclusion
après cet échange passionnant je
retiendrai que finalement il faut
revenir à l'histoire pour comprendre la
situation présente car il y a 50 ans les
objectifs de production de masse d'une
CEE autosuffisante d'une baisse des
coûts de production d'un marché
intérieur protégé d'un cours accru aux
intrants que ce soit les fertilisants ou
les pesticides une tendance lourde à la
productivité et la mécanisation la
consommation de masse et bien on avait
assigné à l'agriculture un certain
nombre de tâches et finalement c'est
grâce à des produits de synthèse qui y
sont parvenus
aujourd'hui la situation elle est
différente puisque on mesure un certain
nombre d'impacts de la politique qui a
été menée j'ai noté de la part de
Christian huygues dans ces solutions
le fait d'avoir moins de spécialisation
d'avoir plus de diversité sur les mêmes
lieux ça va être long parce qu'il y a
des régions françaises qui sont des
régions spécialisées entièrement donc
pour arriver à le modifier ça va être
relativement long et j'ai retenu une
chose majeure pour moi dans le dans la
polémique et dans la controverse c'est
que le zéro pesticide sur lequel
travaille les chercheurs ceux qui est
normal n'est pas prescriptif il cherche
des solutions et finalement je crois que
Christian Huy a bien résumé les choses
c'est des combinaisons et des bouquets
de solutions qui permettront de parvenir
à ce qui est l'objectif
maintenir et non pas réduire les
pesticides et maintenir je reprends le
terme la protection des cultures et je
crois que c'est c'est ce qui est c'est
ce qui est majeur dans ce sujet là il
faut des bouquets de solutions tous les
tous les solutions et Catherine vient de
parler poser une question sur une de ces
solutions on avait travaillé sur les
phéromones avec Catherine sur le
charançon du bananier mais
les bouquets de solutions c'est majeur
or et c'est l'importance de de d'avoir
les sciences humaines et sociales avec
les sciences et techniques or il y a des
refus de certaines solutions
Gérard disait tout à l'heure c'est les
mêmes qui refusent le nucléaire et les
énergies renouvelables enfin les
éoliennes et et là c'est c'est les mêmes
qui réclament l'interdiction des
produits de synthèse et qui refusent les
NBT et et et et on l'a vu ce qui veut
donc dire que les solutions par bouquet
il faut les analyser et et notre
collègue sénatrice parlait de la vigne
dans le dans le rapport que nous avons
fait encore avec Catherine procacia on a
été un couple
prolifique prolifique prolifique mais au
niveau scientifique
et donc avec avec dans ce rapport sur la
vigne on avait un peu tenté l'inrae
Christian s'en souvient en disant que
vous aviez mis du temps quand même à
finalement parce que vous aviez un peu
peur des réactions politiques
les réactions résistantes à l'oïdium ou
au mildiou or on disait de manière très
nette et très forte il vaut mieux quand
même une plante résistante plutôt que
d'utiliser même si c'est encore autorisé
je suis le fait de cuivre à très forte
dose parce qu'il y a un impact on n'a
pas mesuré vous avez parlé du cuivre et
du feu et du soufre il y a quand même
des impacts sur les sols je sais pas
s'ils sont toujours analysés et donc ce
bouquet de solutions y compris avec les
nouvelles technologies numériques les
nouvelles technologies d'agroécologie
les nouvelles technologies de
biocontrôle des nouvelles technologies
génétiques et bien ça doit permettre
d'arriver non pas à faire cesser la
controverse mais peut-être attendre
comme pour le nucléaire énergie
renouvelable tout à l'heure attendre
vers un consensus sur ces sujets
voilà tu feras un excellent
[Rires]
j'ai déjà donné
bien sans plus tarder nous allons passer
à la troisième controverse je laisse la
parole à Catherine
j'invite madame Cécile barrière Trika à
venir à côté de Monsieur Thierry
caquet pour cette troisième controverse
alors si j'ai bien compris pas de pause
désolé pour chacun d'entre vous nous
allons essayer de tenir dans les temps
alors cette troisième table ronde va
parler de la décarbonation c'est une
technique qui s'est imposée et qui
devient un des objectifs prioritaires de
nos politiques environnementales alors
en la matière les technologies nous
offrent quelques perspectives
prometteuses complémentaires de nos
efforts de réduction des missions en
tout cas c'est bien l'intitulé de cette
table ronde alors on est à l'office on
fête les 40 ans
fait-on nous aussi puisque j'ai qu'en
2006 j'en avais vaguement le souvenir
nos collègues Christian Bataille et
Claude Béraud avait présenté un rapport
sur les nouvelles technologies de
l'énergie et la séquestration du dioxyde
de carbone il portait déjà une attention
particulière sur le CSC puis plus
récemment notre ancien collègue Roland
Courtot a publié début 2018
stocké plus de carbone dans les sols
études qui a été prolongée en 2020 avec
celle de notre collègue députés Jean-Luc
furgite dans un rapport sur
l'agriculture et la production d'énergie
bon à l'origine de ces travaux une
interrogation était-il pertinent
d'envisager la neutralité le carbone à
l'aide des technologies de stockage de
CO2 où serait-ce une illusion pour
continuer à reproduire à l'identique les
modes de production et nos perspectives
de croissance c'est bien un thème de
controverse
j'observe que les connaissances
scientifiques nous montrent qu'il existe
déjà des solutions pragmatiques mais
elles sont complexes à mettre en oeuvre
mais dans tous les domaines monsieur lui
qui vient de le montrer il y a deux
grandes technologies qui cohabitent
d'une part le stockage accru du carbone
dans les sols avec l'initiative 4 pour
1000 dont Monsieur caca nous parlera
dans un instant je pense et d'autre part
le captage et la séquestration du
carbone avec ou sans utilisation CCS ou
CCUS qui est davantage la spécialité de
Madame Barrère Trica
au-delà du réel potentiel de ces
technologies pour lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique et alors je
rappelle que le gouvernement vient de
lancer une consultation sur la stratégie
CCUS d'autres enjeux corollaires sont
mentionnés comme l'acceptibilité sociale
de ces technologies par les citoyens
accompagnement des industriels et des
agriculteurs sur des procédés possible
mais coûteux exigeants et qui
nécessitent des adaptations de nos
systèmes productifs c'est un enjeu
important pour notre industrie et pour
certains secteurs ou il n'existent pas
de solutions de décarbonation
telle les secteurs du ciment de la chaux
de la chimie ou de la métallurgie donc
voilà tel est l'objet de cette
controverse qui représente le parfait
sujet scientifique monsieur le Président
et technologique
dont l'approche de lopex peut éclairer
l'action publique sans oublier comme je
l'ai dit la continuité depuis presque 20
ans des travaux de l'OPEX sur ce sujet
je laisse la parole à nos deux
intervenants d'abord monsieur caca qui
est directeur scientifique environnement
à l'inrae spécialiste du stockage du
carbone dans les sens dans les sols que
je crois on qualifie
d'insatiable curieux de la nature je
l'ai vu monsieur Google et Madame Cécile
Barrère Trika qui est directive de
Lifen qui est spécialiste comme je l'ai
dit du captage de CO2 avec le cas
échéant en utilisation avec les
différentes méthodes et des flammes qui
maintenant veut développer les
technologies innovantes après nous
aurons comme pour les précédentes tables
rondes une discussion avec le public je
vous laisse la parole
merci madame la sénatrice monsieur les
présidents mesdames messieurs tout
d'abord merci de m'inviter de participer
à cette controverse cette table ronde
pour parler effectivement d'un sujet qui
doit tous nous concerner qui est le
sujet des sols alors on va parler
carbone dans les sols mais je voudrais
introduire mon propos en rappelant
simplement à une évidence c'est que les
soldes de la planète sont des ressources
finies des ressources certes
renouvelables mais à une échelle de
temps qui dépasse largement une vie
humaine et donc c'est un patrimoine
qu'il nous faut protéger parce qu'il est
menacé gravement menacé par l'érosion
par les contaminations chimiques vous
avez évoqué l'accordéon tout à l'heure
la salinisation n'a désertification le
tassement des sols tout un ensemble de
processus dont un bon nombre sont sous
le contrôle humain finalement où sont
des conséquences des actions humaines et
il suffit de prendre un chiffre c'est le
chiffre de la Commission européenne qui
nous dit qu'actuellement en Europe entre
60 et 70% de nos sols sont dégradés il
vous aura pas échappé la proposition qui
est sortie hier de la Commission
européenne d'une directive sur sol
monitoring
effectivement il y a un enjeu très très
fort à protéger nos sols à reconquérir
la qualité des sols y compris du point
de vue de la biodiversité puisqu'on
évoquait la biodiversité juste avant je
vous rappelle que 1/4 de la biodiversité
terrestre et dans les sols et on la
connaît très peu on la découvre tous les
jours notamment en ce qui concerne la
diversité microbienne et donc quand on
regarde le la question climatique et
qu'on aborde la question de
l'atténuation du changement climatique
effectivement on se tourne assez
rapidement vers le compartiment des sols
parce que finalement c'est l'un des
compartiments qui permet j'allais dire
on verra les solutions technologiques
réellement mais du point de vue
simplement biologique de stocker du
carbone à long terme parce que il y a
tout un ensemble de processus
biologiques dans les sols qui permettent
de stocker carbone de le stabiliser en
tout cas on l'espère on va y revenir
parce que c'est un vrai élément de
controverse peut-on stabiliser le
contenu en carbone des sols et lorsque
l'on regarde finalement les projections
notamment dans le cas de la stratégie
nationale de la bas carbone et bien on
arrivera à une neutralité carbone 2050
que si des puits naturels notamment plus
des puits technologiques qui permettent
de compenser les émissions résiduelles
c'est à dire c'est des rémission des
émissions pardon qu'on ne pourra pas
réduire autrement et donc dans la
dimension naturelles de la neutralité
carbone on va trouver deux grands objets
la biomasse biomasse Forestia par
exemple c'est pas l'objet de la table
ronde mais on pourrait y revenir si vous
le souhaitez et puis les sols qui vont
pouvoir effectivement avec différents
processus biologiques stockés du carbone
de manière plus ou moins permanente
alors vous avez évoqué madame la
sénatrice dans votre propos liminaire
l'initiative cap pour 1000 donc c'est
une initiative qui a été lancée je pense
que beaucoup de gens s'en souviennent
lors de la Coop de la Conférence des
Parties sur le climat 21 donc en France
en 2015 et en fait c'est une idée un peu
tout comme tout à l'heure le zéro
pesticide qui évoqué monsieur le déo
c'est vraiment plus que une prescription
c'est une vision de ce que l'on pourrait
faire avec les sols pour compenser en
partie nos émissions je on va faire tout
le calcul il est très bien détaillé
d'ailleurs dans la note que vous avez
évoquée la nôtre de l'OPEX c'est de dire
finalement quand on regarde le surplus
d'émissions de CO2 et de carbone dans
l'atmosphère liés aux activités humaines
ce que les plus naturels n'arrivent pas
à compenser et bien si on arrive à
augmenter alors c'est une vision de
manière uniforme sur la surface de la
planète la teneur en carbone des sols
alors selon les gens qui ont proposé ces
approches soit sur 30 cm ou un mètre peu
importe de 4 pour 1000 par an de manière
continue et là on commence à toucher du
doigt une difficulté et bien on arrive à
capter finalement chaque année le
surplus d'émission alors ça ne réduit
pas le CO2 déjà présent par contre on
arrive à compenser nos émissions qui ne
sont pas compensées par d'autres puits
donc ça c'est l'idée fondatrice du cas
pour 1000
et ça part aussi d'un constat c'est que
lorsque indépendamment de toute
objective climatique on augmente la
teneur en carbone organique en matière
organique des sols on a tout un tas de
CO bénéfices en premier lieu pour
l'agriculture elle-même et la production
alimentaire qui était le sujet de la
Table Ronde précédente tout simplement
pourquoi parce que dans beaucoup de
régions du monde là j'ai parlé de
l'Europe avec ses sols dégradés mais
dans beaucoup de régions du monde la
fertilité des sols la productivité des
sols est limitée par la matière
organique présente ce sont des sols qui
sont en voie désertification on voit de
dégradation et donc de permettre la
réintroduction de carbone organique dans
les sols ça va être favorable à la
production agricole ça a bénéfice bien
sûr pour la biodiversité et ça a des
bénéfices aussi sur la rétention de
l'eau par les sols et ça a été évoqué
aussi tout à l'heure la question de
l'eau devient une question de pregnante
y compris dans notre pays et donc des
sols enrichis en matière organique sont
aussi des sols qui retiennent mieux
l’eau et donc la réserve utile en eau
des sols donc l'eau disponible pour les
plantes est plus élevée si la matière
organique augmente donc ça c'est un peu
la vision du cadre pour 1000 c'est de se
dire des mesures sans regret si on
arrive par différents leviers sur lequel
je vais revenir à augmenter cette teneur
en matière organique des sols on aura un
effet sur le climat latination et on
aura des effets collatéraux positifs
dans une démarche qui pour moi doit être
totalement combiné à la dénation qui est
l'adaptation de l'agriculture au
changement climatique et plus largement
l'adaptation des écosystèmes au
changement climatique alors quand on
reprend maintenant plutôt une vision
France centrée on pourrait dire
finalement la France dans tout cela
quelle est notre statut évidemment
vis-à-vis de ces questions de carbone
dans les sols alors on a la chance en
France d'avoir un une initiative qui
s'appelle le réseau de mesure de la
qualité des sols qui est portée par les
pouvoirs publics en l'occurrence le
ministère en charge de l'agriculture et
le ministère en charge de
l'environnement doivent une structure
qui s'appelle le Groupement d'Intérêt
scientifiques sur les sols le gisol qui
a lancé des campagnes systématiques de
mesure de la qualité des sols sur
l'ensemble du territoire métropolitain
dans un premier temps et maintenant dans
les territoires ultramarins avec une
revisite régulière sur une grille
géographique très très précise des
parcelles forestières agricoles de
prairies ou de chants grandes cultures
pour mesurer un certain paramètre dont
le carbone des sols et donc on a une
carte graphique très précise qui va être
revisité qui est en cours de revisite
avec la deuxième campagne de ce réseau
qui nous permettra de voir si les
premières mesures qui ont été prises
après la COP 21 ont donné déjà des
premiers résultats parce que c'est très
long le carbone des sols à se stocker
alors qu'est-ce qu'on peut dire sur le
l'état de la situation en France en tout
cas tel que le montre ce réseau en
2017-2018 c'est qu'on a des sols qui
sont hétérogènes bon on le sait la
France est pas homogène vous le savez
tous et on a des stocks de carbone assez
important dans les sols forestiers qui
sont lorsque les forêts sont matures
plutôt en stabilité il y a pas de
déstockage il y a pas de stockage
supplémentaire
en gros c'est 80-90 tonnes de carbone
par hectare qui sont stockés là et puis
dans les 33e centimètres et puis on a
des zones qui sont déficitaires qui sont
les zones de grandes cultures donc le
Grand Bassin parisien une bonne partie
du Sud-Ouest le couloir rodinien ou
finalement les teneurs en carbone des
sols sont nettement plus faibles et en
gros 50% de moins que dans les zones de
prairies ou dans les zones de forêt et
donc dans ces endroits on a la capacité
et c'était l'objet d'une étude qui a été
rendue publique en 2019 par inrae de
pouvoir déployer des leviers
agronomiques ou de gestion des effluents
par exemple de gestion des matières
organiques qui permettent d'augmenter la
teneur en carbone des sols et on est
arrivé à faire des estimations assez
quantitatives qui permettent de dire que
en déployant l'ensemble des leviers que
l'on connaît donc découvert en
interculture couvrir les sols entre deux
cultures principales introduire de
l'agroforesterie faire du semis direct
tout un ensemble de leviers que les
agriculteurs connaissent et bien on peut
augmenter dans ces zones qui sont
actuellement les plus déficitaires de
l'ordre de 4 à 5 pour 1000 par an
pendant une trentaine d'années donc on a
une capacité à faire d'un point de vue
théorique après ça pose des questions de
nature très différentes la première
question étant de dire est-ce que ce
stockage finalement avec des processus
naturels c'est la minéralisation de la
matière organique par les
micro-organismes des sols et constant et
permanent et là première mauvaise
nouvelle on sait que lorsqu'il y a par
exemple un retournement de prairie on
passe d'une prairie un champ cultivé on
va perdre du CO2 qui va repartir dans
l'atmosphère donc ça c'est une première
limite deuxième limite des phases de
sécheresse comme on l'a connu en 2022 et
d'autres avant mais on s'attend à ce que
sous l'influence du changement
climatique ces phases de sécheresse soit
plus fréquentes et plus intenses on
déstocke aussi massivement du CO2 par
des processus de minéralisation de la
matière organique c'est le vivant
catalogue on contrôle pas et donc on va
on peut reperdre du carbone donc il faut
toujours penser que le stockage il n'est
pas définitif en tout cas pas sur une
trentaine d'années faut attendre
beaucoup plus longtemps
après c'est toutes ces mesures tous ces
leviers ont un coût de déploiement donc
l'étude que j'évoquais alors il faudrait
révéler l’écoute mais nous montre que
les différents leviers en gros c'est
entre en étant très schématique 10 20
euros par tonne de carbone et par
hectare et par an jusqu'à une centaine
d'euros par hectare donc ça a un coût
pour les agriculteurs ce qui nous amène
à une vision indispensable par rapport
au levier agronomique au levier on va
dire biologique que l'on peut employer
sur le terrain qui est le modèle
économique du stockage de carbone dans
les sols parce qu'on appelle maintenant
beaucoup le carbone farming c'est un
terme qui est maintenant dans le langage
courant y compris au niveau européen
c'est à dire quel est le modèle
économique que l'on a d'os à cette
stratégie de stockage de carbone dans
les sols
avec déjà des initiatives qui existent
portées par le secteur privé où il y a
certains agriculteurs y compris en
France qui ont maintenant des contrats
pour déployer des techniques de stockage
de carbone
plutôt agronomique avec une rémunération
au bout de cinq ans si le contrat est il
y a vraiment une mise en évidence de
l'augmentation du carbone dans les sols
qui est de l'ordre de 30 à façon ça
dépend des projets mais entre 30 et 50
euros la tonne de carbone stocké qui
rémunéré à l'agriculteur pour ce qu'il a
fait donc ça c'est une tendance qui se
développe très fortement avec ben là
aussi je peux pas parler de controverse
mais des questionnements sur finalement
que doit-on prioriser le stockage de
carbone la production alimentaire c'est
des sujets qu'on a un tout petit peu
effleuré ce matin dans d'autres domaines
mais qui sont sur la table finalement
est-ce que ne va pas je dirais
transformer le métier de certains
agriculteurs vers autre chose que la
production alimentaire on pourra y
revenir et je terminerai ce propos
liminaire par un point qui moi me paraît
absolument indispensable stocker du
carbone oui de différentes manières je
rappellerai simplement que les
estimations qu'on a pu faire même avec
le maximum d'efficacité de cette étude
que j'ai évoquée 2018-2019 pardon
ça ne représente
avec les émissions actuelles que de
l'ordre 10 à 12 voir 15% des émissions
donc ça ne sera en aucune manière la
solution pour atteindre la neutralité
carbone à elle seule et puis ne pas
jamais oublier que on parle de CO2 on
parle de carbone mais il y a les autres
émissions qui contribuent au changement
climatique notamment les émissions
d'azote et si il n'y a pas d'azote dans
le sol le carbone ne sera pas stocké et
s'il faut rajouter des intrants azotées
pour stocker du carbone vous imaginez là
c'est une controverse c'est un peu un
dilemme très fort parce que qui dit à
porte d'intrant azoté dit d'abord des
intrants qu'il faut fabriquer donc des
émissions et puis des risques
d'émissions de protoxyde d'azote du N2O
qui est lui aussi un gaz à effet de
serre donc je sais plus qui évoquait
tout à l'heure dans une table ronde
précédente le fait qu'on peut parfois
prendre des solutions qui soient
finalement non pas
gagnant-gagnant mais un bout d'un moment
ça s'avère plus défavorable que si le
statu quo donc soyons prudent avec ces
méthodes il y a des opportunités il y a
des opportunités aussi pour le modèle
économique des expl la version agricole
et puis pour les je dirais un certain
nombre de personnes qui doivent quelque
part compenser leurs émissions dans mon
industriel mais c'est aussi quelque
chose qui est piloté par le vivant et le
vivant il est toujours un peu têtu il a
toujours tendance à faire un peu le
contrat de ce qu'on voudrait qu'il fasse
et sous un climat qui change et je
terminerai là-dessus les solutions qui
paraissent évidentes en 2023 qui
fonctionne déjà qu'on peut voir sur le
terrain rien ne prouve qu'en 2030 2040
dans un climat qui va continuer à
augmenter car elles seront aussi
efficiente donc une solution parmi
d'autres mais qui est quand même
contingente à beaucoup de facteurs
externes sur lesquels on n'a pas encore
tous les éléments de contrôle je vous
remercie
merci madame la sénatrice monsieur le
député monsieur le sénateur mesdames et
messieurs merci beaucoup pour cette
invitation je suis très heureuse de
participer aujourd'hui et apporter un
éclairage sur le captage stockage et
utilisation du CO2
IFP énergie nouvelle on est impliqué sur
ces sujets au niveau de la recherche
innovation depuis déjà plus de 20 ans
donc
aujourd'hui ça revient vraiment sur le
devant de la scène avec la prise de
conscience de l'urgence climatique et en
particulier en France ces dernières
semaines ont été marquées par le Conseil
national de l'industrie le 23 juin
dernier et puis la publication de la
stratégie nationale CCUS qui finalement
compile les retours des 50 industriels
les plus émetteurs de CO2 sur le
territoire qui propose finalement un
plan de décarbonation pour atteindre les
objectifs
fixés par la SNBC notamment et donc
cette compilation a permis au
gouvernement de proposer une feuille de
route qui d'ailleurs est mis en
consultation auprès des acteurs jusqu'à
fin septembre donc le CCUS aujourd'hui
en fait c'est déjà une réalité les
solutions technologiques elles existent
et elles sont utilisées alors on verra
les inconvénients de ces solutions
aujourd'hui et les perspectives
d'évolution mais il faut savoir qu'il y
a quand même 30 unités industrielles de
grande taille dans le monde qui
permettent de capter du CO2 qui ensuite
est stocké ou utilisée ça représente à
peu près 40 millions de tonnes de CO2
déjà captés et on peut même citer que en
mer du Nord en Norvège il y a déjà un
million de tonnes de CO2 injectés dans
des aquifères Salins profonds parents
depuis 25 ans sans difficulté
particulière en tout cas de difficultés
notables mais est-ce que c'est suffisant
donc clairement non on est à 40 millions
de tonnes de CO2 captés si on regarde
les scénarios de l'Agence internationale
de l'énergie ou les différences
scénarios du GIEC on voit clairement
qu'on va être plutôt on va avoir besoin
de capter 8 milliards de tonnes de CO2 à
horizon 2050 donc en fait c'est 200 fois
plus de CO2 qui vont devoir être captés
pour atteindre la neutralité carbone à
horizon 2050 soit une 25 ans à peu près
donc c'est considérable et c'est ce
captage de CO2 alors ça ça rejoint ce
que ce que vous disiez à l'instant ce
n'est qu'une partie de la de la
résolution de du problème et de la
décarbonation les scénarios indiquent
clairement que c'est environ 15% de
l'effort de réduction des émissions de
CO2 qui devrait venir du captage et
stockage ou utilisation du CO2 ça veut
dire que le captage de CO2 il est là
uniquement quand on a fait tous les
efforts en amont nécessaires que ce soit
bien sûr la sobriété mais également
l'efficacité énergétique le passage aux
énergies renouvelables l'électrification
des procédés quand c'est possible de
appliquer les procédés industriels ça
n'est pas toujours mais en tout cas
quand c'est possible il faut le faire le
recyclage etc donc tout ça pour dire que
le captage des stockage du CO2 8
milliards de tonnes à horizon 2050 et ça
représente environ 15% de des efforts de
réduction donc c'est énorme ça veut dire
qu'il y a toute une industrie qui doit
se mettre en place c'est une dizaine de
sites de stockage par an qui doivent
être développés c'est une centaine
d'unités de captage de CO2 par an je
parle au niveau mondial et c'est de
milliers de kilomètres de de
canalisation pour transporter le CO2 qui
doivent être mis en place aussi chaque
année alors le captage des stockage du
CO2 aujourd'hui c'est quelque chose qui
coûte cher et qui consomment quand même
beaucoup d'énergie donc tous les efforts
qui doivent être fait aujourd'hui visent
en fait à réduire le coût de toute cette
chaîne de captage stockage utilisation
de CO2 de réduire au maximum les
consommations d'énergie les pénalités
énergétiques comme on dit pour amener ce
coup là
du niveau qui sont qui sont acceptables
alors les autres enjeux alors je
reviendrai sur la sur les aspects
recherches et notamment en parlant du
PEPR spleen mais il y a aussi un enjeu
très très fort d'acceptabilité sociétale
et ça là-dessus c'est un sujet ça a été
évoqué déjà ce matin
c'est clairement pas du tout évident à
appréhender le stockage de CO2 est
quelque chose qui peut faire peur à nos
citoyens enfin nous concitoyens alors
même que c'est quelque chose qui existe
déjà aujourd'hui en France pour pour le
stockage du méthane donc on stocke déjà
du méthane dans des réservoirs des
plétés dans des aquifères Salins profond
sans me semble-t-il que ça n'est meuf
personnes et demain on parle de de
stocker du CO2 et on sent on sent
arriver quand même une un questionnement
fort des citoyens sur sur cette les
risques associés à ce stockage du CO2
même si le CO2 n'est ni un produit
explosif ni un produit inflammable et
que sauf à être
dans un milieu confiné il y a pas de
risque particulier sur sur la santé
enfin sauf à des niveaux de
concentration
supérieure à 5%. donc il existe donc je
vous disais des technologies de captage
de CO2 que ce soit la précomption ou on
vise à décarboner le combustible avant
son utilisation l'eau psychibition où on
va là pour le coup
faire la combustion à l'oxygène pour
pouvoir produire de la chaleur et en
même temps récupérer de du CO2 pure et
puis enfin les procédés par poste
combustion ou là on vient récupérer le
CO2 à la sortie d'un procédé industriel
ou à la sortie de d'une usine donc si je
reviens sur ce qui a été enfin ce qui
est prévu dans le dans la stratégie
nationale qui vient d'être qui vient
d'être publié l'objectif en fait il est
d'être capable en France à horizon 2030
de capter et stocker 4 à 8 millions de
tonnes de CO2 par an et horizon 2050 15
à 20 millions de tonnes de CO2 par
donc c'est ambitieux ça va représenter
50 milliards d'euros d'investissement
alors tout confondu en toutes les tout
ce qui concerne la décarbonation de ces
industries donc il y a une part pour le
CCS mais pas que et clairement je le
redis parce que c'est important c'est
uniquement pour le CO2 incompressible
une fois que tous les efforts auront été
faits sur sur les autres pistes de
réduction
et dans certains cas c'est indispensable
parce qu'il y a pas les solutions
technologiques pour le faire aujourd'hui
ou moins dans une période de transition
ça va être nécessaire donc voilà donc
cette feuille de route elle est là pour
inciter les industriels à se doter d'une
trajectoire et on leur proposant une un
accompagnement financier une
sécurisation je capte le CO2 mais je
veux être certain que derrière il va
bien pouvoir être transporté et stocké
ou utiliser alors ce que je voudrais
quand même enfin je voudrais insister
sur la recherche et innovation pour
accompagner en fait cette transformation
de l'industrie donc je vous l'ai dit il
y a des travaux qui sont menés depuis
déjà de nombreuses il y a des
technologies avancées qui sont en cours
de démonstration industrielle
actuellement et je voudrais quand même
citer le démonstrateur de captage de CO2
avec des amis qui aujourd'hui en cours
de démonstration à Dunkerque chez
l'ormittal et qui fonctionne extrêmement
bien et donc qui pourrait être capable
demain quand je dis demain c'est
vraiment demain déployer
industriellement sur des chez des
émetteurs enfin des industriels
émetteurs de CO2 en France et puis il y
a d'autres procédés qui sont français
qui sont également en cours de
démonstration en Chine dans le cadre de
projets européens enfin sinon européen
donc la Recherche et Innovation elle se
poursuit et le PEPR spleen de la
stratégie nationale des décarbonation de
l'industrie a été inaugurée la semaine
dernière à Lyon avec comme copilote le
CNRS et
IFN c'est un projet donc un programme
d'équipements de recherche prioritaire
projet programme prioritaire pour
soutenir l'innovation et développer de
nouveaux procédés industriels soient
largement décarbonés donc on est à des
niveaux de TRL qui sont de 1 à 4 c'est
pour passer du concept jusqu'au pilote
et c'est extrêmement important parce que
les travaux qui vont être menés vont
permettre de réduire enfin l'objectif
c'est vraiment de réduire les coûts la
pénalité énergétique en travaillant sur
l'intensification des procédés être
capable d'avoir des procédés plus
compacts plus efficaces qui vont
consommer moins d'énergie moins de
matériaux également électrifier les
procédés aller vers des nouveaux médias
de séparation ou de catalyse pour
travailler à des températures plus plus
basses notamment et donc consommer moins
d'énergie et puis également d'élargir
d'être capable d'élargir le panel des du
captage de CO2 sur des émetteurs de
petite taille sur des concentrations en
CO2 plus faibles avec des impuretés plus
importantes et en particulier je citerai
ça pour terminer il faut pas oublier que
parmi les procédés de captage du CO2 il
va aussi y avoir le captage direct dans
l'air
qui peut paraître comme ça un peu
surréaliste aujourd'hui parce qu'il
s'agit d'aller récupérer du CO2 dans
l'atmosphère ou les teneurs en CO2 sont
extrêmement faibles mais d'après les
scénarios de de la lieu du GIEC c'est
quelque chose qui sera incontournable
pour justement aller vers la
récupération du CO2 dans l'air pour
enfin pour compenser le CO2 qu'on sera
quand même obligé d'émettre dans
certaines situations voilà donc là il y
a vraiment un enjeu aussi de développer
ces technologies et également je
n'oublie pas les becs biomasse énergie
ou là on est sur de des émissions
négatives de CO2 pareil pour compenser
finalement c'est ce CO2 qu'on ne pourra
pas éviter donc la recherche est
innovation est à est à l'oeuvre et
continuer à être à l'oeuvre mais le
captage est le stockage de CO2 pour
conclure c'est quelque chose qui existe
qui peut être déployé mais il faut une
volonté politique et un travail sur
l'acceptabilité sociétale qui soit
vraiment à un niveau important pour pour
que ça puisse devenir une réalité voilà
merci beaucoup
je vais d'abord vous donner la parole à
la salle qui aurait des questions
monsieur
bonjour Alors moi je suis plutôt du côté
robotique intelligence artificielle mais
il y avait quelque chose qui je trouvais
très bien
pardon donc je suis Arnaud Blanchard
ingénieur de recherche au CNRS et ce que
je trouvais c'est que c'est très
intéressant sur les trois les trois
controverses qu'il y a eu c'est qu'il y
avait un peu une même cause commune
c'était Malak consommation d'énergie et
comme la rappeler monsieur Marchal les
grands axes c'est
le déplacement la l'alimentation et la
le chauffage et donc je me demandais par
exemple pourquoi il y avait pas de
question du thème peut-on consommer un
peu moins c'est à dire est-ce qu'il faut
toujours des maillots plus grosses plus
puissantes plus d'avion est-ce qu'on
peut manger un peu moins de viande moins
de sucre j'y avais pas pensé et puis
surtout le thème des biocarburants parce
que ça va être aussi une pression très
forte sur l'agriculture l'agriculture
qui a été deux thèmes problématique
et puis ben le problème de l'eau aussi
ils en ont pas mentionné sur la
viticulteur qui a toujours la même cause
aussi et voilà et donc je me demandais
c'est ce problème de de controverse de
faire par réponse binaire est-ce que
comment on peut faire ou est-ce que bah
il faut faire plein de choses binaires
et peut-être qu'on peut faire peut-on
aller vers un monde où on consomme moins
d'énergie plutôt que d'essayer de
rattraper les symptômes après coup merci
alors c'est un sujet plus large à la
fois de
l'organisation des thématiques de ces
contourses pour cette matinée je pense
qu'effectivement sur l'enjeu de la
consommation énergétique on a rendu la
semaine dernière un rapport que je vous
invite à lire sur le plan de sobriété
énergétique et qui répond justement
aussi à ces enjeux et qui qui les mêle
puisqu'on le voit bien ce sont des
enjeux croisés que ce soit sur
évidemment le sujet primaire des besoins
énergétiques et de sa production
inévitable comme sur les les
sujets qui ont été traités dans dans le
cadre des trois controverses donc c'est
un enjeu qui qui dépasse qui dépassait
largement le cadre de notre thématique
de cette matinée donc nous semblait
difficile de d'avoir une approche
holistique
alors que voilà il y a une il y avait
une volonté justement de de s'atteler
sur des enjeux bien particuliers des
thématiques bien particulières peut-être
que Catherine je vais simplement dire
c'est que le choix de ces thématiques on
avait proposé une vingtaine de sujets et
que ce soit a été un choix fait par des
internautes sur un certain nombre de
controverses on a voulu être le plus
proche possible des attentes
puis peut-être une dernière remarque sur
le rôle les rôles respectifs de l'Office
Parlementaire d'un côté
des deux assemblées et des formations
politiques qui des peuples je veux dire
que nous notre rôle c'est de donner aux
députés sénateurs
en gros l'état de l'art à un moment
donné
ils doivent être amenés à travers le
travail des commissions mais aussi à
travers le travail des groupes
parlementaires bon je crois la politique
et je crois aux convictions politiques
lorsqu'elles sont réfléchies élaborées
compter enfin discuter enrichi
les faits sont têtus si nous établissons
des fêtes études il peut y avoir des des
conclusions d'une nature très différente
j'ai participé un coloc assez
intéressant où il y avait en réalité une
opposition en dehors de la vie par
cisane une opposition entre
solutionniste entre guillemets et des
clinistes pour caricaturer les
solutionnistes ont leur reproche d'être
confiant dans la technologie et les
déclinistes ont leur reproche de ne pas
nous dire comment ils vont obliger les
gens à accepter quelque chose qui ne
souhaite pas profondément on peut dire
oui mais lui
les gens sont ainsi faits qu'ils sont
encore libres sauf avoir des systèmes
très autoritaires que personne ne
souhaite vraiment et donc nous ce que
nous voulons à l'office fait en sorte
que les parlementaires soient éclairés
dans les choix les plus objectifs
ils ont une son majeure et vaccinée à
eux d'en tirer toute une série de
conséquences l'Office n'est pas là pour
se substituer à la conviction mise en
forme et organisée en programme
la façon dont j'ai précisé l'office et
je crois que Pierre n'y est pas
complètement tactile
y a-t-il une autre question
comme j'avais su bien
[Musique]
identifié en ce qui concerne en fait ce
qui est très intéressant pour les sols
c'est en fait l'économie de système et
en effet est-ce qu'il y a une véritable
est-ce qu'il pourrait y avoir une
compétition dans l'usage des sols
et à quelles conditions de prix parce
que
avait approché avancez-vous sur la
proche économique de la gestion tout à
fait si vous permettez je complète
c'est l'économie des sols c'est
l'Économie de l'Industrie
c'est exactement la même problématique
de
revoir l'utilisation des sols et de
revoir comment on produit
est-ce que il suffit de se donner bonne
conscience et est-ce que c'est efficace
et quel est l'accepte l'acceptabilité
aussi bien pour les agriculteurs que
pour les industriels et ça passera par
là
c'est un sujet qui dépasse largement le
sujet du CO2 puisque c'est plus
largement qu'est-ce que l'on souhaite
faire qu'est-ce que l'on veut faire
est-ce qu'on peut faire avec notre
foncier agricole et que font les
agriculteurs et quelle est l'unité de
l'agriculteur une réponse qui m'a me
paraît assez immédiate c'est quand on va
faire une hiérarchie finalement des
usages parce que c'est un peu ça des
sols
en tout cas la vision que sur laquelle
on est assez convergeant une raie et
puis avec d'autres qui sont ici dans la
salle c'est que le premier usage c'est
la production alimentaire humaine
ensuite à partir du moment où il y a de
l'élevage c'est la production
alimentaire pour les animaux et après
les autres usages par exemple production
de fibres pour le bâtiment autre tout ce
qui est on va dire toute la BU industrie
et puis après la production d'énergie
doit venir plutôt à la fin parce que
aller finalement déconstruire ou
utiliser des sols de la matière
organique qui a pris du temps à gérer à
se générer notamment via les plantes par
la photosynthèse ou bien utiliser des
sols pour le direct directement utilisez
ça pour la production d'énergie ça
paraît quand même la dernière limite
donc il une hiérarchie des usages ça
c'est la première réponse et par rapport
à l'aspect économique c'est clair que et
on le sent dans la profession agricole
et en dehors de la profession agricole
il y a une tension actuellement sur
finalement qu'est-ce qui est le plus
rémunérateur qu'est-ce qui serait le
plus rémunérateur entre la production
alimentaire de la production de
biocarburant ou d'autres types d'énergie
et puis d'autres usages des sols et là
on a vraiment un enjeu politique au sens
noble de la politique qui est de dire
quel est le choix de société que l'on
veut faire sur l'usage de ces sols et
comment les acteurs en l'occurrence les
agriculteurs sont rémunérés par qui et
pour quels objectifs et puis le point
qui vient très très vite derrière et
qu'on commence seulement je pense à
aborder c'est la question du foncier
c'est en gros qui est propriétaire de
l'espace sur lequel on va déployer soit
des énergies renouvelables soit de la
production de biomasse pour faire de
l'énergie ou pour faire de l'alimentaire
soit d'autres usages et ça je pense que
c'est un sujet qui est extrêmement
important et qui est un sujet de nature
politique c'est effectivement le
finalement le droit reprendre versus le
bien commun j'évoquais tout à l'heure
les sols comme bien commun et ça ça va
nous interroger vraiment profondément
sur finalement la société que l'on veut
construire avec ces différentes options
il y a pas une option qui est totalement
positive c'est forcément des une
diversité de solutions on parlait de
région ce matin qui devrait être en plus
grande solidarité parce que c'est la
même chose pour les acteurs des
différents secteurs et je pense qu'il y
a une réflexion collective à voir sur le
modèle économique sinon c'est le mieux
disons économique qui risque de
l'emporter et qui a pas forcément la
société vers laquelle on souhaite aller
donc on est très vigilant par rapport à
cela et effectivement le prix de la
tonne de carbone c'est une chose mais la
production alimentaire reste quand même
la priorité en tout cas pour le monde
agricole doit être la priorité
ajoutez à cela dans votre débat
les
ustries pour le la réduction des
émissions de CO2 il est clair que si ça
leur coûte plus cher de le faire que de
ne pas le faire
ça va être compliqué donc c'est pour ça
qu'effectivement c'est extrêmement
important là ce qui a été enfin ce qui
va être mis en place c'est de pouvoir
les encourager à y aller en les en les
accompagnant par des subventions ou par
des contrats les contrats pour
différences là qui risque d'être enfin
qui vont être mis en place les
industriels s'engagent et l'État
s'engagent en face parce qu'aujourd'hui
clairement ça coûte plus cher de en ce
qui concerne le captage des stockage de
CO2 ça coûte en général plus cher que le
prix du CO2 aujourd'hui qui même s'il a
atteint 100 euros par tonne de CO2
éviter au mois de février mars
aujourd'hui dans les meilleurs des cas
on va être à 120 130 euros par tonnes de
CO2 et ça peut monter beaucoup plus haut
si on est loin d'un site de stock voilà
aussi il y a des infrastructures
coûteuses à mettre en place derrière ça
se répercutera sur sur le coup du CO2
éviter donc évidemment que il faut un
accompagnement de l'État là-dessus
surtout dans une logique de
réindustrialisation dans laquelle on est
aujourd'hui voilà c'est c'est
indispensable autrement ça ça ne
fonctionnera pas en tout cas pour
enclencher la la machine et puis
derrière il y aura le lieu déploiement
forcément il y a après un effet
d'échelle et on les réductions des coûts
elles arriveront
ajoutons à cela naturellement la
dimension internationale de votre
analyse parce que
les sols ne sont pas de même nature et
de même capacité et il est possible que
le stockage du CO2 soit se porte une
opportunité pour des seuls qui ne
pourraient pas faire autre chose tout à
fait ça fait partie des éléments alors
je stockage de CO2 mais aussi
l'amélioration de ces sols grâce à ce
stockage qui permettrait de faire une
production qui est peut-être
actuellement est difficile en raison de
conditions climatiques ou pédagogiques
qui sont très contraignantes donc faut
voir aussi les coûts bénéfices mais là
on est sur des sujets plutôt moyen long
terme et donc les choix qu'on fait
maintenant vont engager sur peut-être
30-45 ans et c'est loin d'être évident
prix qui soit à la fois stable acceptée
prévisible
tous les investissements dont nous avons
parlé ce matin sont des investissements
de long terme ils ne peuvent être
imaginés qu'avec un environnement de
prix stabilisé
enfin prévisible exactement pas
forcément stabilisé mais prévisible et
le on en a pas parlé ce matin sur le
nucléaire et le renouvelable mais il est
évident que la tarification de l'énergie
électrique en Europe et une clé de la
solution et nous savons que ce n'est pas
un combat facile parce qu'il y a des des
points de vue très différents et assez
conflictuels en particulier chez les
gens qui sont censés s'entendre être
formé un couple éternel qui porte dans
ses bras le succès de l'Union européenne
bon je ferme la parenthèse chacun aura
des côtés moi je voudrais simplement
terminer cette table ronde pour laisser
le temps à la quatrième pour vous
demander enfin dans le cadre de cette
controverse est-ce que c'est pas une
controverse de monde purement
occidentale et riche
et est-ce que capter le carbone dans les
pays développés n'est pas une illusion
par rapport à la captation du carbone
dans sur la terre entière
si je peux me permettre avant de
répondre je suis pas certain qu'on soit
dans le cadre d'une controverse
précisément telle que moi je la conçois
puisque finalement on a plutôt une
convergence de solutions certes très
différentes mais qui vont dans le même
sens et je pense que les dispositifs de
stockage qu'on évoquait sont pas en
compétition il y a pas de compétition
d'usage pour revenir à votre question
effectivement on n'est pas du tout sur
les mêmes échelles
je reviens sur cette question de mesure
sans regret c'est à dire que l'avantage
du des sols c'est qu'ils sont présents
sur à peu près un tiers ou 30 ans 40% de
la surface de la planète pas tous très
fonctionnel mais il y en a quand même un
certain nombre et que ça permet quand
même d'avoir de manière en accompagnant
un coup de qui peut être quand même
nettement inférieur dans certains pays
par rapport à ce que j'ai dit décrit de
10 à 100 euros par hectare et par an
parce que finalement il y a des des sols
qui sont déjà
très très bas on stock c'est cela qui
sont lesquels il faut intervenir en
premier notamment dans les pays des Suds
et c'est pour ça qu'on y a une
initiative 4 pour 1000 qui a été
développée aussi sur les territoires
ultramarins et dans d'embarquer à
majorité de pays à mon avis le levier le
plus important et le progrès le plus
important il est surfaces les plus
importantes sont dans les pays des Suds
et c'est là qu'on peut avoir rapidement
des gérer des options gagnantes à un
investissement minimal qui serviront à
l'ensemble de la population et c'est pas
pour ça qu'il faut pas faire des choses
aussi en France bien sûr mais la surface
de la France c'est quand même petite par
rapport à la surface mondiale donc les
soldes des sols du monde sont un enjeu
et le stockage de carburant les sols du
monde est un enjeu qui dépasse largement
l'enjeu français et sur lequel on peut
assez rapidement avoir des solutions à
partir du moment on peut déployer et
informer et former les gens pour le
faire il y a excusez-moi la controverse
elle est
en particulier pour le CCS je nie 500
organisations associatives aux
États-Unis
dénonçaient le fait que il prolongeait
la dépendance au combustible fossiles la
percer les larmes faut-il capter et se
rejoint un petit peu
notre première intervenant ou est-ce que
c'est pas revoir complètement nos modes
de production
enfin c'est ce que je disais en fait le
captage est stockage de CO2 ça doit
représenter vraiment le CO2 ultime quand
toutes les autres leviers auront été
activés et notamment la sobriété le
passage aux énergies renouvelables
l'efficacité énergétique et il y a
encore beaucoup de choses à faire à ce
niveau là le recyclage quand on parle de
l'acier par exemple aller vers davantage
de recyclage ou même du les bétons enfin
il y a plein d'enjeux à ce niveau là et
réellement le captage stockage du CO2 je
vous disais c'est environ 15% des
efforts de décarbonation globale au
niveau mondial qui doivent être faits
pour atteindre la neutralité carbone
donc on voit que c'est vraiment
[Musique]
ce n'est pas une
comment dire une raison de de continuer
à polluer c'est vraiment de se dire
si on veut y arriver il faut que tous
les leviers soient activés il faut pas
opposer les solutions technologiques
comme il faut pas opposer le stockage et
l'utilisation du CO2 pour en faire des
molécules d'intérêt toutes les solutions
elles vont être nécessaires clairement
et bien madame Barère tricas ça m'évite
de faire une conclusion parce que je
crois que vous avez résumé parfaitement
les éléments de cette table ronde merci
bien il me revient de présenter pour
cette quatrième et dernière controverse
l'intelligence artificielle est-elle une
menace sujet plus que jamais d'actualité
au vu des évolutions technologiques que
l'on connaît en matière d'intelligence
artificielle pour cela j'ai le plaisir
d'accueillir donc Laurence Devillers qui
est professeur d'informatique appliqué
aux sciences sociales
et également monsieur Raja satila qui
est professeur de robotique et dans
l'intelligence artificielle également
membre de notre conseil scientifique
très heureux de vous accueillir tous les
deux pour cette controverse je vais tout
d'abord dire quelques mots concernant ce
sujet pour apporter quelques éclairages
sur les enjeux en me fondant en
particulier sur certains travaux de
l'Office qui ont pu être
depuis sa naissance en 1956 lors de la
conférence fondatrice de d'art smooth
l'intelligence artificielle n'a jamais
cessé de susciter des interrogations
quant à sa dangerosité près de 70 ans
plus tard les médias continuent de se
demander si elle est une menace en 2016
nos anciens collègues Claude deganet et
Dominique Gillot ont rendu le premier
rapport parlementaire de France sur
l'intelligence artificielle avec ce
titre pour une intelligence artificielle
maîtrisée
utile et démystifier selon les
observations cycliques l'intérêt pour
l'intelligence artificielle et la menace
qu'elle représenterait fluctue dans le
débat public à l'heure de tchat jeepetty
et de desia génératives on voit là tout
l'intérêt à la fois des travaux de
l'office de faire en sorte d'actualiser
les évolutions technolog et également
les évolutions dans le débat public dans
ce rapport de l'office de 2016 il
constatait que les technologies
d'intelligence artificielle progressent
de manière exponentielle et je pense
qu'on a pu voir notamment sur les enjeux
de Deep learning ou encore dans le
caractère massif des Big Data ou
l'accélération de la vitesse de calcul
des processeurs que cela c'est plutôt
avéré une vérité et et même parfois
sous-estimé au vu des évolutions qu'elle
prend et notamment depuis ces derniers
temps la science nous montre que
l'avènement d'une super intelligence
dite il y a forte ne semble pas faire
partie de ces risques à court et moyen
terme et sur le long terme la réalité de
cette menace n'est pas certaine non plus
prophétisée par certains révélerait
plutôt du fantasme alors que des
technologies d'intelligence artificielle
restent soumises à une contrainte
d'acceptabilité sociale assez forte sous
l'effet de représentation souvent
catastrophique
et notamment amplifier dans la
littérature des sciences de la
science-fiction ou encore dans le cinéma
de façon donc plus réaliste
qu'elle menace sont réellement présentes
en phase de nous quel risque peuvent et
ou doivent être
identifiés anticipés maîtriser quels
impacts de Lia sur la place dominante et
monopolistique
occupé par quelques entreprises dans un
contexte d'économie globalisé de
plateforme quels impacts sur l'économie
et le marché du travail comment mettre
ses technologies au service de l'homme
et des valeurs humanistes quel principe
éthique juridique et politique doivent
encadrer ces technologies et cette
régulation doit-elle se placer au niveau
national européen international de
nombreuses questions donc se posent dans
cette science transdisciplinaire grâce
au dialogue croisé entre différentes
approches scientifiques technologiques
et l'Office qui est naturellement depuis
40 ans un espace de dialogue entre
parlementaires scientifiques et sociétés
et le lieu idoine pour pouvoir poser ces
questions y apporter des quelques
éléments de réponse et d'ailleurs je le
rappelle le bureau nos bureaux de
l'Assemblée nationale et du Sénat ont
d'ailleurs donc acté ces derniers jours
la poursuite des travaux de l'Office sur
ce sujet des nouveaux développements en
matière d'intelligence artificielle je
remercie d'ailleurs à ce titre le
président
Gérard Larcher qui est venu tout à
l'heure et qui a pu également complété
ce propos et donc je laisse ainsi la
parole à nos deux intervenants dans le
but d'ouvrir à la fois cette perspective
et puis cette controverse nous permettra
bien évidemment de pouvoir nous donner
aussi des pistes de réflexion à l'avenir
et notamment dans le cadre de ce futur
rapport monsieur peut-être je vous
laisse la parole pour introduire cette
controverse merci
beaucoup pour cette introduction qui
déjà éclaire les choses
nous allons en fait nous partager un peu
la question avec avec Laurence donc
l'intelligence artificielle est un
domaine scientifique
est une technologie qui a un effet
important sur la société et à cause de
son caractère diffusif en particulier
caractère qui la rend omniprésente dans
toutes les secteurs et tous les domaines
c'est donc un domaine sociotechnique
c'est important de l'appréhender comme
tel avec une approche pluridisciplinaire
mais il faut bien garder à l'esprit
qu'il ne s'agit pas d'un phénomène
naturel qu'on étudie c'est ce sont des
objets
conçus développés utilisés par des êtres
humains
et des applications diffusées par des
entreprises donc notre maîtrise en tant
que qu'être humain en tant que société
en tant que
gouvernement en tant que Parlement doit
être possible à mettre en œuvre il ne
s'agit pas juste de d'observer et de
dire à que pourrait-on faire comme
parfois on peut le croire
il ne s'agit pas non plus de croire un
certain nombre de
d'annonces à l'armiste justement que
Monsieur Henri a mentionné sur la super
intelligence qui
émergerait mystérieusement de ces
systèmes là et qui dépasseraient des
capacités humaines ce discours n'est pas
fondé scientifiquement
il est probablement motivé par d'autres
raisons parce qu'ils énoncent justement
pour avoir un effet
de crainte qui susciteraient de leur
donner confiance dans la maîtrise de ces
risques
or la maîtrise de ces risques devrait
revenir à la société et à ses
organisations
comme toutes les technologies donc
l'intelligence artificielle doit être
correctement maîtrisée et sa diffusion
régulée de manière adaptée
pour qu'elle soit en accord avec la loi
avec les valeurs démocratiques et les
droits humains
il est essentiel dans le comprendre donc
les mécanismes pour la démystifier et
les effets pour la maîtriser et
l'utiliser j'ai repris le titre du
rapport que Monsieur Henri a mentionné
de le rapport de l'OPEX qui date de mars
2017 mars 2017 c'est exactement l'année
où une nouvelle
architecture de système d'intelligence
artificielle est né développer chez
Google que qu'on appelle Transformers je
ne veux pas développer sur le détail
bien sûr mais cette nouvelle
architecture a permis une avancée
majeure dans le domaine du traitement
automatique de la langue naturelle
ceci a accéléré considérablement le
développement de système appelé système
d'intelligence artificielle générative
comme Jack GPT dont il a été question
alors il faut bien savoir que si on
parle de chat GPT et d'openhaya donc là
la société qui l'a qui l'a produit il y
a d'autres systèmes et en particulier il
y a un système qui s'appelle Bloom qui a
été développé en Europe grâce aux
calculateur Jean Zay donc il est
essentiel aussi d'avoir à l'esprit que
nous ne sommes pas en retard par rapport
à au développement de ces systèmes mais
qu'il nous faut bien sûr être avoir de
la motivation et mettre les moyens pour
en être des acteurs et non pas des
utilisateurs qui subissent les les bons
vouloir des sociétés qui les produisent
en Californie
alors si les recommandations du rapport
de l'OPEX de 2017 reste valide et il
faudrait d'ailleurs les mettre en oeuvre
de nouveau défi et de nouveaux enjeux
sont apparus quand même à cause de ces
systèmes le Comité National pilote
d'éthique du numérique dont nous sommes
membres ajustement publié hier
son avis sur les enjeux d'éthiques des
systèmes d'iat générative
l'une des questions alors je vais pas
développer l'ensemble des
recommandations du rapport et il y en a
22 10 sur la conception et 12 sur la
gouvernance mais je vais quand même
emprunter quelques-unes
une des questions
qui est une question fondamentale qui a
surgi à cause de ce système c'est la
question de la vérité alors il ne s'agit
pas d'une discussion philosophique sur
la vérité et qu'est-ce que la vérité
bien sûr mais il s'agit du fait que les
résultats les textes produits par ces
systèmes mélangent le vrai et le faux
à cause de leur nature statistique et
corrélative donc c'est par nature que
ces systèmes mélangent le vrai et le
faux or
l'accord commun sur des vérités
partagées et l'un des socles de la
cohésion de la société
on a vu ça par exemple avec la sauce sur
le Capitole
suivant l'élection de du Président il
est clair que un accord sur la valeur de
vérité des faits est essentiel or
justement ces systèmes menaces cela et
en cela c'est une menace c'est une
menace qu'il faut effectivement
maîtriser
un autre aspect qui d'ailleurs n'est pas
propre au seul système génératif c'est
l'absence de signification de sémantique
ces systèmes n'appréhendent pas la
signification des mots des textes qu'il
produisent et qu'il manipule ce sont les
humains qui font l'interprétation mais
donc ils peuvent produire des textes
sans aucune signification mais bien
construit convaincant d'une certaine
manière avec une certaine autorité il
faut donc considérer avec beaucoup de
précautions les productions de ces
systèmes et je ne parle pas des images
bien évidemment
il est donc nécessaire d'informer et de
former les utilisateurs assez limites et
à ses problèmes
je ne vais pas énumérer ici les
différentes questions les temps le temps
étant limité mais je vais mentionner
l'une des premières applications qui ont
été envisagées l'éducation
l'éducation est l'apprentissage de
manière générale et bien sûr un
cheminement un cheminement au cours
duquel le pédagogue et la prenant
interagissent pour que la prenant
maîtrise des raisonnements spécifiques
pour comprendre les connaissances
accueillir acquérir les savoir-faire il
ne s'agit pas d'enregistrer d'ingurgiter
des textes tout fait aussi imparfait
qu'il soit d'ailleurs justement
ou des conseils qui sont donnés avec une
certaine
autorité disons par des systèmes
artificiels mais sans évaluation de leur
qualité
et sans mention de leurs ressources
parce que de tels systèmes n'ont pas la
capacité d'ident ifier les sources
justement à cause de la nature
corrélative il faudrait les plonger dans
des systèmes supplémentaires il faut
donc savoir et pouvoir étudier
l'effet sur le développement cognitif
des jeunes élèves et sur le véritable la
véritable acquisition des savoirs à
travers l'utilisation de ces systèmes
avant de s'y lancer
enfin en termes de régulation les
systèmes d'intelligence artificielle
générative doivent être considérées
comme des systèmes à haut risque au sens
de la réglementation européenne en cours
de construction
et en cours de négociation dans le
trilogue pourquoi ce sont des systèmes à
haut risque parce que quel que soit
l'utilisation que vous en faites dans un
deuxième dans un deuxième stade il
contiennent de manière inhérente cette
question que j'ai mentionnée justement
sur la vérité et une interaction simple
avec le système tchatchepetty par
exemple vous montrera que effectivement
indépendamment du domaine d'application
il y a là un sujet de Fond la
responsabilité des acteurs donc tout au
long de la chaîne de valeur
des modèles de fondation jusqu'au
développement des applications
spécifiques dans des secteurs donnés
doivent ces responsabilités doivent être
identifiés il ne s'agit pas de laisser
échapper un acteur à sa responsabilité
et la raison est très simple focalisez
la responsabilité uniquement sur ceux
qui développent le système sur le marché
dans tel ou telle application les rangs
prisonniers des de ceux qui produisent
les modèles de fondation à partir
desquels ils ont construit leur
application et qu'ils ne maîtrise pas
les rendre responsables signifie
finalement les faire se retourner contre
un acteur qui lui n'a aucune
responsabilité qui ne s'est engagée à
rien et qui peut donc leur imposer ces
conditions donc ce n'est pas un service
à rendre en particulier à l'industrie
européenne qui va utiliser ces modèles
c'est pour ça que la responsabilité doit
être bien tout au long de la chaîne de
valeur enfin sur les questions de
réglementation il est clair que à cause
du fait que ces systèmes sont construits
à partir de calcul sur de grandes
quantités de données qui sont sur
internet ils utilisent effectivement des
données personnelles ils utilisent des
données qui rentrent dans la propriété
intellectuelle de telle ou tel
producteur donc il y a des questions
importantes sur l'application du
règlement sur la protection des données
personnelles il y a des questions
importantes sur la propriété
intellectuelle et les droits voisins qui
devraient être examinés en fonction de
l'existence de cette nouvelle
technologie et de savoir correctement
les appliquer
je vais m'arrêter là pour l'introduction
et je vous remercie de m'avoir écouté
bonjour merci pour cette invitation donc
je vais essayer de compléter puisqu'on a
travaillé ensemble sur ce rapport
du Comité National pilote des titres du
numérique qui a été pérennisé par le
président Macron en mars donc il y aura
un nouveau comité à partir de septembre
et je serai
extrêmement intéressant de réutiliser ou
en tout cas d'être en connaissance de
des avis produits des deux côtés je
pense
la controverse existe évidemment puisque
tout un chacun un père de son père de
son travail ou alors pense que la
machine va devenir super intelligente et
de l'autre côté on sait que et en plus
cette ce numérique consomme beaucoup
d'énergie voilà donc la controverse elle
existe et de l'autre côté qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire avec du numérique
beaucoup de choses on peut trouver des
nouveaux vaccins on va peut-être
effectivement aussi pour la transition
écologique trouver des nouvelles façons
de mieux consommer donc on est bien sur
les tensions fondamentales il existe des
tensions à la fois
éthiques anthropologie sur les
connaissances il y a énormément en fait
de menaces à différents niveaux
alors je vais essayer d'en dresser un
peu le portrait
tout d'abord
il est important de comprendre que entre
admiration et peur les utilisateurs sont
des consommateurs ils ne comprennent pas
les mécanismes derrière cette
technologie il est décideur rarement
donc nous sommes devant une progression
exponentielle comme vous l'avez dit deux
technologies qui sont
connus maîtrisés par très peu il y a là
une menace d'équilibre
si demain nous sommes devant encore plus
de consommation de ces objets nous
risquons d'avoir une société qui va
créer des modèles complexes qui sera
incapable de les remettre à jour de les
recréer avec une perte de savoir-faire
très fort donc il y a un problème
d'éducation fondamentale sur ces outils
non seulement pour en faire des
experts en technologie mais également
pour former les citoyens à l'utilisation
de ces outils
parce que en ce moment que ce soit donc
un enfant pour faire ses devoirs ou un
adulte pour faire sa lettre de
motivation ou n'importe quel de vos amis
concitoyens je pense vous avez tous
entendu parler de quelqu'un qui utilise
tchatche j'ai pété donc moi j'étais ravi
de voir arriver de chat GPT dans la
société en me disant enfin on va
considérer ce sujet réellement il quitte
le laboratoires l'intelligence
artificielle n'est plus un fait d'une
petite communauté mais devient un fait
majeur
il y a derrière cela un dessin de
certains notamment des géants du
numérique qui est une prise de pouvoir
c'est un problème géopolitique très
grave dans le sens où si je vais très
vite à cette première vision globale
comme l'a dit Raja un système dit à
génératif c'est deux choses c'est un
modèle de fondation qu'on a calculé sur
des milliards de données qui est sur
étagères et c'est un système que je mets
en oeuvre pour faire de la traduction
pour faire un agent conversationnel pour
faire tout un tas de choses et peut-être
excellentes mais il s'agit quand même de
comprendre que le modèle que je prends
sur étagère a été fait par d'autres
personnes qui contient un certain nombre
de données que nous maîtrise pas qui ne
soit pas transparentes il y a des hyper
paramètres dans ces modèles qui ne sont
pas non plus transparents et qui ont un
impact énorme sur
le résultat donc cette opacité des
modèles doit être un premier souhait on
doit absolument réguler pour obliger
ceux qui sont en train de faire ces
systèmes dont Bloom on a entendu parler
quel est l'intérêt de Bloom c'est qu'il
est justement open ouvert plus
transparent on sait avec quoi il est
entraîné combien de nombre de langues
les hypersparamètres et la recherche
peut s'en emparer et faire des tests
avec vous voyez et l'industrie aussi
donc c'est un vrai sujet les autres sont
opaques pour vous donner une idée de
l'opacité et bien il y a un facteur qui
s'appelle la température qui a une
espèce de facteur qui est finalement un
peu au hasard puisque au lieu de
produire la meilleure solution le
système va vous produire le premier mot
la séquence de mots probable après le
prompte que vous donnez il va vous
produire parmi les haines possibles
alors on se rend pas compte ça veut dire
que si j'interroge deux fois de suite le
même système il peut me répondre par
deux phrases différentes
et là je vais dire il est intelligent
mais non nous avons un paramètre qui
permet d'aller chercher un deuxième
possible qui le rend un peu humain
peut-être alors vous voyez ça va très
vite la projection qu'on fait sur ces
systèmes
d'autre part fondamentalement comment
sont créés ces systèmes ils sont créés à
partir d'une hypothèse linguistique qui
est la suivante
on va prendre la phrase je prends
l'aspect langage on la réduit à un
ensemble d'entités minimales qui ne sont
pas des mots ça peut être en dessous du
mot c'est un nombre de caractères et on
appelle ça des token et c'est ça qu'on
va apprendre on va apprendre à modéliser
des token qui ne sont même pas des mots
qui peuvent être des morfèmes peut-être
mais pas sûr et on les représente sous
forme de vecteurs le vecteur contenant
des indications de plein de contextes
dans lequel j'ai vu ces mots
l'hypothèse distributionnelle derrière
tout cela c'est que les entités
appelaient token qui se trouvent dans
des contextes d'apparition similaire
tant à avoir des sens similaires
c'est pas forcément vrai donc on a vu
des hallucinations les vaches qui
pondaient des œufs faut trouver tout un
tas de coquilles amusantes parce que
cette machine ne comprend rien elle ne
fait que des statistiques
lié à des normes contextes mais on peut
aussi s'apercevoir que à partir de
certaines tailles de données que l'on
donne à ce modèle il est capable d'avoir
des comportements émergents dans un plus
une interaction avec le système Serge
l'agent qu'on va stationner pété va
questionner j'ai pété 3.5 qui est le
modèle de fondation plusieurs fois et il
y a un historique qui est pris en compte
de token qui fait que il va affiner sa
requête et il a l'impression que la
machine s'adapte à lui encore une fois
si on vendait cela plus transparent il y
aurait moins de confusion et moins une
distinction plus forte entre ce qui est
machinique et ce qui est de l'humain
donc il est essentiel aujourd'hui que
ses capacités soient plus ouvertes
l'apprentissage de ces machines n'a rien
à voir avec notre apprentissage un
enfant il met sa main sur le feu hop il
la retire il sait que ça brûle la
machine elle a besoin d'énormément de
cas pour arriver à trouver des règles
automatiques il y a les trois types
d'apprentissage dans le chat GPT il y a
le cœur de fondation qui travaille sur
l'auto-apprentissage c'est-à-dire par
exemple je cherche à produire le mot le
plus probable derrière une séquence de
mots ou bien dans un autre il y a deux
sortes de Transformers
qui est le système qui arrive en 2017 et
qui bouscule un peu ce qu'on faisait
jusqu'à présent il y a un autre une
autre façon d'apprendre qui est j'enlève
un mot de la phrase et je cherche à
prédire ce mot c'est par le manque que
j'essaie de comprendre les relations
entre les mots c'est extrêmement
intéressant mais ça va pas très loin il
y a aucune abstraction dans tout cela
donc il faut vraiment expliquer mieux
pour que on puisse comprendre que ces
systèmes engrange des qualités mais que
ils n'ont pas du tout un raisonnement
humain absolument pas et pourtant
lorsque je projette
Jean tropomorphisme ces machines je leur
prête des capacités de type ils ont des
connaissances
ils ont peut-être des affects il me
parle en disant je
et ils ont peut-être des qualités
morales parce que la simulation est
telle que on peut se demander lorsqu'on
ne connaît pas donc il est essentiel
pour moi que dans l'éducation on montre
très vite à une démystification mais
technique sans aller sur des formules
mathématiques mais sur de la
compréhension des liens entre ces hyper
paramètres et ce qu'on perçoit de la
machine et ça c'est fondamental
ne pas le faire c'est amené à une
société de dépendance deuxième raison
pour l'industrie la majorité de ces
larges bordel L&M on parle sur les
modèles de fondation sur le langage sont
faits avec des données anglo-saxonnes
viennent donc de
Wikipédia en anglais de scroller sur
Internet et majoritairement à plus de
80%, c'est de l'anglais or la machine
nous parle en français les plongements
des tokens sont faits dans toutes les
langues en parallèle au niveau recherche
on ne sait pas quelle est l'influence
d'une langue sur une autre est-ce que
alors on sait qu'il y en a tu en as une
puisque une langue peut dotée qui a peu
de données et bien lorsqu'on l'utilise
un autre corpus à côté on va enrichir
les performances de cette langue peu
dotée ayant peu de données pour
l'apprentissage donc il y a une
influence par famille de langue par
contexte similaire mais on est donc
devant quelque chose de très apprenti
sorcier donc j'ai dit que le
consommateur le citoyen ne comprenait
pas du tout ce qui se passait les
ingénieurs les chercheurs
comprennent les mécanismes mais nous
comprennent pas ce que la machine peut
produire elle peut produire des
émergences de comportements qui vont
sidérer les gens c'est ça cet exaltation
qu'on entend même des chercheurs vont
dire c'est incroyable ce que ça arrive
de faire afin mais de la même façon la
machine peut être totalement incohérente
et avoir des hallucinations dont
quelques petits bijoux vont s'en donner
dans ce rapport je vous encourage de
lire il est donc important de comprendre
que cette machine qui n'a ni conscience
ni émotion ni attention peut se
comporter à la manière de comme un
humain et quels vont être nos croyances
quelles vont être notre coévolution face
à ces machines ce sont des ujugés ces
sujets extrêmement intéressants sur
lequel il faut absolument travailler ce
problème de multilinguisme c'est de la
géopolitique donc j'ai beaucoup
travaillé avec le ministère de la
Culture dernièrement il y a un gros
projet qui est en train d'être monté
pour dans le château de
villers-le-bretêtre faire une plateforme
sur le
traitement automatique de la langue qui
soit européenne dans lequel on va
travailler sur ces modèles multilingues
pour le langage donc il y a là un effort
réel du gouvernement qui me semble être
intéressant à regarder nous avons besoin
de faire la recherche c'est d'ailleurs
le premier des la première des
préconisations que nous donnons dans ce
rapport sur le sur la gouvernance c'est
de dire il nous faut une entité
souveraine
capable de travailler sur la formation
et la recherche sur ces différents
sujets qui arrivent beaucoup trop vite
dans la société et sur lequel nous
manquons en fait de
recherche et de et de résultats mais les
gars femme aussi manquent de résultats
donc eux-mêmes ne sont pas en qualité
non plus de percevoir ce qu'il va se
produire donc nous mettons sur le marché
des objets qui ont une certaine
autonomie
qui n'est pas magique
donc il faut absolument se rendre compte
que le citoyen pour lui il y a des
conséquences dans l'éducation dans le
travail donc il faut absolument
accompagner donc je dirais que à l'heure
actuelle cette menace fait qu'il faut
absolument travailler sur la une loi de
Lia et l'Europe fait bien de le faire et
tout ce qu'on entend en géopolitique
montre qu'on a fait bien le faire parce
que tout le monde vient essayer de
s'emparer de cela aussi
[Musique]
de personnes remplacées parce que pour
l'instant on peut pas dire ces systèmes
soient à la hauteur d'un humain du tout
mais par contre pour faire une tâche ils
peuvent être meilleurs que nous
donc il faut bien comprendre que le
bouleversement est énorme dans le
travail il faut l'anticiper et nous
avons pas beaucoup abordé ce sujet là
dans cette concertation nous sommes
allés comme le disait Raja sur la vérité
le maintien des distinctions grâce à des
filigranes qui sont aussi des sujets de
recherche le fait même des filigranes
dans le texte puisque je vous ai dit
chaque token c'est un vecteur dans ce
vecteur on peut mettre des paramètres
cachés un filigramme c'est quelque chose
qu'on ne voit pas mais par contre un
outil peut aider l'enseignant pour
savoir que la dissertation a été faite
par un ensemble de d'apport alors c'est
vrai ce qui dit Raja essentiellement ce
modèle construit de la façon suivante il
prend des token qui sont tout petits et
donc ils combinent il fait du LEGO
donc qui construit des unités minimales
qui vont peut-être être proche d'un
texte ou peut-être être non pas une
invention mais une combinaison de ces
entités et c'est nous qui allons trouver
que c'est très inventif voire
intéressant surprenant ou tout à fait
absurde
donc c'est vraiment intéressant de
d'aller beaucoup plus loin sur la
compréhension de ce système si j'avais
un message à faire passer c'est celui
que tant que on sera non on ne sera pas
capable d'expliquer simplement
ces hyper paramètres quelques
comportements du système on ouvrira pas
le capot de la voiture et donc on sera
pas capable devant les gafam de dire
c'est ce point-là qu'il faut donner
comme transparent c'est cette
information dont j'ai besoin pour le
grand public quand on dit par exemple il
faut réguler et mettre sur le marché
sous des conditions sur les hauts
risques pour la loi sur l'IA nous avons
en recherche l'habitude de mettre des
modèles sur GitHub disponible pour la
communauté en open source donc là aussi
il y a un danger et là aussi il faut que
ces objets soient mis à disposition avec
des mécanismes de mutualisation des
bonnes pratiques et j'ai beaucoup aimé
dans vos discours avant ces idées de
mutualisation je pense que face à des
machines qui arrivent avec une
intelligence qui n'a pas rien à voir
avec ce que nous sommes mais qui est
extrêmement intéressante pour aller
découvrir de nouveaux potentiels et en
même temps qui peut nous amener à être
époustouflé devant des situations et
peut-être en dépendantes il est
essentiel que nous travaillons sur les
objectifs en mutualisant nos
intelligences donc pour les entreprises
mutualiser les bonnes et les mauvaises
pratiques sur des plateformes par
vertical sur chacun pour les transports
pour l'agriculture pour je ne sais quel
objectif de la même façon pour
l'éducation il faut mutualiser quand
j'entends les professeurs qui ne
travaillent pas assez ensemble l'arrivée
de cette ces outils plus
socio-technique comme l'a dit Raja c'est
vraiment essentiel de comprendre ça ce
ne sont pas des outils ce sont des
outils socio-techniques cela veut dire
autre chose et ils peuvent avoir une
certaine autonomie de vous donner des
informations et peut-être que on ne
résistera pas à suivre les décisions de
la machine donc c'est vrai pour la
médecine c'est vrai pour l'éducation
c'est vrai à tout niveau donc la menace
est énorme leadership est en train de
prendre les États-Unis
cachés dans ces modèles de fondation si
on va pas chercher parce que l'entrée
des entreprises que je vois souvent me
disent ah bah on va aller chercher on
commence à l'utiliser tout ça doucement
puisqu'il y a pas encore de
réglementation
donc je pense que c'est notre devoir
d'aller éclairer ce que vous avez dit
sur l'état de là et sur les pièges qui
sont réels à travers le déploiement de
CJA génératives on aura il y a beaucoup
d'autres sujets la manipulation étant un
des sujets majeurs sur lequel je
travaille c'est-à-dire le nudge et si
vous regardez bien
ce social dilemma je sais pas si vous
aviez vu ce film
par des gafams repenties
qui disait Facebook Google etc ça
s'appelle en français derrière les
écrans de fumée
ils énoncent que ils ont été
incroyablement forts ils sont sortis du
système ils en ont quand même profité et
ils expliquent qu'ils faisaient pour
beaucoup ils allaient prendre des cours
à Chicago à l'École d'économie
comportementaliste pour savoir mieux
comment on manipule les individus qui
sont dans les réseaux sociaux pour qu'il
reste plus longtemps pour leur affaire
acheter plus de choses et pour les
rendre dépendants de ces machines
l'école de Chicago a produit un nombre
incalculable de prix Nobel ces derniers
temps système un système 2 prise de
décision toleur le nudge l'incitation à
faire c'est encore l'école de Chicago
regardez un petit peu l'influence que ça
pour les gafams leurs ingénieurs l'ont
plus haut niveau vont prendre des cours
là-bas reviennent et mettre ça en oeuvre
dans des systèmes opaques non
transparents sur lequel nous sommes les
cobayes
si vous utilisez chaque GPT actuellement
vos données vont là-bas ils vont être
utilisés peut-être que maintenant ils
auront plus de données en français que
nous-mêmes
donc il y a un effort de guerre à faire
et j'espère que l'Office peut être un
moyen de catalyser cet effort de guerre
que je n'arrive pas à faire sur les
normes nous sommes très il y a très peu
d'industriels qui sont présents les
personnes qui sont là sont des experts
avec derrière eux les gafams et les
béaté etc il se pourrait que demain les
normes les standards sur l'IA soit fait
par les Américains et les Chinois pour
notre marché européen merci
merci à vous je suppose qu'au vu des
deux interventions cela doit susciter un
certain nombre de questions que je vais
prendre il y a deux questions madame je
vous
bonjour moi je voudrais revenir sur les
différentes controverses alors d'abord
ce qui apparaît c'est l'extrême
complexité des questions l'extrême
importance également et l'intérêt
d'office pour éclairer les politiques
mais également les transitions et les
changements qui vont être nécessaires et
les résistances en même temps vous avez
été nombreux à le signaler de l'opinion
publique donc moi je demanderai quelle
accompagnement au changement comment
l'Office aide-t-il aide-t-il d'ailleurs
au changement et donc quel
accompagnement au changement alors à la
fois pour apporter un appui aux
politiques et pour éclairer l'opinion
publique
oui bonjour à toutes et à tous une
question peut-être sur sur les émotions
a priori ce qui différencie l'humain du
robot c'est l'émotion le sentiment j'ai
appris il y a pas longtemps qu'il y
avait un intelligence générative qui
s'appelle projet X Amber qui permet de
modeler l'intelligence
générative sur le modèle d'une personne
décédée une personne proche de sa
famille ou de ses amis et qui permet
ensuite d'échanger avec
alors la question et la suivante est-ce
qu'il existe un risque pour que des
intelligences génératives puissent créer
ou en tout cas donner l'illusion
d'émettre une capacité d'émotion ou de
sentiments et quels entrer les
conséquences à votre avis
je peux répondre sur les émotions parce
que c'est mon sujet de recherche parce
que je m'intéresse à la détection des
émotions dans la voix et le langage avec
des
LLM là avec les larges j'engagements non
pas la partie générative mais la partie
encoder celle dont j'ai parlé les token
avec les plongements sémantique c'est ça
qu'on utilise effectivement pendant très
longtemps dans la linguistique on a eu
un problème qui était le sens
l'interprétation vous savez pas comment
faire c'était compliqué de faire des
ontologies autour du sens et c'est grand
modèle de langage viennent faire quelque
chose d'assez brillant par rapport à ce
qu'on faisait jusqu'à présent mais sans
conscience aucune ok sans absolument de
morale sans conscience pour revenir sur
les émotions on travaille sur la
détection des émotions en France et en
au niveau international depuis
j'étais là au début depuis 2000 moi je
travaille sur ces sujets donc
effectivement je peux détecter dans la
voie de quelqu'un s'il est en colère
joyeux si la peur j'ai fait beaucoup de
travaux pour montrer que en fait on est
souvent avec des émotions mélangées
c'est à dire qu'on peut être à la fois
positif et négatif je donne un exemple
vous appelez au SAMU pour quelqu'un qui
est en train de mourir devant vous et
vous dites Valérie et la personne
vraiment on arrive et là vous êtes ah
merci et dans ma voix j'ai à la fois
quelque chose de soulagement et en même
temps j'ai une anxiété forte j'ai pas
dit qu'on était tous les jours comme ça
mais on peut avoir des émotions très
mélangées ces machines sont à des années
lumière de détecter ça puisque dans le
contexte on voit bien que c'est
compliqué de comprendre le pourquoi il y
aurait ces mélanges donc nous sommes
devant une simplification énorme en ce
moment qui serait détestable d'utiliser
pour l'éducation ou pour autre chose
mais qui peut être intéressant lorsque
par exemple je m'intéresse à suivre
quelqu'un qui a une pathologie genre de
particulière mental ou qui est en
détresse et qui et pour lequel j'adapte
le système à savoir
je peux adapter à savoir et comprendre
les modulations et l'aider donc c'est
pas des sujets qu'il faut rejeter en
bloc c'est des sujets qu'il faut
comprendre pour lesquels on a besoin de
faire attention l'autre sujet dont vous
avez parlé c'est son les dettes bots
c'est-à-dire je prends des données le
premier à faire ça c'est ma Microsoft
macropos des poses un brevet il y a
quelques années sur je sais à partir de
dialogue sur la voie de quelqu'un
dialogue écrit puis après je mets de la
synthèse ou de la reconnaissance de la
parole donc je peux le faire aura l'oral
ou écrit d'accord je suis capable de
faire parler quelqu'un
qui n'est plus là alors le meilleur
exemple qui est très bien si on a fait
reparler le général de Gaulle
vous avez entendu parler de ça donc on a
repris sa voix on s'est simulé
parfaitement la voix d'accord et d'autre
part si je prends donc là on a là on n'a
pas cherché à modifier le discours on a
même été chercher le discours là où il
était auprès de quoi vous savez où il
était ce discours pas en Angleterre qui
a aucune trace pas en France mais en
Allemagne ce sont les registres nazis
qui ont bien noté tout ce qui avait dit
le général de Gaulle pendant ce cet
échange et ils ont réussi à le
reconstituer
pour revenir à ce qu'on peut faire sur
le langage de quelqu'un et bien on prend
beaucoup de données et puis on peut
nourrir un système et effectivement la
régularité on va c'est ça l'intérêt de
ces là l'engagement là c'est que je les
prends sur étagère je les optimise sur
un certain encore plus qui peut être
petit et j'obtiens des performances
assez importantes c'est cette faculté
qui fait que toutes l'économie est à
vide de cela puisque il y a un gain
énorme et donc on est capable de faire
ça mais qu'est-ce que ça veut dire non
on en a parlé en fait on avait fait un
premier rapport qui s'appelait les
enjeux qu'on va stationner en jeu
d'éthique
et qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça veut
dire que si je prends une image
générative c'est un puzzle c'est-à-dire
je fais par exemple reparler mon père
avec peut-être sa voix mais peut-être
quelque chose qui n'a jamais dit donc
c'est pas digne de faire parler
quelqu'un avec des mots qu'il n'aurait
jamais dit on peut arriver à des
extrêmes
maintenant je peux juste recopier enfin
je rejouais ce qu'il a dit à travers ces
systèmes et l'avoir toujours dans ma
poche j'ai même été dans des conférences
où on parle de ça l'immortalité
numérique entre la recopie du cerveau il
y a aussi j'ai mon papa dans mon
portable et je lui demande des conseils
je ne sais pas comment la société peut
vivre cela les premiers qu'on voit
utiliser ça ce sont les Japonais qui
font des l'utilisation cela pour la
ritualisation autour du deuil autour du
deuil ils ont 40 jours où on évoque la
personne décédée à travers des photos
des vidéos etc et c'est une sorte
d'hommage et bien maintenant ils
essaient de le faire avec des robots on
projette la tête du défunt et on peut le
faire parler grâce à ces systèmes
répliqua qui a été fait en Russie qui
est arrivé aux États-Unis et que mes
étudiants ont testé c'est l'idée à la
base de répliquer quelqu'un qui était
décédé c'est comme ça que la jeune Russe
la fait et ensuite elle dit voilà ça
peut être votre ami votre petit ami
enfin il y a là des dérives évidentes
je nous ne sommes pas très fan de cela
en Occident en Chine et au Japon ils
sont très friands sans doute en faisant
un pack de côté assez immédiat sur c'est
des objets bon il parle c'est pas grave
de toute façon le fleuve à une âme donc
bon l'objet il parle pas grave on sait
gérer ils savent plus peut-être mieux
gérer que nous et nous on est un peu
dans cette confusion on est choqué
d'avoir arrivé ces objets en même temps
nous ce qu'on avait mis dans le rapport
l'idée c'est pas d'interdire mais c'est
collectivement encore une fois il faut
se poser cette question de est-ce qu'on
souhaite des objets comme cela si vous
regardez ce qu'on a fait pour les avis
on avait fait aussi une un questionnaire
qui a été une centaine de personnes ont
répondu sur ces aspects là aussi en
disant c'est souhaitable c'est pas
souhaitable c'est pas évident et quand
j'avais été assez conférences avec des
psychologues et des psychiatres et des
sociologues le psychiatre disait le
rituel de deuil est important on va donc
changer de rituel si on apporte ces
objets parce aura du mal à s'en défaire
Black Mirror le montre en SF mais par
contre le social disait c'est un outil
génial les voies de l'au-delà arrive
dans le téléphone et là moi je j'ai
l'impression que nous sommes plus
rationnel donc arrivé à mettre des
émotions dans ses machines c'est quelque
chose qui va forcément arriver d'autant
plus que Yann Lequin parle et dit que à
travers ces systèmes on va pouvoir avoir
des émergences émotionnelles que demain
il est capable de monter de faire un
système différent des IA générative la
prochaine version et qui sera avec des
émotions comme un chien leur vrai ou un
chat ce qui n'est pas vrai encore une
fois nous sommes devant un monde
d'experts qui nous fait miroiter des
choses par pour des points de vue
économiques et marketing il faut
absolument s'en méfier et je pense qu'il
est utile d'en parler de façon carré en
remettant les choses au clair merci
pour la première question
oui effectivement pour la première
question c'est plus adressé directement
à l'office puisqu'il est question aussi
de son rôle sur sur ce sujet je pense
qu'il faut pas confondre les rôles de
chacun
des rôles d'expertise
des rôles d'analyse dans l'évaluation et
dans la future prise de décision ce
n'est pas ce qui est pas tout à fait la
même chose c'est trois séquences sont
sont sont à fait tout à fait différente
et l'Office se situe au milieu
c'est-à-dire dans dans la séquence de
l'analyse et de l'évaluation
pour ça je crois véritablement que
ce que l'on fait ce matin finalement
réponds répond aussi je l'espère en
partie à un certain nombre de vos
interrogations c'est à dire on le voit
bien en particulier vous l'avez dit sur
lia je crois que le
l'intérêt de la maîtrise c'est
d'approfondir la connaissance la
connaissance profonde pour savoir où
est-ce qu'on régule et donc pour cela il
faut que ceux qui seront les régulateurs
et qui poseront les conditions de la
régulation sachent aussi blé et et où
être véritablement efficace pour avoir
cette chaîne de valeur qui qui sera
garantie parce que effectivement c'est
ce sont des questions complètement
sociales qui qui sont qui sont derrière
et pour lesquels les utilisateur doit
absolument avoir une une connaissance
approfondie et donc véritablement voilà
je crois que on se situe dans dans cette
phase
d'évaluation et d'analyse et de
compréhension
encore une fois je pense que on doit
faire preuve aussi d'efficacité dans les
travaux que nous menons pour les futurs
prises de décision qui sont faites non
pas simplement pour les membres de
l'office mais pour l'ensemble du
Parlement et des organismes d'autorité
publique extérieure et donc pour cela
on comprend bien aussi
que ce soit effectivement pour l'enjeu
de l'intelligence artificielle
effectivement avec ce
nerf de la guerre qui va qui va
véritablement se situer dans la
compréhension des résultats même si on
comprend bien que
aujourd'hui on maîtrise absolument pas
effectivement le la compréhension des
résultats en tout cas effectivement
on en est à une pour l'instant une phase
epsilonesque par rapport à l'étendue de
la production de ce que représente
l'intelligence artificielle sauf si
effectivement vous vous voulez compléter
mon propos ce qui sera la bienvenue
de mettre des filigranes d'expiscabilité
des systèmes de voilà le là où il y a
vraiment un peut-être un manque dans ce
qu'on fait ici par rapport aux angles
sachons c'est la compréhension de la
nécessité de mettre en œuvre une entité
souveraine
[Musique]
on a du mal à mélanger les deux coeurs
il me semble que sur ces sujets
d'intelligence artificielle il est
vraiment nécessaire d'avoir des réelles
entités sûrement européennes mais au
moins elle est monté en France
allez-y je vous en prie un mot de
complément encore faut-il bien être au
carré sur les déclarations de liens
d'intérêt
les déclarations de liens d'intérêt en
tout cas on mélange expert et
société civile pour avoir une expertise
plus réaliste là on pêche souvent en
France dans les déclarations de
l'intérêt mais j'ai pas dit société
civile
Sonia la propreté également s'exprimer
oui je suis une réflexion il me semble
qu'on est vraiment dans un cadre
d'expérimentation en vie réelle et qu'il
faut traiter cette situation comme telle
on se pose la question quand on doit
faire une injection quand on doit
provoquer la gestion parce que c'est un
acte physique de faire une
expérimentation avec tout une série de
protocoles et sur cette dimension là qui
est une dimension qui n'est pas invasive
au sens physique du terme mais qui est
invasive pour le coup au sens
psychologique intellectuel et des
conséquences sur la société il me semble
qu'il nous manque un cadre réglementaire
ou une extension de du cadre qu'on
accorde à l'expérimentation
j'allais dire médicale donc dans
laquelle avec laquelle on procède
habituellement parce que c'est un vrai
sujet en fait toute cette dimension là
n'est pas du tout prise en compte dans
le cadre de l'expérimentation
scientifique voilà et
c'est ce qui s'est en train de se passer
ça signifie derrière des coordes de
suivi des protocoles de suivi et là pour
le coup niveau international parce que
on n'aura pas de conclusion si on ne si
on ne sait pas se mettre d'accord sur ce
qu'on regarde quels sont les hypothèses
de départ pendant combien de temps on
regarde et quelle est la conclusion de
nos hypothèses à hypothèse principale et
hypothèse et hypothèse secondaire le
deuxième sujet c'est que l'information
elle est numérique et je pense qu'on a
quand même un vrai sujet par rapport à
ça tout ce qui alimente c'est du
numérique et le numérique évidemment
c'est pas un truc tout à fait
ancien c'est à dire que toute
l'information qui est antérieure à
l'effervation à l'effervescence du
numérique et toute la circulation
l'excès de données numériques est plutôt
correspond plutôt à des données récentes
semi récente ça signifie que le poids
finalement de la formation de ce qui est
très ancien par rapport à ce qui est
très récent et est faible quelque part
hormis celles et ceux qui alimentent la
toile entre guillemets sur des sujets
plus anciens et ça pose quand même la
question du poids de la science par
exemple et de la vérité scientifique
parce que ce qui était avéré est fondé
comme étant une vérité incontournable
scientifique il y a une cinquantaine
d'années par les controverses et par
comment dire ce qu'on considère comme
étant les avis qui en réalité ne sont
pas des avis mais je pense aux platistes
et à tous ces sujets là à un poids quand
même important et donc peut entraîner
comme conséquence
comment dire une déstabilisation de la
science et de la vérité scientifique et
mon troisième point c'est que face à ça
il faut quand même développer l'humain
et ça veut dire la pédagogie et
l'éducation et là pour le coup ce sont
de gros moyens à mettre en oeuvre parce
que le sens critique le libre choix le
choix éclairé tout ça ça passe par la
pédagogie parce qu'on doit considérer
ces outils comme étant des outils pas
comme étant des éléments qui modifient
et la pensée et la société
et d'ailleurs on voit que tchat GBT
devient aussi un des outils
utilisés par pour alimenter les théories
du complot ce qui montre justement les
limites en termes d'éthique mais vous je
vais vous laisser la parole oui parce
que vous avez tout à fait raison Madame
il y a il y a ces trois aspects et bien
d'autres
effectivement la nous sommes des cobayes
de l'expérimentation à l'échelle
planétaire qui a été lancée par open
Airi sans demander l'autorisation à
personne et sans contrôle le seul
contrôle c'est celui qu'ils exercent
dans la mise sur le à disposition de
tout le monde de ce système et de la
manière dont il distille le c'est
capacités et la manière dont il contrôle
ces paramètres donc ceci est une sorte
de coup d'état numérique si vous voulez
qui qui est quand même dont il faut
effectivement prendre conscience vous
avez raison et sur lequel il faut réagir
or effectivement c'est plutôt l'effet de
sidération à cause de
des performances du système qui
prédominent et les premiers je me
souviens très bien de derrière son des
médias et à différents niveaux quand
c'est système ont été diffusés et c'est
pour ça qu'il est absolument essentiel
de démystifier ces systèmes de voir
cette réflexion pluridisciplinaire
d'éclairer le débat mais il faut aller
plus loin il faut aller plus loin parce
que il n'est plus question de subir
finalement sans aucun
mécanisme de de protection et du
contrôle au niveau international
finalement le bon vouloir de ces gaffes
et c'est pour ça que la question sur la
première question sur les différents
rôles des institutions de mon point de
vue peut-être posé la le rapport de
Monsieur degane et Madame Gillot émis
des recommandations et ont été mises en
application que partiellement il y a de
mon point de vue dans le rôle de l'OPEX
dans le rôle de l'exécutif un lieu à
trouver pour que les préconisations et
les recommandations de de l'Office soit
effectivement discuté prise en compte
même si elles ne sont pas impliquées et
qu'ils ne le soient pas à juste titre
disons pas pas parce que simplement
elles sont ignorées
un autre problème et effectivement le
fait que la qualité des informations va
être impacté par ces systèmes parce que
aujourd'hui par exemple
a arrêté les concepteurs ont arrêté son
sur l'entraînement c'est-à-dire son
alimentation par les données en
septembre 2021 donc il ignore tout de ce
qui s'est passé depuis 2021 mais la
nouvelle version va tenir compte de
nouvelles informations de nouvelles
données sur Internet y compris celles
qui ont été produites par des systèmes
génératif qui effectivement produisent
le vrai et le faux et donc aussi des
théories
farfelues mais dangereuses et là on va
effectivement avoir une augmentation sur
internet de donner qui sont de mauvaise
qualité et ça sera un contrôlable parce
que ça plus bien là et plus ça sera
produit et donc il va il faut aller
au-delà de la pédagogie il me semble il
faut aller vers une réflexion collective
avec les bons acteurs
et pas uniquement des recherches mais
aussi une réflexion sur l'action qu'il
convient de mener pour faire face à ces
problèmes la question des émotions je ne
vais pas y revenir n'est pas des
moindres
en fait on voit aussi que sur la toile
ce que ceux qui en profitent beaucoup
sont les
utilisateurs malveillants pour propager
des fake news et repropagés grâce à des
chats GPT qui sont là qui vont générer
plein de données on sait qu'en Russie il
y a ça on sait que il y a beaucoup de
pays qui sont en guerre qui essaient de
déstabiliser nos démocraties donc c'est
pas je crois qu'on peut lever le
fallait dire à ce qu'il y a un chat un
chat donc
cela nécessite effectivement ce que j'ai
dit un
effort de guerre de recherche allié à de
la politique je sais pas c'est pas les
chercheurs qui font la politique bien
entendu mais il est évident que elle
peut les recherches qu'on peut faire
peuvent nourrir des idées et faire
comprendre mieux et après peut-être que
la solution c'est
des chercheurs disaient ça c'est
l'anarchie c'est-à-dire que tout le
monde m'est très n'importe quoi sur
cette toile qui la rendrait complètement
absurde puisque sur ces données que
volontairement on met donc faire des
systèmes qui en boucle envoie des infos
c'est assez facile on peut tous le faire
on ne le fait pas parce qu'on estime que
c'est une
ineptie mais si il y a que des gens qui
envoient des informations négatives on
peut aussi tuer la toile
après peut-être pas que nous en France
mais en tout cas on pourrait imaginer un
dessin qui est de se dire je fais un
raz-de-marée et hop là on va passer à
autre chose surtout que tout ça consomme
que plus il y a de données plus je vais
avoir besoin d'Atta Santa que nous avons
dans ce rapport expliqué qu'il faut
mesurer le point l'empreinte en fait de
dépenses d'énergie de la requête à ces
gros modèles de le faire ce gros modèle
de tous les composants nécessaires pour
utiliser ces modèles et c'est loin
d'être négligeable et loin d'être
possible à faire il y a une très bonne
étude de Stanford qui montre parmi les
deux dix plus grands modèles ce qu'on
peut évaluer et si on doit mouillé parce
que c'est pas transparent donc c'est un
c'est un des points sur lequel il faut
appuyer pour obliger les les grands
géants du géants du numérique ouvrir
plus si on a des réglementations au
niveau des mesures de
dépenses d'énergie on peut appuyer pour
avoir plus d'informations sur ces grands
systèmes on savait pas dire que ça
résout tout problème il faut également
qu'on en fasse en Europe et en France
monolingue multilingue qu'on comprenne
bien ce qu'on peut utiliser pour que on
dynamise aussi notre économie donc
en fait donc nous on est donc la société
française énergies nucléaire donc
nous on est donc la société française
parce que notre mission c'est de
permettre à tous ceux ou celles qui
s'intéressent à l'énergie nucléaire de
développer leur connaissance voilà c'est
notre mission donc on est allé dans
chaque GPT on a posé trois quatre
questions on s'est rendu compte que
c'était pas fiable
voilà et puis après on s'est dit mais
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire est-ce qu'on
peut l'entraîner ce qu'il faut voilà on
était un peu perturbé mais en fait après
on s'est posé la question de comment les
gens en fait cherchent de l'information
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui ils cherchent
vraiment de l'information via ces
systèmes parce que quand vous dites moi
ça me touche quand vous dites il y a
plein de on va voir n'importe quoi sur
Internet on a déjà n'importe quoi sur
Internet moi j'ai quand je suis arrivée
en poste c'était après Fukushima c'était
une catastrophe internet ça Fukushima
et puis peu à peu ça se régule parce
qu'on sait qu'on doit aller voir
Wikipédia ça se régule parce qu'on
cherche des textes où il y a des sources
quand vous dites la recherche des
sources pour moi c'est vrai que je suis
peut-être éduqué pour ça mais je lis pas
un texte sur lesquels il y a pas de
source enfin voilà je refuse ce texte
voilà donc est-ce que c'est mécanisme
régulatoire que finalement on a mis en
place quand internet est arrivé où tout
était possible on va pas avoir ces mêmes
mécanismes de mise en place en utilisant
ces nouveaux outils si je pense que
c'est une bonne idée et pour l'éducation
c'est une bonne idée c'est-à-dire en
fait interdire à l'école c'est pas
possible parce qu'il utilise toute façon
donc il faut utiliser il faut apprendre
aux enfants deux choses top down
up c'est à dire je sais faire à mémoire
en comprenant comment je fais un plan
comment j'élabore la succession de mes
idées et comment je vais sortir une
conclusion à partir des idées que j'ai
mis en avant en surçant avec des
références mais la même chose à l'envers
j'ai un texte tout fait qui vient de
chat GPT et je cherche quels sont les
idées majeures et j'essaie de comprendre
qui les a dit et je déconstruis tout ça
pour arriver à comprendre peut-être
l'inépsie qui est dedans je pense que
c'est essentiel d'avoir ces deux Top
Down bottom up à chaque fois et qu'on
travaille là-dessus et j'encourage tous
les adultes à le faire aussi ce qui
nécessite un temps non négligeable et
tous les gens que j'entends dire c'est
très intéressant utiliser c'est paresse
parce que par manque de temps et donc on
va aller très vite vers ça et donc j'ai
peur que effectivement par paresse ou
par facilité nous soyons beaucoup à
utiliser tchat j'ai pété alors s'il vous
plaît dans votre travail quand vous
faites quelque chose d'éminemment
important n'utilisez pas on aura bientôt
des textes bio fait par les humains
bien sûr ces paroles
ça plein de sagesse nous allons pouvoir
clôturer cette matinée de rencontre et
sur ces quatre controverses
scientifiques d'actualité en remerciant
évidemment l'ensemble de des
intervenants pour toujours la qualité
avec laquelle il nous faut l'honneur de
de nous donner ces éléments si
importants pour la prise de décision
politique
et donc je vous invite également donc il
y a un cocktail déjeunatoire qui se
trouve au pavillon de l'Orangerie et qui
nous attend
maintenant pour que l'on puisse conclure
et on va on va indiquer oui
effectivement le sens de la de la visite
pour pouvoir y accéder et donc on va
pouvoir conclure cette deuxième journée
d'anniversaire de l'Office avec toujours
l'immense plaisir que l'on a de recevoir
des intervenants de encore une fois de
qualité qui nous permettent de bien
comprendre que que l'ensemble des enjeux
scientifiques et de et de connaissances
nous permettent aussi justement d'être
sur la table des décisions et de pouvoir
influencer sur les régulations et ce
dans tous les domaines que ce soit dans
l'énergie dans la production agricole
dans le stockage du CO2 évidemment dans
l'intelligence artificielle mais sur de
nombreux sujets sur lesquels
l'Office tient évidemment à à avoir
cette rigueur qui est également la vôtre
au sein de vos laboratoires ou de vos
organismes de recherche un grand merci à
vous et évidemment que continue à à
faire prévaloir la science au sein de
l'office et surtout la science en
général merci à vous